THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE --
THE SENATOR ALLEN WHOSE CODE
SHARING THIS WITH ME IS AN A R.
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS AT THE MOMENT
WE'RE NOT SURE HOW LONG THAT'S
LASTING.
HOWEVER --
WE WILL HAVE --
STAFF MEMBERS HERE.
AND I THINK IT'S BEST THAT WE
JUST START AND RECOGNIZE THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COME HERE --
TO BOTH LISTEN AND PRESENT.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME YOU ALL TO THE JOINT
HEARING IN THE ASSEMBLY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE.
AND THE SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE --
I'M BILL QUIRK CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL COMMITTEE --
TODAY WILL DISCUSS THE STATE'S
EFFORT AND PROTECTING PEOPLE AND
THE ENVIRONMENT FROM TOXIC
MATERIALS.
IN PRODUCTS THROUGH IMPLEMENTING
A REPROCESSED GREEN CHEMISTRY
PROGRAM.
EACH YEAR TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CHEMICALS ARE MANUFACTURED IN --
IMPORTED INTO THE UNITED STATES.
AS WE ALL KNOW CHEMICAL PRODUCTS
CAN HAVE IMPORTANT FUNCTIONS
THAT IMPROVE OUR EVERYDAY LIVES.
HOWEVER WE DON'T KNOW MUCH WHAT
WE HOWEVER WHAT WE DON'T KNOW
MUCH ABOUT IS HOW THESE
SUBSTANCES.
CAN EFFECT --
YOU MEN AN ECO SYSTEM HEALTH.
THIS BRINGS JUST GREEN CHEMISTRY
GREEN CHEMISTRY IS A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO ENVIRONMENTAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTION
[inaudible]
AND IT'S YOU KNOW IN THERE WAS A
TIME [inaudible]
WHEN -- THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE MIGHT
VOTE ON BANNING THE CHEMICAL OR
STANDING IN ANY --
SUBSTANCE IN WHICH THERE'S A
TRACE OF THE CHEMICAL.
IT'S MUCH BETTER IN FACT TO DO
TWO THINGS ONE IS TO USE THE
BEST SCIENCE.
AND THE OTHER IS TO LOOK AT IF
YOU WERE TO BAN THAT CHEMICAL
AND WHAT WILL HAPPEN AND ARE
THEIR SUBSTITUTES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY SAFER --
IS THIS --
OR IT CAN WE DO WITHOUT THIS.
CHEMICAL OR ANY SUBSTITUTE FOR
IT ALL TOGETHER OR IS THERE IS A
SUBSTITUTE AND THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE.
IN MY MIND AND WHAT GREEN
CHEMISTRY DOES.
SO IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATURE ENACTED
TWO BILLS A. B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
NINE AND SB. FIVE OH NINE TO
ESTABLISH A GREEN CHEMISTRY
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA.
TODAY WERE FOCUSING ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A. B. --
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE THE
AUTHORS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MIKE
FOR YOUR AND JARED HOFFMAN
CLEARLY STATED THEIR INTENT WITH
THIS BILL WAS PAID A
COMPREHENSIVE.
SCIENCE BASED AND DELIBERATE
APPROACH TO CHEMICALS POLICY. TO
PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROLLER.
WITH CLEAR AUTHORITY TO REGULATE
HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS IN ALL
PRODUCTS WITH FEW EXCEPTIONS.
I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED AGAIN GREEN
CHEMISTRY BELLS WAS NO FISCAL
ANALYSIS COMPLETED FOR EITHER
VEIL.
MAKING THE FUTURE COSTS OF
IMPLEMENTATION ON CERTAIN.
IN FACT WERE NOT SURE TODAY THAT
WE HAVE FUNDED THIS AT THE RIGHT
LEVEL --
GIVEN THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES AND CONTROL.
IS FACING FISCAL CHALLENGES WE
WILL BE DISCUSSING THEIR BUDGET.
AND A JOINT HEARING LATER THIS
MONTH THE PURPOSE OF A HEARING
TWO DAYS TO ASSESS WHETHER THE
GAME CHEMISTRY PROGRAM HAS
ACCOMPLISHED THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE LAST TEN AND
A HALF YEARS.
AND DETERMINE HOW WE CAN INSURE
ITS GREATEST SUCCESS IN THE
FUTURE -- SO
I WOULD LIKE --
TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
VICE CHAIR OF SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY --
SENATOR PATRICIA BATES IS WITH
THIS AND THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REBEKAH POWER KAHAN --
NEW MEMBER OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS.
ARE COMMITTEE IS ALSO HERE --
AND I'D LIKE TO WELL.
THEY ARE THE ONLY MEMBERS HERE
AT THE MOMENT BEFORE WE GET
STARTED -- I
DO WANNA THANK.
OF THE SENATE --
FOR I DOING THIS COMMITTEE
JOINTLY SO WE CAN START WITH THE
SAME SET OF FACTS --
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
WITNESSES WE HAVE HERE TODAY AND
THERE WILL BE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END OF THIS --
SO.
I SELL IT NOW CENTER BAD THAT
ALLEN IS HERE HE'S GOTTEN OUT OF
HIS OTHER MEETING.
AND AGAIN I REALLY WANT TO THANK
HIM -- FOR
HAVING THIS IS A JOINT HEARING
SO AS A SAID WE CAN OPERATE FROM
THE SAME SET OF FACTS.
IT'S MY HOPE.
THAT IF THERE'S A BILL PASSED IN
SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY OR
AN ASSEMBLY --
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS.
THAT.
WHEN IT REACHES THE OTHER
COMMITTEE THAT WILL BE BECAUSE
WE WORK FROM THE SAME SET OF
FACTS AND VALUES?
THAT IN FACT --
THE AUTHORS OF WHAT PASSED IN
ONE HOUSE WILL NOT HAVE TO SEE
RADICAL CHANGES IN THE NEXT ONE
THAT'S OUR HOPE.
DOESN'T ALWAYS HAPPEN BUT THAT'S
MY HOPE --
SO SENATOR ALLEN WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO SIT MAKE A FEW OPENING
REMARKS THANK YOU CHAIRED QUIRK
AND I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WE WERE.
THE THE CAUCUS IS STILL IN A
DEEP.
DISCUSSION ABOUT ANOTHER
IMPORTANT TOPIC OF P. JEANNIE
PATADA -- AN
ISSUE I'M SURE YOU'VE SPENT SOME
TIME THINKING ABOUT BUT I DO
APPRECIATE YOU GREAT DEAL I
APPRECIATE THE MEETING THAT WE
HAD NOT TOO LONG AGO TALKING
ABOUT SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT WILL BE CORNY TOGETHER.
ARE AND ON THE ISSUE OF OF YOU
KNOW YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE
LEGISLATIVE HISTORY OF THIS
ISSUE.
AND THE LEADERSHIP OF PREVIOUS
MEMBERS WHO HAVE WHO REALLY
UNDERSTOOD THE FACT THAT --
THAT THAT --
THAT IF CALIFORNIANS YOU KNOW
WANT TO MAINTAIN THEIR STANDARD
OF LIVING THEY THEY THEY THEY
CERTAINLY WANT TO HAVE THEIR
SANTA LIVING IMPROVED BY MODERN
CHEMISTRY.
BUT WITHOUT EXPOSURE TO
DANGEROUS.
HI DANGEROUS CHEMICALS.
AND SO WHEN THIS IS HOW WE WE
GREW THIS CONCEPT OF GREEN
CHEMISTRY IN.
AND THIS IS A AN IDEA WHEREBY WE
LOOK AT THE GOODS THAT PEOPLE
USE EVERY DAY.
WE FIND DANGERS IN THOSE GOODS
THAT CAN BE REMEDIED.
AND WE IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES TO
IMPROVE THOSE PRODUCTS TO
MINIMIZE RISKS AND THAT'S AT THE
THE CORE OF OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE AND IT WAS TO THAT IN
THE TEN YEARS AGO THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE PASSED TO LAWS.
BOTH ME SOME IN THE SENATE SIDES
THAT ESTABLISHED THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM WITHIN THE DTS
SEE THAT WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
TODAY.
AND SO THE IDEA IS TO USE THE
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE IN AN
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT PROCESS.
TO MAKE APPROPRIATE REGULATORY
DECISIONS.
AND WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING FROM
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
WORKING TO LEARN ABOUT HOW THE
FIRST TEN YEARS HAVE GONE WE
WANNA KNOW WHAT'S WORKING WELL
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT IS IT WE WE
WE CERTAINLY WANT AND ALSO KNOW
WHERE STAKEHOLDERS FEEL AS
THOUGH THE PROGRAM.
HAS BENEFITED CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS WHERE
IT'S FALLEN SHORT.
AND AND AND YOU KNOW LOOK TO TO
TO TO TO SEE WHAT SORT OF
LEGISLATIVE REMEDIES MAY BE
NECESSARY.
MOVIE FOR BUT I DO APPRECIATE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE SO
NUMBER QUIRK AND AND ALL THE WAY
HARD WORK OF THE STAFF ON BOTH.
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE SIDES
ARE HELPING TO PUT THIS TOGETHER
I HOPE IS THE OTHER MEETING AND
WE'LL HAVE SOME MORE OF OUR A
SENATORS COME OVER [inaudible]
YEAH.
YES OF COURSE THE ASSEMBLY --
STAFF MEMBERS OF COURSE WROTE MY
COMMENTS THAT I GAVE EARLIER AND
OF COURSE THEY DIDN'T MENTION
THE GREAT WORK THEY'VE DONE.
BUT SHANNON THE KIDNEY AND TRASH
TALKER MY TWO STAFF MEMBERS HAVE
BROUGHT THIS TOGETHER AND I WANT
TO THANK THEM VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
AND YOU PROBABLY WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF.
WELL WE GET THE WHOLE THE WHOLE
TEAM ACTUALLY WANT TO HAVE TALK
WHATEVER HIS WORK ON THIS --
WE HONESTLY THAT THE ASSEMBLY
TOOK THE LEAD THIS TIME BUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO BE A PART OF IT
THINKING.
MENTION THAT.
I GUESS YOU GUYS --
ABOUT ERIC WALTERS OUR SCIENCE
FILE PHOTO OKAY SO ERIC WALTERS
A SCIENCE VALLEY DEBT YOU DON'T
HAVE YOUR MICROPHONE ON BUT
THAT'S OUR I DON'T REPEATED.
ITSELF THANK YOU ERIC FOR BEING
HERE --
SCIENCE FELLAS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR PROCESS MY
SCIENCE FELLOW.
XIAO FINE GUY IS --
IN THE FRONT ROW OVER THERE WITH
OUR OTHER --
STAFF MEMBER --
PAGE BROCA.
ALL RIGHT A SENATOR BATES --
DO YOU HAVE ANY OPENING REMARKS
FACED IT AGAIN CENTER IS VICE
CHAIR OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER KAHAN.
AND THEN WE'VE BEEN JOINED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAURA FRIEDMAN
WHO IS CHAIR OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE --
WHICH ALSO DEALS WITH RELATED
ISSUES SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DO YOU.
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT.
SO THE FIRST PERSON UP TODAY
THIS DOCTOR MARTIN MULL THE HELL.
GENERAL PARTNER OF SAFER MADE SO
YOU CAN COME UP AND JUST SIT IN
FRONT OF WHAT ONE OF THE
MICROPHONES.
GENERAL PARTNER SAFER MADE A
VENTURE CAPITAL FIRM AND CO
FOUNDER OF EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
EMERITUS OF THE BERKELEY CENTER
FOR GREEN CHEMISTRY. TO EXPLAIN
TO US WHAT GREEN CHEMISTRY IS
AND HOW IT CAN MAKE PRODUCTS
SAFER.
AYE FORTUNATELY HAD A CHANCE.
TO TALK WITH DOCTOR MORE OF A
MOLEHILL EARLIER SO HE STARTED
OUT FRESNO.
GOT A PHD IN CHEMISTRY --
LEARNED --
THEN SET UP THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL IN BERKELEY AND THEN
PEOPLE ACTUALLY CAME TO HIM AND
SAID.
YOU KNOW WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
INVEST IN SAFER PRODUCTS.
AND HE ENDED UP DOING SOMETHING
HERE I NEVER EXPECTED HE WOULD
DO -- WHICH
IS -- TO
BECOME A VENTURE CAPITALIST SO --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND PLEASE
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN QUIRK
CHAIRMAN ALAN.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR GIVING
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU.
TODAY ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUPPORTING GREEN CHEMISTRY.
I'M A CHEMIST AND I KNOW AND
LOVE THINKING ABOUT THE FACT
THAT EVERYTHING WE CAN TOUCH SEE
SMELL INTERACT WITH IT'S MADE
OUT OF MOLECULES.
SINCE LEARNING ABOUT GREEN
CHEMISTRY WILL GRADUATE SCHOOL
I'VE BEEN COMMITTED TO
ACCELERATING THE DEVELOPMENT AND
ADOPTION OF SAY FOR CHEMISTRY
FIRST AT THE UC BERKELEY CENTER
FOR GREEN CHEMISTRY AND NOW IT'S
SAFER MADE.
JUST.
JUST A SECOND WE'RE HAVING SOME
TROUBLE WITH THE MICROPHONES.
MAYBE I PUSHED THE WRONG BUT NOT
SURE [inaudible]
CHECK.
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE IF IT WORKS
NOW.
EXCELLENT HOW'S THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY FINE [inaudible]
PERFECT.
I RECOGNIZE THE EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM MAY NOT SHARE MY LOVE OF
CHEMISTRY.
REGARDLESS I HOPE TO CONVINCE
YOU THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
TIME TO ACCELERATE THE GROWING
MOVEMENT TOWARD INHERENTLY SAFER
CHEMISTRY.
HEALTHIER PRODUCTS AND HEALTHIER
WORKPLACES IN CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR BUSINESSES SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES WE ALREADY HAVE THE
BUILDING BLOCKS WE NEED TO USHER
IN A NEW ERA OF SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS.
THE DEMAND FOR SAFER PRODUCTS IS
PART OF AN YOUR REVERSIBLE
SOCIAL TREND.
IT'S PART OF OUR MODERN AGE
SHIFT TOWARDS HEALTHIER LIVING
MORE SECURE LIVES.
OTHER SIMILAR DEVELOPMENTS HAVE
BEEN THINGS LIKE.
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF SMOKING
FOCUSING ON CHILD SAFETY.
FOCUSING ON HEALTH AND NUTRITION.
THESE WELLNESS TRENDS ARE NOT
NEW ST WE ARE ENTERING A NEW
PHASE OF DEVELOPMENT AND HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY IN FRONT OF US TODAY.
FOR MANY CONSUMERS.
THE MATERIAL CHEMICAL SAFETY OF
PRODUCTS HAS BECOME A NEW
DIMENSION OF THEIR PURCHASING
DECISIONS.
THIS CHANGE IN PREFERENCE IS
RESHAPING ENTIRE PRODUCT
CATEGORIES AND SECTORS.
A GROWING NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
IDENTIFY WITH LIFESTYLES OF
HEALTH AND SUSTAINABILITY.
AND HEALTH IS THEIR BIGGEST
CONCERN.
SO SIGNIFICANT PRODUCT PRODUCT
CATEGORIES HAVE BEEN TRANSFORMED
INCLUDING FOOD PERSONAL CARE
CLEANING PRODUCTS AND
INCREASINGLY APPAREL IN
BUILDINGS.
THINK ABOUT IT PEOPLE START WITH
THE THINGS THEY CONSUME
LITERALLY PUT IN THEIR BODY AND
THEN THEY START THINKING ABOUT
THE PRODUCTS THEY PUT ON THEIR
SKIN BRING INTO THEIR HOME AND
SHARE WITH THEIR FAMILY.
MANY CONSUMERS BECOME SENSITIZED
TO THESE ISSUES WHEN THEY BEGIN
TO HAVE FAMILIES WHEN THEY BEGIN
TO HAVE CHILDREN.
THIS IS A TIME WHERE PEOPLE MAKE
ARE OPEN TO NEW INFORMATION AND
MAKE NEW DECISIONS ABOUT
SWITCHING BRANDS AND CREATING
NEW HABITS.
PEOPLE'S CONCERN ABOUT EXPOSURE.
TO CHEMICALS --
AND THE RISKS THEY PRESENT TO
THEIR FAMILIES TRANSLATES INTO A
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR DEMAND FOR
SAFER PRODUCTS AND THE
CHEMISTRY'S THAT ARE NEEDED TO
MAKE THEM.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE ORGANIC
FOOD MOVEMENT AS A GOOD PROXY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE FACT THAT
ORGANIC FOOD HIS GROWN 12% YEAR
AFTER YEAR.
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR TO
TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN DURING
THAT AMOUNT OF TIME.
THERE WERE ACQUISITIONS OF
COMPANIES PUBLICLY DISCLOSED
ABOUT HALF OF ALL THE ANY WORK
OVER FORTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN NEW WEALTH CREATED FROM THE
ORGANIC FOOD MOVEMENT.
SIMILARLY AND YOU CAN SEE ON THE
TABLE BELOW.
COMPANIES THAT ARE LEADING --
WITH MATH ARE ALL PERFORMING
QUITE WELL.
SO WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR OUR
HEARING HERE TODAY.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU THAT
TEN YEARS AGO IN CALIFORNIA
LAUNCH THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
INITIATIVE TO ADVANCE THE SAFER
USE OF CHEMICALS THERE WAS AS
THERE IS TODAY AND DESIRE FOR
HEALTHIER CHEMISTRY IN OUR
PRODUCTS AND WORKPLACES?
AT THAT TIME MIKE WILSON AND
OTHERS IDENTIFIED THREE GAPS
THAT WE'RE LIMITING THE ADOPTION
OF SAFER CHEMISTRY.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS TAKE A
MOMENT AND REMEMBER THOSE GAPS?
BECAUSE EACH OF THOSE GAPS HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN.
PROVEN TO BE AN OPPORTUNITY WERE
RELATIVELY SMALL INVESTMENTS AND
EITHER CAPITAL OR IN YOUR CASE
IN ACTIONS.
CAN HAVE AN OUTSIZED INFLUENCE
ON THE ADOPTION OF SAFER
CHEMISTRY IN OUR SOCIETY.
SO START WITH THE FIRST GAP.
THE NEED FOR INFORMATION.
PROPERLY FUNCTIONING MARKETS
REQUIRE THE FREE FLOW OF BOTH
GOOD AND INFORMATION.
WHAT WE HAVE ABUNDANT ACCESS TO
PRODUCTS OF ALL SORT FROM
BUILDING MATERIALS TO TOYS AND
COSMETICS WE STILL HAVE ALMOST
NO INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT GOES
INTO THEM?
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT THIS IGNORANCE OFTEN GOES
BEYOND THE CONSUMER. TO ACTUALLY
THE BRANDS AND RETAILERS
THEMSELVES WHO STRUGGLE TO
IDENTIFY AND MANAGE POTENTIAL
CHEMICALS OF CONCERN.
IN THE PAST TEN YEARS MANY
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
SECURE INGREDIENT LEVEL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PRODUCTS
THEY SELL.
DESPITE RELATIVELY WEAK
REGULATORY MANDATES WE'RE SEEING
BRANDS AND RETAILERS CREATING
THEIR OWN CHEMICAL TRANSPARENCY
IN DISCLOSURE POLICIES THE GO
FAR BEYOND ANY REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS.
I'VE INCLUDED IN THE TESTIMONY
BELOW EXAMPLES OF JUST.
KIND OF THE LARGEST RETAILERS OF
WHAT THEY'VE DONE IN THE LAST
YEAR AND THE LIST GOES ON AND ON
INITIATIVES LIKE MINE THE STORE.
HAVE HELPED CREATE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CREATE A
SENSE OF COMPETITION AMONG
RETAILERS TO IMPROVE THEIR
GRADES ON THE ON THE SCORING
SYSTEM AND ALSO GIVE SHOPPERS A
SENSE OF SECURITY.
THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING PEOPLE
WITH THE SAFEST PRODUCTS.
WELL THESE VOLUNTARY DISCLOSURES
AND RESTRICTIONS BY BRANDS ARE A
GOOD START.
MORE MUST BE DONE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION DIRECTLY TO THE
CONSUMER.
THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT I CAN
ORDER A TWENTY FOR MY DAUGHTER
ONLINE TRACK THE PACKAGE DOWN TO
THE MINUTE IT LEFT THE WAREHOUSE.
AND GET A TEXT MESSAGE WHEN IT
ARRIVES AT MY DOOR.
BUT ONCE I HAVE THE TOY IN HAND
I WILL HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
MATERIALS DIES PLASTICIZERS OR
OTHER CHEMICALS ARE IN IT.
HAVE YOU SEEN THAT INGREDIENT
LIST ON A TOY A PHD IN CHEMISTRY
AND YET I STILL DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION I NEED TO CHOOSE THE
SAFEST PRODUCT FOR MY THREE YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER.
WE ARE OFTEN TOLD THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS A TRADE SECRET OR
THAT IT SHOULD NOT BE DISCLOSED
BECAUSE CONSUMERS WILL NOT KNOW
HOW TO INTERPRET THE INFORMATION.
THE REALITY IS.
THAT BOTH ARGUMENTS COULD HAVE
BEEN MADE FOR FOOD PACKAGING AS
WELL.
BUT WE'VE SEEN THAT ACCESS TO
THIS SORT OF INFORMATION CREATES
A WHOLE ECOSYSTEM OF EDUCATION
AND COMPETITION WERE GOVERNMENT
BRANDS AND CONSUMER EDUCATION
ALL WORK TO CONTINUE TO RAISE
THE BAR NUTRITION.
AND COULD DO THE SAME.
ON THE HEALTH OF THE CHEMICALS
WE FIND OUR PRODUCTS.
IN THE ABSENCE OF GOOD CHEMICAL
INFORMATION WE WILL CONTINUE TO
RELY ON BANDS AND POORLY DEFINED
CLAIMS THAT MAY BE MISLEADING TO
THE CONSUMER WHICH BRINGS US TO
THE SECOND GAP THAT WAS
IDENTIFIED.
IN ADDITION TO GREATER CHEMICAL
TRANSPARENCY IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE HAVE.
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS THAT ENSURE
THE CONSUMERS ARE GETTING USEFUL
INFORMATION.
LET'S START BY THINKING BACK TO
THE EXAMPLE OF THE TOY THAT I
BOUGHT.
JUST FOR MY DAUGHTER IF IT'S A
QUOTE UNQUOTE GREEN TôI THE
PACKAGE MAY TELL ME SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT ISN'T IN THE TOY WITH
ASSURANCES LIKE BPA FREE ORGANIC
NATURAL OR CHEMICAL FREE MY
FAVORITE.
THESE LABELS DO LITTLE TO ASSURE
ME.
THAT THE TôI IS SOMETHING I
WANT TO GIVE TO MY CHILD.
AS THE CHEMIST I KNOW IF I CAN
HOLD IN MY HAND IT'S MADE FROM
CHEMICALS.
BUT WHAT THEY ARE I CAN'T BE
SURE OF IF THE LABEL SAYS
NATURAL THAT MADE TELL ME
SOMETHING ABOUT THE SOURCE OF
RAW MATERIALS USED TO
MANUFACTURE THE TOY BUT IT
DOESN'T GUARANTEE THEIR SAFETY
OR THAT THEY WERE PROCESS
WITHOUT HARMING PEOPLE OR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
EVEN THE TERM ORGANIC A THIRD
PARTY CERTIFICATION TELLS ME
LITTLE MORE THAN HOW THE RAW
MATERIALS USUALLY COTTON.
OR IN THE CASE OF TOWARDS OUR
CLOTHES WERE GROWN IT DOESN'T
TELL ME ANYTHING ABOUT THE DICE
FINISHES OR OTHER CHEMICALS
ADDED TO MAKE THE FINAL PRODUCT.
SIMILARLY MANY PRODUCTS LABELED
BPA FREE DON'T MENTION THE
CHEMICALS THAT ARE IN THE TOY
THE COULD BE JUST AS HARMFUL AS
THE ONES THAT WERE LEFT OUT.
INSTEAD OF BPA IT MAY HAVE BEEN
MADE WITH AND BE PS WHICH
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN COULD BE JUST
AS DANGEROUS.
THERE'S NO WAY OF KNOWING THESE
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTION HAPPEN
MORE OFTEN THAN WE'D LIKE.
BECAUSE WHEN WE BàN SPECIFIC
CHEMICALS THE EASIEST SOLUTIONS
ARE DROPPING SUBSTITUTES WHICH
ARE LIKELY COMPOUNDS WITH
SIMILAR STRUCTURES THE COULD
HAVE SIMILAR HEALTH CONSEQUENCES.
SAFER MADE WAS CREATED TO ENSURE
THAT HAS IT IS THAT AS HAZARDOUS
CHEMICALS ARE PHASED OUT.
THERE WILL BE A PIPELINE A
VIABLE SAFER ALTERNATIVES.
IT'S SAFER MADE WE'VE DEVELOP
STRATEGIES TO IDENTIFY.
IN SUPPORT INHERENTLY SAFER
CHEMICALS AND PRODUCTS.
FIRST WE TAKE A FUNCTIONAL
APPROACH TO IDENTIFYING SAFER
CHEMICALS.
A FUNCTIONAL APPROACH REFOCUSES
CHEMICAL MANAGEMENT FROM THE
RISKS OF A SINGLE CHEMICAL TO
VALUE WAITING ALL THE AVAILABLE
OPTIONS TO DELIVER A PARTICULAR
FUNCTION.
THIS FUNCTIONAL APPROACH COMES
FROM A SIMPLE RECOGNITION.
PEOPLE DON'T BUY CHEMICALS.
THEY PAY FOR FUNCTION.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT PERFLUORINATED
SURFACTANTS THAT ARE KNOWN TO
PERSIST IN THE ENVIRONMENT FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS.
BUT THEY DO LIKE HAVING OVER
BREATHABLE RAIN JACKET TO KEEP
THEM DRY.
A FUNCTIONAL APPROACH ENCOURAGES
MATERIALS AND SYSTEM LEVEL
CHANGE THAT PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS BOTH THE
CHEMICAL CHALLENGES AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL SUSTAINABILITY IN
GOALS.
INCLUDING THE REDUCTION OF
ENERGY AND WATER USE.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE DO IT
SAFER MADE TO AVOID REGRETTABLE
SUBSTITUTION IS TAKE A CLASS
APPROACH.
WE LOOK AT CHEMICALS OF CONCERN
AS MEMBERS OF A LARGER CHEMICAL
FAMILIES WHICH ARE LIKELY TO
SHARE SOME OF THE SAME.
PHYSICAL AND CHEMICAL PROPERTIES
CHEMICALS THAT FALL INTO KNOWN
CLASSES OF CONCERN LIKE THIS
FINALS ARE PERFORMED AIDED
SUBSTANCES SHOULD HAVE TO PASS A
HIGHER BAR FOR SAFETY BEFORE
BEING USED.
GROUPING CHEMICALS BY CLASS
BASED ON CHEMICAL STRUCTURE IN
PHYSICAL PROPERTIES IS SOMETHING
THAT CHEMISTS OFTEN DO QUICKLY
TO EVALUATE.
A NEW CHEMICAL GROUPING
CHEMICALS OF CONCERN BY CLASS
HELPS US MAKE SENSE OF THE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF CHEMICALS THAT
WERE MENTIONED IN THE EARLIER
REMARKS.
AND ALLOWS US TO AVOID WASTING
TIME.
THIS BRINGS ME TO MY FINAL AREA
OF COMMON.
WHICH IS HOW DO WE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE LEADING
IN EDUCATION AND INNOVATION.
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY BOTH CREATE
DEMAND.
NOW WE WILL SHIFT OUR ATTENTION
TO THE WAYS THAT WE CAN GROW THE
SUPPLY OF C. FOR CHEMICALS AND
PRODUCTS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THE CALIFORNIA
ALREADY HAS THE EDUCATIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INDUSTRIES AN
INNOVATION ECOSYSTEM TO SUPPORT
AND ACCELERATE THE INNOVATION OF
SAFER CHEMISTRY.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE TOP
SCHOOLS FOR STUDYING CHEMISTRY
IN THE NATION INCLUDING THREE OF
THE TOP.
FIVE ACCORDING TO THE US NEWS
AND WORLD REPORT.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO WITH THREE
BILLION DOLLAR CHEMICAL INDUSTRY
AS WELL AS MANY LEADING BRANDS
SOME OF WHICH ARE IN THE ROOM.
CALIFORNIA ATTRACTS MORE VENTURE
CAPITAL FUNDING THAN ALL OTHER
STATES --
COMBINED REGULARLY ATTRACTING
OVER HALF OF ALL VENTURE DOLLARS
TO BACK EARLY STAGE STARTUPS
ACROSS SECTORS.
CLEARLY WE HAVE ALL THE BUILDING
BLOCKS NEEDED TO LEAD THE NATION
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CHEMISTRY THAT'S
BETTER FOR HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
NATURAL WORLD.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE TO FOCUS MORE OF
THESE RESOURCES ON GREEN
CHEMISTRY THE BIGNESS TECHNOLOGY
TEN OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE TO
IMPROVE HUMAN HEALTH.
AND THE NATURAL WORLD. TO CREATE
SAFER MATERIALS AND CONSUMER
PRODUCTS INNOVATORS
ENTREPRENEURS AND INVESTORS
PRODUCT DEVELOPERS MARKETERS
RESEARCHERS AND SCIENTISTS WILL
BE HELPED BY.
THE FOLLOWING THINGS.
A COMMON LANGUAGE TO ADEQUATELY
DESCRIBE THE INNOVATION
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN EACH SECTOR.
A CLEAR SIGNAL FROM GOVERNMENT
INDUSTRY AND NGOS ABOUT WHAT
INNOVATION IS NEEDED.
AND PARTNERSHIP MODELS THAT
ILLUSTRATE HOW PREFERRED
CHEMISTRIES AND PRODUCTS CAN BE
BROUGHT TO MARKET.
AS AN INVESTOR IN SAFER
CHEMISTRY MATERIALS I OFTEN FIND
MYSELF DESCRIBING THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE NEED FOR SAFER
CHEMICALS.
FINDING THE RIGHT LEVEL FOR THIS
CONVERSATION IS IMPORTANT.
THE BEST WAY TO MAKE THE NEED
FOR SAFER CHEMISTRY INNOVATION
CLEAR IS TO FOCUS ON SPECIFIC
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES IN
EACH SECTOR OF THE ECONOMY.
THE CHEMISTRY IN PERFORMANCE
REQUIREMENTS ARE VASTLY
DIFFERENT FOR MATERIALS USED IN
CLOTHING COMPARED WITH SAY
SHAMPOO OR BUILDING PRODUCTS ALL
TOO OFTEN WE START AT THE END
AND FIND THE BAD ACTOR CHEMICALS.
WE NEED TO START AT THE
BEGINNING AND FIGURE OUT TO FILL
AND HOW DO WE FILL THEM IN A
BETTER WAY.
THE BEST WAY.
WITHIN IN EACH INDUSTRY YOU WILL
FIND THAT THERE ARE KNOWN
CHEMICALS OF CONCERN THAT
CURRENTLY PROVIDE IMPORTANT IN
USE OUR MANUFACTURING FUNCTIONS.
AND THAT THE COMPANIES MAKING
THOSE PRODUCTS WOULD BE WILLING
TO CHANGE IF.
COMPETITIVE ALTERNATIVES WERE
AVAILABLE.
THE IDENTIFICATION OF PRIORITY
PRODUCTS BY DTS SEE TAKES
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN THIS
DIRECTION.
BUT MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE. TO
IDENTIFY AND PRIDE CAST SPECIFIC
INNOVATION NEEDS TO A MUCH
BROADER AUDIENCE AND BROADER
INDUSTRY SECTORS [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT WE'VE DECIDED AS A BENEFIT
WITH THOSE NEEDS ARE IT TAKES A
CLEAR SIGNAL?
BECAUSE THERE ARE LOTS OF
RESOURCES AND TIME NEEDED TO
INNOVATE.
AND TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF TO
HAVE THE BEST WAY TO UNLOCK THE
CREATIVE POTENTIAL.
THAT IS BEHIND GREEN CHEMISTRY
IT'S INTERESTING TO FOCUS ON
SOMETHING THAT'S IN THE NEWS
TODAY.
FOOD PACKAGING PLASTIC POLLUTION
MARINE PLASTIC POLLUTION.
THINK ABOUT ALL OF THE WAYS.
THAT ARE BEING ALL THE ACTIONS
BEING TAKEN BY ADVOCACY GROUP
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
BUSINESSES THAT ARE DRIVING
INNOVATION IN THIS SECTOR AND
HOW WE CAN XCELERATED.
PEOPLES ARE ALREADY SEEKING
SAFER PACKAGING AVOIDING.
METAL CANS BECAUSE OF BITS FROM
AWAY PAPER CUPS OR AVOIDING
PLASTIC CUPS BECAUSE OF POLY
STYRENE OR OTHER PLASTICIZERS
WANTS INFORMATION ABOUT.
THESE MATERIALS A CONCERN IS
PUBLIC IT IS NO LONGER ENOUGH TO
BE COMPLIANT WITH FDA GUIDANCE
ON FOOD CONTACT MATERIALS.
LIKE TOSCO BEFORE IT THE FDA
GUIDANCE AND FOOD CONTACT
MATERIALS IS NO LONGER
SUFFICIENT.
I PREDICT THAT WE WILL BE SEEING
THE PACKAGE FOOD INDUSTRY ADOPT
VOLUNTARY RESTRICTED STANDARD
SIMILAR TO WHAT I OUTLINED IN.
THE RETAILERS AND BRANDS RUMORS
ARE DEMANDING IT.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT LIKE THERE
ARE SIMILAR WAYS THAT.
ADVOCACY GROUPS LIKE THE OWN
MACARTHUR FOUNDATION WHO MANAGED
TO GET OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
20% OF GLOBAL PRESSED PLASTIC
PRODUCTION SIGN A PLEDGE TO
ELIMINATE PLASTIC.
AND THERE'S ALSO BEEN A NUMBER
OF STATE AND LOCAL ACTIONS TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF PACKAGING
USED INCLUDING.
RESTRICTIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THESE PRESSURES SET THE STAGE
FOR ADOPTION OF NEW PACKAGING
MATERIALS DESIGNS AND BUSINESS
MODELS THAT WILL PROVIDE
CUSTOMERS WITH CONVENIENCE AND
BENEFITS OF SINGLE USE PACKAGING
WITHOUT THE UNINTENDED HARM.
SEE FOR MADE IS ACTUALLY MADE TO
INVESTMENTS IMPACTING COMPANIES
BOTH LOCATED HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
AND IT'S BECAUSE THERE IS THIS
SORT OF AWARENESS.
SO I'D LIKE TO END WITH THE
IMPORTANCE OF PARTNERSHIP.
ACTIVE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
BRANDS AND RETAILERS ON ONE SIDE
RESEARCH ENTERS AND INNOVATORS
ON THE OTHER HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TO BRING NEW PRODUCTS AND
TECHNOLOGIES TO MARKET.
THAT HAVE BOTH SUPERIOR
PERFORMANCE AND SAFETY.
CONNECTING STUDENTS AND
RESEARCHERS WITH ORGANIZATIONS
LOOKING FOR STUDENT OUT FOR
SAFER CHEMISTRY CAN HAVE A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON ALL EVERYONE
INVOLVED ONE EXAMPLE THE GREENER
SOLUTIONS PROGRAM YOU SEE
BERKELEY.
SHOWS HOW UNIVERSITIES PLAYING
AN ACTIVE ROLE IN PROMOTING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SAFER CHEMISTRY
CAN HAVE AN IMPACT.
IN THEIR PROGRAM
INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAMS OF THREE
TO FIVE STUDENTS WORK WITH HOST
ORGANIZATIONS.
TO FIND WAYS TO ADOPT SAFER
CHEMISTRY FOR THE DESIGN
MANUFACTURE AND USE OF PRODUCTS.
THAT PROJECT BASED COURSE DRAWS
GRADUATE STUDENTS FROM ACROSS
THE CAMPUS AND STUDENTS OF
PROVIDED GUIDANCE FOR
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING LEVIS
METHOD SEVENTH GENERATION
PATAGONIA AUTODESK AN H. P..
AND SOME OF THESE PROJECT OF
TURN INTO ONGOING RESEARCH
COLLABORATION TO NEW
TECHNOLOGIES WHICH MAY BE
LICENSE FROM THE UNIVERSITY SOME
DAY.
IN A NUMBER OF INSTANCES THE
STUDENTS WENT ON TO WORK WITH
WITHIN THE FIELD OF SAFER
CHEMISTRY INCLUDING GRADUATES
WHO WORK HERE DTS SEE CRADLE TO
CRADLE THE USDA HEWLETT PACKARD
AND GUNS WERE.
XCELERATED INCUBATORS AND EARLY
STAGE INVESTMENT FUNDS ALL
PROVIDE PLATFORMS INSTRUCTIONS
FOR YOUNG COMPANIES TO SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND PRODUCTS AND
ALSO FOR BRANDS TO KEEP UP TO
DATE WITH NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
AND SHARE THEIR INNOVATION
PRIORITIES THIS TWO WAY
COLLABORATION CAN GUIDE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES
TO MAKE THEM MORE COMPATIBLE
WITH INDUSTRY NEEDS AND
ACCELERATE THEIR DEPLOYMENT.
THERE ARE GOVERNMENT FUNDED
ORGANISATIONS ALREADY SUPPORTING
THE SORT OF WORK HERE IN
CALIFORNIA A FEW THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO MENTION ARE THE USDA
LABORATORY --
WHICH SUPPORTS B#O BASED
MATERIALS THAT LOS ANGELES CLEAN
TECH INCUBATOR.
AND TO THE COW RECYCLE LOAN
PROGRAM WHICH AND IS THE RE USE
OF RECYCLED PRODUCTS.
SAFER MADE IS WORKED WITH ALL OF
THEM AND HIS WORK WITH START UP
TO BENEFITTED FROM THEIR SUPPORT
BUT THE AMOUNT OF SUPPORT GIVEN
TO THESE ORGANIZATIONS IS
MINUSCULE WHEN COMPARED TO
SIMILAR AT EFFORTS AND
BIOTECHNOLOGY AND ENERGY
RESEARCH.
I HOPE THAT I'VE CONVINCED YOU
THAT THERE IS BOTH A CLEAR
DEMAND FOR SAFER CHEMISTRY AS
WELL AS A GROWING SUPPLY OF
SAFER PRODUCTS AND CHEMICALS.
PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO WAKE UP
TOMORROW AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT.
A LITTLE BIT OF CARCINOGEN IS
OKAY AND MY KIDS TOYS TODAY.
IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
SO OUR FOCUS NEED TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER TO MAKE THE TRANSITION
TO HEALTHIER CHEMISTRY AND SAFER
PRODUCTS HAPPEN FASTER AND
HAPPEN IN A WAY THAT BRINGS
BENEFITS TO ALL CONSUMERS.
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS HAVE
BEEN MADE INTO THE CURRENT
SYSTEM OF PRODUCTION AND
COMMENSURATE INVESTMENT WILL BE
NEEDED TO TRANSITION US TO A
CLEANER ECONOMY.
IS A GREAT TIME TO BE WORKING
AND LEADING ON THIS ISSUE EVEN
WHEN RELATIVELY MODEST
INVESTMENT IN ACTION CAN MAKE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS ON THE SPEED
INTRODUCTORY OF THE DEVELOPMENT
OF SAFER CHEMISTRY.
I HOPE THAT YOU ARE EXCITED TO
JOIN ME IN ACCELERATING A FUTURE
FOR CALIFORNIA THAT IS SAFER.
AND MORE PROSPEROUS FOR US IN
MORE IMPORTANTLY OUR CHILDREN
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT WILL HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS I'M SURE.
A DOCTOR MOBILE HELL BUT I WANT
TO SAY HOW EXCELLENT YOUR
TESTIMONY WISE AND FOR ANYONE
WHO WANTS --
TO LOOK AT A WRITTEN COPY OF THE
TESTIMONY I IT IS ON THE WEBSITE
IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC MATERIALS --
WEBSITE SO YOU CAN GET IN THERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN DOLLY.
WHO IS MY FAVORITE --
EXPRESSION FOR HIM IS THAT FROM
HIM IS THAT HE IS
ENVIRONMENTALIST BECAUSE HE IS A
FARMER.
AND FARMERS REALLY HAVE TO
PROTECT THE LAND.
WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO SAY A WORD TO THANK YOU FOR
THE KIND WORDS IT'S GOOD TO BE
BACK ON THE COMMITTEE I SERVED
FIVE YEARS ON THE COMMITTEE TOOK
A BREAK LAST YEAR AND I'M REALLY
GLAD TO BE BACK IN.
GET IN THE MIDDLE OF THINGS THAT
THAT WE ALL CARE ABOUT AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ALL RIGHT --
SO --
SENATORS --
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY GUY HAD --
SENATOR YEAH I JUST TELL ME WHAT
YOU GO WHAT WHAT HOW HOW DO YOU
AND INCORPORATE THE CURRENT
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK WHEN YOU'RE
MAKING YOUR INVESTMENT DECISIONS
HOW HOW DO YOU.
HOW DO YOU --
YEAH THAT'S MY QUESTION.
NO AND IT PROVIDES A VALUABLE.
INFORMATION SO THE FIRST AND
EASIEST WAY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
IS WHEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WENT AHEAD AND IDENTIFIED OVER
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED CHEMICALS
OF CONCERN RIGHT TO NOT THE
PRODUCT CHEMICAL COMBINATIONS
BUT THE LIST OF LISTS AS IT WAS
CALLED.
THAT GIVES US AN EXTERNAL
VALIDATION FOR THIS APPROACH IT
ALLOWS US TO SAY WE'RE NOT GOING
TO INVEST IN ANYTHING THAT USES
THESE CHEMISTRIES FOR TALKING
ABOUT THE FUTURE.
I DON'T CARE WHERE THE RATES
WERE PRIORITIES ARE IF THESE
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY CHEMICAL
AS CHEMICALS OF CONCERN.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO THERE --
AND SO I USE LISTS LIKE THE WITH
OUR INNOVATORS AND SAY HEY IF
YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING IN THIS
AREA UNITE NEED TO NOT ONLY USE
ANY OF THESE CHEMICALS.
I ALSO INCORPORATE THE CLASS
BASED APPROACH AND SAY YOU CAN'T
USE ANY CHEMICALS THAT ARE.
IN THE CLASS OF THESE CHEMICALS
THAT ARE ON THIS LIST SO I TAKE
THAT LIST AS A STARTING PLACE.
AND THEN BROUGHT IT USING THE
CLASS APPROACH.
WHAT ABOUT SO BUT I GUESS MY
[inaudible]
I'M.
TOTALLY GET THAT AND THAT WOULD
MAKE SENSE GIVEN GIVEN YOUR WHAT
YOU DO.
BUT BROADLY SPEAKING YOU'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE
SOME CHEMICAL WHAT WHAT IS AND
WHAT ARE SOME SOME SOME GREEN
CHEMICAL PRODUCTS.
THAT WILL BE THAT WILL ACTUALLY
GROW RIGHT THEY'LL MAKE MONEY
THAT -- YOU
KNOW WITHOUT GETTING TOO MUCH IN
YOUR BUSINESS MODEL.
ARE YOU ARE YOU.
ARE YOU SORT OF TRYING TO
ANTICIPATE WHERE GOVERNMENTS
WILL GO.
IN GREATER REGULATION.
AND WHERE YOUR SENSE OF THE
PRODUCT.
DEMAND WILL BE IN THE FUTURE IS
THAT YOU HAVE TO KIND OF CREATED
A COMPLICATED MATRIX THAT
INCORPORATES ALL THOSE THINGS.
WE DO AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT
THERE IN A RELATED.
RIGHT SO WE FOLLOW THE CONSUMER.
THE CONSUMER FOLLOWS THE
INFORMATION THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
THEM SOMETIMES THROUGH ADVOCACY
GROUP SOMETIMES THROUGH
REGULATORY AGENCIES.
AND THE BRANDS AND AND RETAILERS
TO ME --
FOLLOW THOSE THOSE MARKET
SIGNALS SO WE DO TRY TO LOOK
INTO THE FUTURE AND SAY WHERE.
IS THE CONSUMER MOVING AND LIKE
I SAID IT IT OFTEN STARTS WITH
FOOD RIGHT AND THEN IT MOVES
FROM FOOD TO PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS AND FROM THAT. TO
TEXTILES IN THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT.
AND FOR EXAMPLE THE WIN
CALIFORNIA NAMED --
THE POLYURETHANE FOAM AS A
PRODUCT CHEMICAL COMBINATION
WITH MD I THE WAY I LOOK AT THAT
AS A SIGNAL THAT POLYURETHANE
EXPRESSLY USED IN CONSUMER
[inaudible]
PLACES IS.
NOT A LONG TERM VIABLE ANSWER
FOR INSULATION SO THAT.
EVEN THOUGH CALIFORNIA'S ONLY
LOOKING AT THE PARTICULAR
CHEMICAL PRODUCT COMBINATION IT
TELLS ME THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHIFT INSULATION
MATERIALS.
AND CONSUMERS ARE AKC ASKING
THAT QUESTION.
SO YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT
THERE IS A A MATRIX OF INTERPLAY
HERE WHERE GOVERNMENT ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS AND BUSINESS ALL
PLAY A PART TO DRIVE THE DEMAND.
AND WHERE WE SHOULD FOCUS IS ON
THAT SIDE OF THINGS IF YOU START
WITH THE CHEMICAL COMPANIES
THEMSELVES THEY WILL ALWAYS TELL
YOU EVERY TIME.
THAT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE AND THAT WE
HAVE TO DO WHAT WE DO TODAY AND
THEY DO THAT NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE
BAD THOSE CAMPS ARE GREAT PEOPLE
THEY DO THAT BECAUSE THEY'VE
INVESTED IN AMORTIZE THEIR
ASSETS OVER.
LONG TIME FRAMES SO SHIFTING
IT'S HARD IF YOU'RE AT THAT PART
OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN.
IF YOU'RE TOWARDS THE CONSUMER
INTO THE SUPPLY CHAIN GET OUT
AROUND THE WORLD WHERE WHERE DO
YOU THINK WHICH WHICH
JURISDICTION YOU THINK --
IS IS IS THE BEST IN THIS AREA
WHAT WHERE SHOULD WE BE LOOKING.
FOR GUIDANCE AND AND HOW TO GO
POLICY WISE IN THE COMMISSARY.
VERY HELPFUL WITH A THAT THE
EUROPEAN UNION HAS --
THE REACH PROCESS THAT PROVIDES
A BASS LINE LEVEL OF INFORMATION.
FOR CHEMICALS ENTERING THE
MARKET PLACE THAT.
IN MY OPINION THAT MODEL
PROVIDING.
A BASELINE OF SAFETY INFORMATION.
COUPLED WITH MORE ACTION WHICH
WE HAVEN'T SEEN TAKEN IN MANY
PLACES ON DISCLOSURE OF WHAT'S
ACTUALLY IN PRODUCTS ARE THE TWO
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS ROLES THE
GOVERNMENT COMPLY.
SO THAT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO CHOOSE THE
WINNERS AND LOSERS YOU JUST HAVE
TO SET THE THE PLAYING FIELD AND
SAY THIS IS WITH THE INFORMATION
YOU HAVE TO SHARE.
AND EVERY OTHER PEOPLE WILL BE
ABLE TO TAKE ACTION ACROSS.
MY LAST QUITE THAT'S GOOD K. SO
DISCLOSURE INFORMATION AND
THAT'S AT THE HEART OF THE OF
THE SOLOMON --
LATER THE RECOMMENDATIONS I FELT
QUESTIONS WHAT DO YOU WISH THE
GENERAL PUBLIC HAD A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF IN THIS AREA --
I WISH THAT THE GENERAL PUBLIC
DID THINK OF NUTRITION AND
HEALTH MORE HOLISTICALLY SO THAT
IT ISN'T JUST THE FOOD WE EAT IN
THE ACTIONS WE TAKE.
IT IS ALL OF THE PRODUCTS THAT
WE BRING INTO OUR HOME THIS IS
PART.
OF A MUCH BROADER CONVERSATION
ABOUT HEALTH --
AND I THINK WE SHOULD TREAT IT
THAT WAY IF YOU LOOK AT CANCER
OFTEN PEOPLE THINK CANCER IS --
EITHER GENETICALLY LINKED OR
CONCORD ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS
WHAT ARE ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS
ITS DIET IT'S OUT LIFESTYLE
ACTIVITY AND IT'S THE CHEMICALS
THAT ARE IN YOUR DAILY LIFE.
RIGHT WE NEED TO THINK OF THIS
AS A AS A PART OF OUR NUTRITION
AND WELLNESS THAT'S HOW.
AND I ACTUALLY SEE THAT IN TWO
WAYS BECAUSE USUALLY WHAT I FIND
IS EITHER CONSUMERS KNOW NOTHING
OR THEIR NEW PARENT AND THEY'RE
AFRAID OF EVERYTHING.
LIKE THERE'S VERY FEW THINGS IN
THE MIDDLE.
THE REALITY IS WE'RE NOT GONNA
HAVE ZERO HARM PRODUCTS I DON'T
NECESSARILY THINK THAT'S
POSSIBLE.
BUT IF YOU WE HAVE EDU IF WE CAN
MAKE EDUCATED DECISIONS ABOUT
WHAT IS HEALTHIEST FOR US WHAT
ARE THE BEST THINGS TO BRING
INTO OUR HOUSE SO WE CAN TRADE
OFF PERFORMANCE FOR POTENTIAL
HARM.
RIGHT NOW WE CAN'T DO THAT --
AND THAT'S A PROBLEM --
JUST A SECOND I'M GONNA
INTRODUCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AL
MURATSUCHI ANOTHER --
PERSON VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT WE HAD MANY
DISCUSSIONS OVER THE YEARS WHERE
HE HAS BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE
WITH ME --
DID YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS.
THAT HAVE --
INTERACT REMARKS BUT I DID HAVE
QUESTIONS EIGHT YOU KNOW OKAY
WELL WE'LL GO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOLLY AND THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND THEN
ANYONE ELSE.
SO I JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON
THE SENATOR'S COMMENTS SO IT YOU
KNOW AS LEGISLATORS WE ARE FACED
WITH.
A LOT OF DECISIONS AM AND WHEN
WE PUT SOMETHING INTO LAW.
IT CHANGES THE PLAYING FIELD
DRASTICALLY SALAMI ARMS WILL
DROP FISHER SO I I SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR SIXTEEN
YEARS.
AND WE HAD A COMMUNITY THAT ONE
TO FLOOR NATE THEIR WATER.
OKAY TO SAVE CAVITIES FOR
CHILDREN.
BASICALLY --
WHO WEREN'T?
DOING G..
AND MAY TAKE SOME THAT CREATED
OF TSUNAMI OF OPINIONS ABOUT
WHETHER WE SHOULD BE FORTY OUR
WATER WHICH IS CAN CAN KILL YOU.
THE CHEMICAL RIGHT SOME WOULD
SAY THAT AND WHICH WE GET PAID
OPINIONS ON ALL SIDES.
AND WE HAVE TO ACTUALLY MAKE
GOOD DECISIONS UPON THOSE
OPINIONS IN AND STE ONE SIDE IS
ON ONE SIDE ONE SIDE IS ON THE
OTHER ONE DENTIST ON THE SIDE
ONE ON THE SITE.
AND WE HAVE THE FAMILIES IN
BETWEEN.
SO.
I WOULD LIKE TO IN AND IN WHAT
YOU SAID I HEARD EARLIER ABOUT
YOU KNOW THE MARKET DRIVES.
THE CONSUMER TO DO CERTAIN
THINGS BASED OFF OF WHAT THEY
KNOW.
SO. FOR ME IT BE VERY HELPFUL.
IF IN THESE DISCUSSIONS THAT WE
HAVE IN IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
COME UP ALL THE TIME OF OF ONE
VERSUS THE OTHER AND WHAT'S THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT VERSUS THE
PERSONAL.
CHOICE THAT YOU WANT HAVE AND SO
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU YOU GIVE
US AS LEGISLATORS.
A BOUNDARY OF HOW WE ENGAGE IN
THOSE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
ACTUALLY.
GIVE.
PERSONAL CHOICE AND AND ALSO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AT THE SAME
TIME.
YEAH I MEAN THAT IS.
THE TRICKY BALANCE TO WALK AND I
THINK THE SAFE PLACES TO WALK IN
MY OPINION ARE AROUND.
TRANSPARENCY AND INFORMATION
DISCLOSURE THESE ARE PLACES
WHERE WE SEE WE IT WAS FUN TO BE
WORKING WITH COMPANIES AS DTS
DTS C. ROLLED OUT THEIR FIRST
THREE PRIORITY PRODUCTS.
THREE PRIORITY PRODUCTS RIGHT.
I SAW INDUSTRIES ALL OVER BEING
WORRIED THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
BE ONE OF THE THREE AND PRO
ACTIVELY REMOVING CHEMICALS OF
CONCERN THAT WERE ON THAT LIST
OF TWENTY THREE HUNDRED OR
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED AT THE TIME --
THEY WERE ACTING PROACTIVELY
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WANT THE
TARGET PUT ON THEM RIGHT AND
THAT TARGET IS JUST AN
INFORMATION TARGET IT'S NOT EVEN
A BAND.
RIGHT -- SO
I THINK IN THIS AREA OF
CHEMICALS IN PARTICULAR
INFORMATION IS OUR MOST POWERFUL
TOOL.
AND WORSE SO FAR AWAY FROM THE
SATURATION POINT OF THE
INFORMATION THAT SHOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE THAT THAT IS A SAFE
PLACE THAT WILL BOTH HAVE
POSITIVE IMPACT.
ARM AND NOT BE CHOOSING WINNERS
OR LOSERS.
RIGHT ARM I THINK THAT THERE
SHOULD BE CASES PROBABLY WHEN
THERE IS ENOUGH DATA FOR DTS SEE
ANOTHER TO TAKE REGULATORY
ACTION THEY SHOULD HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY.
WRITES THAT COMES WITH ART ONCE
YOU'VE MADE THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE THEY SHOULD HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO ACT.
BUT I ACTUALLY THINK THAT IN THE
NEAR TERM IS THE MOST POWERFUL
TOOL WE HAVE.
FINANCE YOUR QUESTION
[inaudible]
NOT ENOUGH [inaudible]
NOT QUITE.
I WOULD SUPPORT FOR NATION WATER
BASED ON THE SCIENCE IS OUT
THERE BUT THAT WASN'T A QUESTION
LIKELY.
IT -- YEAH
IT IS HARD BRIAN I UNDERSTAND
AND I JUST WANT TO MAYBE JUST
THAT MORE OF JUST A COMMENT IS
THAT.
NO PUBLIC PERCEPTION OF OF
WHOEVER'S ON WHATEVER POWER
BROKER OR WHATEVER MEDIA'S
PUSHING OR WHATEVER GROUP IS
TRYING TO SELL SOMETHING THAT
DEPENDS ON HOW GOOD OF A JOB
MARKETING THEIR PRODUCT.
TO PUT THE SCARE OR THE YOU KNOW
THERE'S A MEAN EVERYTHING CAUSES
CANCER IN THE LIST IS VERY DEEP
AND LONG AND WHITE --
BUT YOU KNOW I GO BACK TO
SOMETHING THAT THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS AND MOST OF US THERE'S NO
THAT YOU KNOW THERE IS THIS.
WE SHOULD NEVER CUT A TREE IN
THE FOREST BECAUSE IT WAS THE
WRONG THING TO DO WHEN WE SHOULD
BE CUTTING TREES AND SO BECAUSE
THE PUBLIC DIDN'T UNDERSTAND.
THE CONSEQUENCES OF NOT DOING
SOMETHING SO I TRY TO THAT'S WHY
I'M LOOKING FOR IS THAT BALANCE
OF AND WE HAVE THOSE DECISIONS
MAKE IN THEIR HARD DECISION TO
MAKE WHEN YOU HAVE.
YOUR WHOLE CONSTITUENTS I MEAN
WE WE WENT THROUGH.
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE
VACCINATIONS WHETHER YOU SHOULD
VACCINATE OR NOT ACTING I MEAN
TRUST ME.
YOU CAN GET VERY OF ME ALMOST
GET KNOCKED OUT YOUR OFFICE FROM
SOME PEOPLE THAT ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
AND WE'RE WE'RE MAKING DECISIONS
UPON THEIR CHILDREN'S LIVES AND
WHEN IT BECOMES A MOTIONAL AND
DRIVEN.
IT'S IT'S SO I I'M TRYING TO
FIND A PLACE WE NATION WITHOUT
ALL THE HYPE.
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY TAKE THE
TIME TO READ THE INFORMATION.
FROM EXPERTS WHO HAVE A NON BIAS.
OPINION ON THIS IS THE FAX THEN
YOU CAN ACTUALLY MAKE A DECISION
THAT IS EDUCATED AND CLOSE TO AS
GOOD AS IT'S GONNA GET.
YEAH.
I THINK --
MY OTHER ANSWER TO AN EARLIER
QUESTION THAT RELATES TO WHAT
YOU JUST SAID IS.
I WISH THE PUBLIC HAD A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF UNCERTAINTY.
AND THE FACT THAT WE ARE GOING
TO NEED TO MAKE DECISIONS TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION.
EVEN WHEN WE DON'T HAVE A 100%
CERTAINTY AND THAT IS WHAT'S
HARD ABOUT THIS HE'S ARE COMPLEX.
INTER RELATED QUESTIONS WHICH
MEANS THAT AS A SCIENTIST I HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE THERE'S A FAIRLY
LARGE UNCERTAINTY.
AND SO I THINK ANOTHER WAY TO
FRAME YOUR CHALLENGES HOW DO YOU
MAKE DECISIONS AND ACT.
IN THE FACE OF UNCERTAINTY AND I
THINK THAT IS A IS A COURT
CHALLENGE WORKING IN THE SPACE
OF CHEMISTRY --
CHAU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY YES
IT'S HARD WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE
ON BOTH SIDES --
I WILL SAY IN THE CASE OF
VACCINATIONS.
THE THERE IS A SCIENTIFIC
CONSENSUS.
IN THE CASE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
THERE'S A SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS
AND THERE'S GOOD REASON FOR THAT.
AND I THINK YOU YOU NEED TO RELY
UPON THE SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS
WHEN THERE ISN'T.
ONE ARE BUT THERE ARE OTHER
CASES -- WE
WERE P. FAST PER FLOOR NATIVE
OUT KILL OUTDATED SINCE YES AS
YOU SAID.
AND THAT THERE WASN'T.
THOSE DRUGS AND THERE WASN'T FOR
OTHERS.
AND THEN IT BECOMES VERY HARD
AND THAT'S WHY WE TRIED TO USE
THE GAME CHEMISTRY PROCESS. TO
LOOK AT THIS WHERE WE WEREN'T
SURE WHETHER OR NOT THOSE
PARTICULAR CHEMICALS WERE BANNED.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS ABOUT THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROCESS IS TO TAKE IT
OUT OF THE POLITICAL.
DISCUSSION AND TRY AND GET IT
INTO A SCIENTIFIC BASIS.
AND THAT TO ME IS A ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS ABOUT THE
GAME CHEMISTRY PROCESS.
ALSO THAT WE DON'T AS A DOCTOR
MOLLY HILL SAID SIMPLY.
PUT ANOTHER CHEMICAL IN THAT
MIGHT BE JUST AS BAD AND THAT'S
ANOTHER THING --
WE MAY NOT THINK ABOUT IT IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BUT WITH THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROCESS.
THERE MANDATED TO DO THAT.
SO THAT'S THE REASON WHY TRUST
THAT OVER US JUST LEGISLATING --
MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF HI I WAS
LISTENING TO YOUR TESTIMONY ON
THE THE DAY THAT THE TV THAT TO
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS ESPECIALLY AS A A A NEW
PARENT --
AND AND YOUR COMMENT ABOUT HOW
WHEN YOU BECOME A PARENT YOU
BECOME AFRAID OF EVERYTHING I
THINK THAT.
TO SOMETHING THAT I CAN REALLY
APPRECIATE I CONSUMERS ABOUT
UNCERTAINTY BECAUSE I THINK.
YOU KNOW --
DID NOT NOT NOT JUST IS IT OF
DID DO CONSUMERS --
MAKE CHOICES BASED ON THE
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED TO THEM
BUT I THINK.
VOTERS AND POLITICIANS MAKE
CHOICES BASED ON THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND SO.
YOU KNOW.
WHEN THEY'RE?
WHEN WHEN WHEN SCIENTISTS SAY
THAT THERE IS A LACK OF
CONSENSUS ON THE DANGERS OF A
CERTAIN CHEMICAL?
BUT THAT THERE IS OVERWHELMING
PUBLIC PERCEPTION THAT THERE IS
A DANGER THEN THAT'S WHEN WE
RESPOND AND THAT'S THE WORLD
THAT WERE OPERATING IN.
AND YOU KNOW I I WANT TO BRING
UP THEY THEY EXAMPLE OF OF
GLYPHOSATE.
YOU KNOW WHERE [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
IN OF THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION IS SAYING THAT IT'S
A PROBLEM CARCINOGEN AND AND AND
WE HAVE.
IT AND AND YET I UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY THEY THE E. YOU JUST
EXTENDED THE THE THE THE LEASE
FOR THE USE OF OF OF CLIVUS
EIGHT AND YET ON THE OTHER HAND
WE HAVE.
NUMEROUS COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
ALREADY BANNED OR WRIST --
RESTRICTED THAT THE USE OF OF
CLIVUS SAY.
AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW LAST YEAR
WE WE HAD --
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE MILLION
DOLLAR JURY VERDICT --
YOU KNOW WELL CHALLENGING THE
USE OF OF CLIVUS SATAN SO MY MY
POINT IS THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHY WE LIKE TO
THINK THAT THAT SCIENCE IS THE
ANSWER TO EVERYTHING I I THINK
SCIENCE.
YOU NY IS ARE LIKE STATISTICS
THAT IT CAN BE USED TO SUPPORT
AND SOMEONE SAID --
ONE SIDE'S AGENDA OR THE OTHER --
AND AND SO I I WANT TO HEAR YOUR
YOUR THOUGHTS IN A WAY WHEN WHEN
THEY'RE THERE SEEMS TO BE
COMPETING SCIENTIFIC'S EARNS
ABOUT.
ABOUT FTA STUDIES BEING
UNDERMINED BY INTEREST GROUPS --
YOU KNOW HOW HOW ARE WE SUPPOSED
TO DEAL WITH THE UNCERTAINTY AND
SCIENCE ITSELF.
THERE I I THINK THAT THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION ASKING WHY
YOU NEED.
TEAMS LIKE YOU HAVE A T. T. S.
C. WHO ARE THE EXPERTS IN
EVALUATING THE QUALITY OF
INFORMATION AND STUDIES THAT ARE
BEING DONE.
AND SO THE WHAT THE WAY I THINK
OF THE QUESTION IN AN ISSUE YOU
JUST BROUGHT UP IS.
BASICALLY A HOW MUCH OF AN
INDICATOR EARLY INDICATOR DO YOU
HAVE NEED TO HAVE OF A POTENTIAL.
PARTNER RIGHT BECAUSE WHEN WE
LIVE IN SUCH A COMPLEX SOCIETY.
EXPOSED TO SO MANY DIFFERENT
CHEMICALS IDENTIFYING THAT A
SINGLE BAD ACTOR AT A SINGLE
EXPOSURE.
IS GOING TO CAUSE A PROBLEM IT'S
KIND OF LIKE SAYING I GOT CANCER
BECAUSE A ONE TWENTY WE DON'T
KNOW THAT BUT IF YOU HAVE A
HABIT OF EATING TWINKIES AND NOT
EXERCISING YOUR YOUR LIKELIHOOD
OF HAVING A HEALTH PROBLEM IS IS.
HIGHER RIGHT.
AND SO.
THAT EARLY INDICATOR OF HARM --
IS THE THRESHOLD THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING.
FOR AND SO.
WHERE YOU CHOOSE TO DRAW THAT
LINE IS A MORAL JUDGMENT NOT A
SCIENTIFIC JUDGMENT AND I THINK
THIS IS THAT THE ROOT OF WHAT
YOU'RE DRIVING AT?
IS HOW MUCH CONSENSUS DO YOU
NEED DO NEED CONSENSUS THAT THIS
HAS.
THE CHEMICAL PROPERTIES THAT ARE
SIMILAR TO THINGS THAT ARE KNOWN
TO HAVE THESE EFFECTS DO YOU
NEED TO KNOW THOSE EFFECTS IN
PEOPLE DO YOU NEED TO JUST HAVE
SAY THAT --
WELL COMPUTER MODEL SAID THAT
THEY SHOULD HAVE A SIMILAR
EFFECT THOSE ARE ALL REASONABLE
PLACES TO DRAW THE LINE TO SAY
THIS IS A POTENTIAL CARCINOGEN
DON'T AYE ARC THAT HAS THEIR SET.
OF REQUIREMENTS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT I THINK PEOPLE MISS
THIS ALL THE TIME IT'S NOT THAT
SCIENCE CAN BE USED ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER ON SCIENCE CAN BE
INTERPRETED IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER.
ALL OF THOSE THRESHOLDS ARE
REASONABLE THRESHOLDS.
AND THE DATA UNDERLYING IT.
SHOULD BE OBJECTIVE BUT WHERE TO
DRAW THAT LINE IS A MORAL
JUDGMENT AND IT'S NOT AN EASY.
ONE AND THAT IS WHAT WE FOR YOU
KNOW PUT YOU GUYS IN OFFICE TO
DO IS MAKE THOSE MORAL JUDGMENTS
WHERE DO YOU DRAW THE LINE --
AND WE AGREE WITH YOU WE VOTE
YOU AND WE WE DON'T WE WATCH OUR
THANK YOU.
THAT WAS AN EXCELLENT ANSWER --
JUST TO TALK ABOUT THE LIFE IS
STATE. ONE OF MY FAVORITE TOPICS
AS A SCIENTIST AND THERE IS A
CONSIGNA THE CONSENSUS IT'S NOT
A PROBLEM BUT YOU DO HAVE ONE
GROUP SAYING IT IS.
ACTUALLY OTHER GROUPS WITHIN THE
WHL WORLD HEALTH IT SAYS IT'S
NOT A PROBLEM --
IT'S JUST ONE AGENCY BUT THE WAY
PROP SIXTY FIVE WORKS TO GETS
LABELED WHETHER OR NOT --
ANYONE BELIEVES IT REALLY IS A
PROBLEM IT'S JUST THIS WAS THE
WAY THEY INITIATIVE WAS WRITTEN.
IT GETS LABELED THE NICE THING
ABOUT GREEN CHEMISTRY AS IT LETS
YOU USE --
THE EXISTING EXPERTISE.
AND MAKE A DECISION AS OPPOSED
TO JUST ARBITRARILY DECIDING
WE'RE GOING TO PUT A LOT LABEL
ON THIS BECAUSE ONE AGENCY OUT
OF DOZENS HAS DECIDED IT'S
PROBLEM --
OTHER QUESTIONS --
IN [inaudible]
LET'S SEE.
I'M JUST GONNA MAKE A COMMENT
WHICH IS THAT.
THE CHEMICAL RESIDENT REVOLUTION
ARE AND FOR THAT MATTER THE
COMPUTER REVOLUTION WHICH HAS
ALLOWED US.
TO EVALUATE CHEMICALS --
HAS BROUGHT MANY MANY BENEFITS
TO ASSAULT WE'RE LIVING LONGER.
FOR THE MOST PART ALTHOUGH THERE
ARE SOME AREAS WHERE.
IN THIS IN THIS PART OF THE
COUNTRY IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY WHERE PEOPLE ARE LIVING
LONGER BUT BY AND LARGE --
WE'RE LIVING LONGER AND IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE CHEMISTRY IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE BREAKTHROUGHS
THAT ARE BEING MADE IN VARIOUS
TECHNOLOGY SO IN NET IT'S
DEFINITELY A GOOD THING --
BUT WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON THAT IN
TERMS OF NOT ONLY HOW TO FIX OUR
HEALTH BUT OUR ECONOMY --
DR MOTHER HIM.
ABSOLUTELY HAVE LOTS OF THOUGHTS
ABOUT CHEMISTRY BUT WHAT I WOULD
SAY TO IS THAT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
THAT CHEMISTRY AND MATERIALS
BRING US A LOT OF BENEFITS.
I THINK.
WHAT WE'RE LEARNING AND WHAT
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN SHIFTING
TOWARDS A SAFER CHEMISTRY SO WE
USED TO HAVE?
ISSUES OF ENVIRONMENTAL
POLLUTION THAT WERE EVEN WORSE
AND DIFFERENT THAN THE ONES WE
HAVE TODAY WE'RE CONSTANTLY
MOVING THE LINE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AND OUR JOB ISN'T.
TO YOU KNOW RETRY ISSUES OF THE
PAST IT'S TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO
WE MOVE THAT LINE.
IN THE FUTURE TOWARDS SOMETHING
THAT IS AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE AS
BENEFICIAL AS POSSIBLE AND I
THINK THAT IS THE CHALLENGE
THAT'S BEFORE US.
RATHER THAN THAN RETRYING ANY
PARTICULAR ISSUE WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
NOW WITH --
GREATER RESOURCE IS TO THINK
ABOUT INSTEAD OF JUST USING ALL
THE WASTE PRODUCTS FROM THE
PETROLEUM INDUSTRY TO MAKE OUR
MATERIALS WHICH IS WHAT WE DO
ABOUT. 98% OF CHEMICALS ARE BY
PRODUCTS THE PETROLEUM INDUSTRY
WHAT WOULD IT LOOK LIKE IF WE
STARTED WITH DIFFERENT SOURCES --
WHAT IF WE STARTED WITH CROPS OR
WASTE AND RE OPTIMIZE FOR BOTH
HEALTH AND FUNCTION AND
PERFORMANCE --
SO I GUESS THE THE COMMENT I
WOULD.
INDY WITH IS DON'T THINK OF
CHEMISTRY IS SEPARATE FROM THE
OTHER ISSUES YOU THINK ABOUT
LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE LIKE
RESOURCE USE --
BECAUSE REALLY MAKE EVERYTHING
OUT OF ARE AT THE CORE OF A LOT
OF THESE IMPACTS --
SO I'D LIKE TO SOMETIMES A JOKE
THAT WERE STUCK IN BETWEEN
CANCER CLIMATE CHANGE THE NO ONE
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT.
CHEMISTRY --
ON A GOOD DAY I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT WE ARE THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN CANCER AND CLIMATE
CHANGE SO IF YOU REALLY WANT TO
MAKE AN IMPACT.
FOCUS ON CHEMISTRY.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU CAN YEAH YOU CAN APPLAUD WHY
NOT.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
EXCELLENT --
CHEMISTRY.
CHOOSE FROM YOUR ERIC EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION AND GOOD CHEMISTRY --
NEXT I'D LIKE TO INVITE DR
MEREDITH WILLIAMS WHO IS THE
ACTING DIRECTOR AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE SAFER CAM.
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM AT DTS
SEE.
WE'VE INVITED DR WILLIAMS TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW THE
DEPARTMENTS IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM --
NOW DTS SEES BACKGROUND
INFORMATION AGAIN IS IN THE E.
S. T. M. WEBSITE [inaudible]
SO -- DOCTOR
WILLIAMS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROCEED SURE.
THANK YOU CHAIR QUIRK.
CHAIR ALLEN AND OTHER MEMBERS
WHO ARE HERE TODAY TO TO GIVE
ATTENTION TO GREEN CHEMISTRY.
WE APPRECIATE THE INTEREST AND
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE --
AND GREEN INDEED YES HE'S GREEN
CHEMISTRY WORK.
AND SINCE OF COURSE WHERE AT THE
FIVE YEAR MARK OF THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS REGULATIONS
AND IT'S BEEN TEN YEARS SINCE
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY LAWS PASSED
IT IS INDEED A GOOD TIME TO TAKE
THAT STEP BACK.
TAKE STOCK OF THE LAW THE
REGULATIONS AND THE DEPARTMENT'S
EFFORTS.
WE TOOK SOMETIME LAST LAST FALL
IN OUR PROGRAM. TO TO CELEBRATE
OUR FIFTH BIRTHDAY AND WE'RE
GROWING UP FAST BEFORE I GO ANY
FURTHER I DO WANT TO IT AT
INTRODUCED THE BRANCH CHIEF FOR
THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
GRANT BRANCH AND THAT'S CARL
PALMER [inaudible]
SEVERE FORGIVING.
TODAY I'LL BRING YOU UP TO DATE
ON DETAILS HE'S WORK TO
ESTABLISH THE REGULATIONS CALLED
FOR IN AB.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE AND ALL
DESCRIBE WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
WHAT WE'VE DONE TO BUILD A
PROGRAM TO IMPLEMENT THOSE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS REGULATIONS.
DR MALL THE WHOLE PAINTED A
POWERFUL PICTURE OF THE PROGRESS
THAT'S BEEN MADE.
AND THE INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY.
CONSUMERS ARE DEMANDING CHANGE
AND COMPANIES ARE RESPONDING.
IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO REDUCE
TOXICS IN PRODUCTS MAY BE THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT OF ANY STATES.
TEN YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
THE LEGISLATIVE DIGEST FOR
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE INCLUDED
THIS STATEMENT.
WHAT IS NEEDED IS NOTHING SHORT
OF A COMPLETE OVERHAUL OF
CURRENT TOXICS POLICY?
REPLACING IN EFFECT INEFFECTIVE
LAWS WITH POLICIES THAT RELIEVE
THE PUBLIC'S BURDEN TO PROVE
HARM AFTER THE FACT AND SHIFTED
ON TO THE CHEMICAL INDUSTRY. TO
DEMONSTRATE LACK OF HARM BEFORE.
DESPITE THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE
PROTECTING CONSUMERS IS AS
URGENT AS EVER.
JUST SUNDAY NEW YORK TIMES
ARTICLE LAMENTED THE PRESENCE OF
TALL EWING LED AS BEST AS
PARABENS AND PHTHALATES IN
COSMETICS.
FORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA'S
LEGISLATURE WRECKED RECOGNIZE
THIS THE SHORTFALLS OF CHEMICALS
MANAGEMENT AND PUSHED
LEGISLATION TO TACKLE THE
CHALLENGE.
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY INITIATIVE
SB FIVE OH NINE EIGHT FEET ABC
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE AND THE
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
REGULATIONS ALL RECOGNIZE THE
SCALE OF THE SEA CHANGE.
THAT WAS NEEDED UNFORTUNATELY
THE LAWS AND REGULATIONS WERE
CRAFTED TO BE AMBITIOUS ENOUGH
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS.
AND REALIZE THE BENEFITS.
THE GREEN CHEMIST OF THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY OPPORTUNITY.
MY COMMENTS TODAY WILL FOCUS ON
OUR WORK IMPLEMENTING THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS REGULATIONS.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT THEY ARE ONLY ONE FACET.
OF WHAT IT WILL TAKE TO GET YOU
A GREEN CHEMISTRY BASED ECONOMY
IN CALIFORNIA.
IN THE TEN YEARS SINCE THE LAW
PASSED WE'VE BEEN DOING WHAT THE
LEGISLATOR AT LEGISLATURE ASKED
US TO DO.
FIRST WE UNDERTOOK THE
DEVELOPMENT OF REGULATIONS THAT
WOULD SHIFT THE PARADIGM FOR
MANAGEMENT OF TOXIC CHEMICALS.
THERE WAS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
ENGAGEMENT ACROSS THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY DURING THE
REGULATIONS DEVELOPMENT.
AND THAT'S STILL A SIGNATURE OF
THE PROGRAM.
AS EVIDENCED BY A BROAD SPECTRUM
OF SPEAKERS TODAY AND THOSE IN
ATTENDANCE.
WE ADOPTED REGULATIONS INTENDED
TO MOVE AWAY FROM REACTIVE
CHEMICAL WHACK A MOLE APPROACH
TOWARDS SCIENCE BASED DECISIONS.
THAT ARE COMPREHENSIVE IDENTIFY
SAFER ALTERNATIVES AND AVOID
SHIPS REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTES.
THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
REGULATIONS HOLD MANUFACTURERS
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THE SAFETY OF
THEIR PRODUCTS BY COMPELLING
INDUSTRY TO OFFER SAFER PRODUCTS
TO CONSUMERS.
IMPORTANTLY ADOPTING THE
FORCIBLE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
PROVIDES MORE MARKET CERTAINTY.
AN IN AND PROVIDES INCENTIVES
FOR CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA IS BLESSED WITH
COMPANIES WHO ARE COMMITTED TO A
SAFER PRODUCTS METHOD HEWLETT
PACKARD LEVI APPLE BEAUTY
COUNTER AND MANY OTHER COUNTRIES
COMPANIES.
ARE ALREADY AGGRESSIVELY
ELIMINATING TOXIC CHEMICALS IN
THEIR PRODUCTS YOU'LL HEAR FROM
REPRESENTATIVES OF SOME OF THOSE
COMPANIES TODAY.
AND I THINK THEY'LL THEY'LL GIVE
YOU A PERSPECTIVE OF HOW THEY
ARE TACKLING THIS PROBLEM.
THE SEP RAPPER REGULATIONS HELP
SET A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD SO
THAT THOSE TYPES OF COMPANIES
THAT MOVE FORWARD.
TOWARD SAFER ALTERNATIVES.
ARE AT A DISADVANTAGE IN THE
MARKET PLACE.
THESE OUTCOMES WARRANTED SHIVA
BOWL WITH THE HISTORICAL
VOLUNTARY PROGRAMS.
SUCH AS THE POLLUTION PREVENTION
PROGRAM AT THE TSC.
WE'VE BUILT THE PROGRAM ON THREE
FUNDAMENTAL PILLARS. TO BUILD
CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT THE RIGS.
TO EXECUTE.
AND TO LEAD.
SO BY CAPACITY BUILDING WILL I
MEAN WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE SKILLS THE PROCESSES
AND THE SCIENTIFIC RESOURCES. TO
IMPLEMENT THIS UNIQUE SET OF
REGULATIONS.
WE'VE HIRED STAFF WITH NEW AREAS
OF EXPERTISE THAT ARE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT.
OUR WORK WE DEVELOPED PROCESSES
TO SUPPORT OUR DECISIONS AND
REGULATORY ACTIONS.
AND WE'VE ENSURED THAT OUR STAFF
HAVE ACCESS TO THE RIGHT TOOLS
SUCH IS ACCESS TO RESEARCH AND
DATA.
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO PRESS
PRESIDENT FOR APPROACH WE BUILT
MANY OF OUR TOOLS FROM SCRATCH.
AND PROCEDURES THE SAME WAY.
BUT WE LOOK WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO USE
EXISTING RESOURCES AND ADAPT TO
THEM FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FRAMEWORK.
OUR CAPACITY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
OUR CAPACITY WE'RE NOT JUST
TALKING ABOUT THOSE IN THE
DEPARTMENT WE TALK ABOUT THOSE --
BEYOND THE WALLS OF THE
DEPARTMENT WE LEVERAGE EXTERNAL.
TOOLS AND EXPERTISE EXTENSIVELY
AND THAT IS REALLY HELPED US
MAKE OUR LIMITED RESOURCES GO
FURTHER.
MUCH OF OUR CAPACITY BUILDING
WAS MADE POSSIBLE WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE.
WE'VE UNDERTAKEN A FOUGHT FOR
EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM WITH
LEGISLATIVE SESSION WERE SUPPORT
FOR CERTAIN RESOURCES.
WE'VE ASKED FOR NEW STACK OF
STAFFING COMMENSURATE WITH WHERE
WE ARE ON OUR PROGRESS OF
IMPLEMENTING THE REGULATIONS AND
OUR CONFIDENCE ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT.
WE'RE READY TO USE THOSE
RESOURCES WISELY AND THAT'S
ENABLED US TO COME AS FAR AS WE
HAVE.
WITH RESPECT TO THE SECOND
PILLAR THE EXECUTION PILLAR THAT
MEANS WE SIMPLY MUST DO THE NUTS
AND BOLTS TASKS THAT ARE DEFINED
BY THE REGULATIONS. FOR INSTANCE
WORKING TO THE REGULATORY TIME
LINES FOR ANNOUNCING THE FIRST
PRIORITY PRODUCTS AND THE WORK
PLANS.
ESTABLISHING THE CANDIDATE
CHEMICALS.
ISSUING ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS
GUIDANCE.
AND COMPLETING PRIORITY PRODUCT
RULE MAKING.
EXECUTION ALSO MEANS SENDING A
HIGH STANDARD OF QUALITY.
OR TECHNICAL WORK HAS BEEN
CONSISTENTLY VALIDATED BY OUR
GREEN RIBBON SCIENCE PANEL AND
BY EXTERNAL PEER REVIEWERS.
LASTLY LEADING THE WAY.
AS IS SO OFTEN THE CASE
CALIFORNIA MUST PROVIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP.
I THINK THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS
THAT BETTER THAN MOST --
DOCTOR MALL THE WHOLE TALKED
ABOUT GREEN CHEMISTRY IS A
LARGER ECONOMIC TREND.
BUT IN ORDER TO REACH A TIPPING
POINT.
GOVERNMENTMUST PLAY ITS ROLE TO
BUILD A NEW MODEL OF INHERENTLY
SAFER PRODUCTS DESIGNED PRODUCT
DESIGN.
THE AND A MODEL THAT FOSTERS
INNOVATION AND EMBRACES GREEN
CHEMISTRY.
WE LEAD BY CALLING FOR ADVANCES
IN SCIENCE AND BEING SHORT TO
APPLY EMERGING SCIENCE TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF OUR
DECISIONS.
WE LEAD BY ENGAGING OTHER
FORWARD LOOKING GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS AT THE LOCAL STATE
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL LEVEL.
WE HAVE DONE SO AND DERIVE GREAT
BRENT BENEFIT FROM MEMORANDA OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH OREGON AND
WASHINGTON STATE.
AND WITH U. S. EPA'S OFFICE OF
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT AND
OFFICE OF CHEMICAL SAFETY AND
POLLUTION PREVENTION.
WE ALSO HAVE PARTNERS IN OUR
FELLOW REGULATORS IN CANADA AND
IN EUROPE.
SO WE'VE USE THESE THREE PILLARS
TO GUIDE OUR WORK AND ACCOMPLISH
A GREAT DEAL.
THE SECOND PAGE OF YOUR HAND OUT
SHOWS SOME OF THE ACTIONS WE'VE
TAKEN ALL HIGHLIGHT A FEW AND
MENTION SOME ITEMS THAT AREN'T
CAPTURED AND NOT IN THE HANDOUT.
WHEN THE START OFF WITH PAINT
STRIPPERS WITH METHYLENE
CHLORIDE?
THIS CHEMICAL IS CARCINOGEN IT'S
A CARCINOGEN AND INNER OF TALKS
CAN.
AND IT IS CAUSED AT LEAST SIXTY
FOUR FATALITIES OVER THE LAST
DECADES.
MEANWHILE DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THE DESPITE PLEAS FROM THE
FAMILIES OF THOSE WHO DIED USEPA
HAS DRAGGED ITS FEET ON TAKING
ACTION.
WORKERS AND DO IT YOURSELFERS
ARE AT RISK AND THEY LET US KNOW
THAT DURING THE COMMENT PERIOD.
NOW IN RESPONSE TO OUR PRIORITY
PRODUCT LISTING MANUFACTURERS
ARE ANALYZING.
THE SAFETY OF THE ALTERNATIVES.
WE HAVE PROPOSED CARPETS AND
RUGS WITH PER OR POLY FLORAL
ALCOTT SUBSTANCES.
AS A PRIORITY PRODUCT THESE P.
FAST SUBSTANCES ARE
DEVELOPMENTAL AND REPRODUCTIVE
TOXICANTS.
CHILDREN FROM CRAWL ON RUGS AND
SPEND TIME ON THE FLOOR ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO EXPOSURES.
ADDITIONALLY.
P. FAST ARE EXTREMELY PERSISTENT
IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
LEADING TO REPEATED EXPOSURES
LONG AFTER THE USEFUL LIFE OF OF
ANY GIVEN PRODUCT.
WE'RE DRESSING THE THOUSANDS OF
P. FAST CHEMICALS USING A CLASS
APPROACH.
WITCH DOCTOR MORE THE WHOLE
REFERENCED AND WHICH IS
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE REPORT.
USING A CLASS APPROACH WE'RE
USING A CLASS APPROACH RATHER
THAN A CHEMICAL BY CHEMICAL
APPROACH.
THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT OBJECTIVE
OF THE LAW AND OUR REGULATIONS
INSURER THAT WE DON'T DO THEIR
AROUND WITH ONE CHEMICAL OR TWO
CHEMICALS BUT WE CAN TAKE A LOOK
AT THE FULL RANGE OF CHEMICALS
IN THIS CLASS.
WHICH ALL SHARE --
THE PERSISTENCE ATTRIBUTES.
ON ANOTHER FRONT WE'RE GIVING
COMPANIES THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO
ANALYZE ALTERNATIVES TO STOP THE
BLIND SUBSTITUTION OF ONE BAD
CHEMICAL FOR ANOTHER.
OUR GREEN RIBBON SCIENCE PANEL
MEMBERS PROVIDED LEADERSHIP FOR
THE NATIONAL ACADEMIES OF
SCIENCES ALTERNATIVES ASSESSMENT
FRAMEWORK.
AND THEY'VE HELPED TO USE THAT
THAT WORK TO INFORM OUR
ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS GUIDANCE.
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVES
ANALYSIS GUIDE IS A
COMPREHENSIVE RESOURCE FOR THE
REGULATED COMMUNITY AND
ALTERNATIVES ARE NOT ANALYSIS
PRACTITIONERS.
LAST FALL WE HOSTED THE SECOND
INTERNATIONAL SYMPOSIUM ON
ALTERNATIVES ASSESSMENT.
THE BAND THAT BROUGHT LEADERS
LEADING RESEARCHERS AND
PRACTITIONERS TO SACRAMENTO.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE TIME IS
RIGHT FOR GREATER ADOPTION OF
METHODS TO LOOK FOR SAFER ALSO
AND ALTERNATIVE SAFER
SUBSTITUTES WITHOUT INCURRING
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
PAGE FIVE OF YOUR HAND OUT HAS
SOME INFORMATION ON CAL SAY FOR
OUR INFORMATION MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM.
CAL SAFER PROVIDES ONE STOP
SHOPPING FOR THE ENTIRE
REGULATORY PROCESS.
IT FACILITATES TRANSPARENCY AND
INFORMATION SHARING BETWEEN US
AND THOSE WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
OUR WORK.
AND IT'S MADE US MORE EFFICIENT
WE CAN COMPILE COMMENTS AND
REVIEW THEM IN A MUCH MORE
ORGANIZED FASHION.
THESE ARE A FEW OF THE ACTIONS
BE TAKEN IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
TO IMPLEMENT THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS REGULATIONS.
IN ARE DECISIONS WE'VE EXERCISE
THE CONSIDERABLE DISCRETION THAT
THE REGULAR REGULATIONS AFFORD
WE'VE MADE POLICY DECISIONS TO
PROTECT WORKERS AND CHILDREN.
IN OUR WORK PLAN EMPHASIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING THE
MOST VULNERABLE VULNERABLE.
THIS HEARING WAS PROMPTED BY THE
RELEASE OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE REPORT AND TAKING
STOCK OF CALIFORNIA'S APPROACH
TO GAME GREEN CHEMISTRY.
GIVEN THE LACK OF ACTION AND
LEADERSHIP AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO BE OUT FRONT ON
TOXICS.
WE HAVE REVIEWED THE REPORT AND
USED IT TO REFLECT ON OUR WORK.
MANY OF THE CONCLUSIONS OF THE
REPORT ARE SPOT ON WE AGREE THAT
IT'S TIME TO REVISIT.
THE OTHER ELEMENTS OF THE
INITIATIVE. FOR INSTANCE WE'VE
HIRED AS DR MOBILE HOME
MENTIONED OUTSTANDING GRADUATES
FROM UC BERKELEY'S GREENER KEPT
GREENER SOLUTIONS PROGRAM.
BUT WE NEED UNIVERSITIES TO
EDUCATE MORE STUDENTS AND MORE
DISCIPLINES IN THE CONCEPTS OF
TRUE SUSTAINABILITY IN GREEN
CHEMISTRY.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE TOXIC
INFORMATION CLEARING HOUSE IS
NOT SERVED ITS INTENDED PURPOSE.
AND THAT THERE ARE BETTER MORE
USEFUL TOOLS AVAILABLE TODAY.
AND WE KNOW THE DTS HE'S
POLLUTION PREVENTION PROGRAM
OFFERS SOLUTIONS TO MANY.
MANY INTRACTABLE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROBLEMS.
RE COMMITTING TO THAT WORK WOULD
BENEFIT THE STATE.
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
THE REPORTS DISCUSSION OF OUR
DATA CHALLENGES ECHO THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATIVE REPORT
OUTLINING A DATA GAP THE
PREVENTS GOVERNMENT FROM
ADEQUATELY PROTECTING PEOPLE
FROM HARMFUL CHEMICALS.
IT WOULD BE TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL
FOR US TO HAVE ACCESS. TO MANY
TYPES OF DATA INGREDIENT
DISCLOSURE AS THROUGH.
MORE EXPOSURE STUDIES OR THROUGH
STRENGTHENING OUR DATA CALL IN
AUTHORITY.
WE WILL BENEFIT FROM THE
TRANSPARENCY INITIATIVES LIKE SB.
TWO TO FIFTY EIGHT THE CLEANING
PRODUCTS RIGHT TO KNOW ACT.
WE BELIEVE THAT DATA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BY A MONITORING
PROGRAM NOT ONLY CAN INFORM OUR
PROVIDE OUR PRIORITIZATION WORK.
BUT COULD POTENTIALLY PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE EFFICACY
OF OUR ACTIONS.
BIO MONITORING FUNDING HAS BEEN
PRECARIOUS AND INADEQUATE.
WE WILL FOLLOW THE REPORT'S
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY THE GREEN RIBBON
SCIENCE PANEL DO A
PRIORITIZATION LOOK BACK TO SEE
IF THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. TO STRENGTHEN
OUR PRIORITIZATION APPROACH OR
IMPROVE THE PRESS THE PACE OF
THE PRIORITIZATION PROCESS.
WE ARE ALREADY PREPARING
MATERIALS ON THIS TOPIC AND IT
WILL BE THE FOCUS OF OUR SECOND
OUR OUR GREEN RIBBON SIGNS PANEL
SECOND MEETING LATER THIS YEAR.
SOME OF THE OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS NEED IN ME
DEEPER ANALYSIS OR NEED MORE
INFORMATION BEFORE PURSUING. FOR
INSTANCE WE HAVEN'T YET RECEIVED
HER FIRST ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS
ANALYSES SO IT MAY BE PREMATURE
TO TINKER WITH THAT PART OF THE
FRAMEWORK.
DTS SEE HAS ALREADY PROVIDED
GUIDANCE SINCE AND WE STAND
READY TO SUPPORT. TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO THE REGULATED
COMMUNITY AS THEY GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
EXAMINE OTHER OPTIONS TO EXIT
OUT EXPEDITE THE ALTERNATIVES
ANALYSIS PROCESS BY WORKING WITH
COMPANIES.
WHO ARE BEGINNING TO CONDUCT THE
ALTERNATIVES ANALYSES?
I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PACE OF OUR WORK.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT AND SUMMER
INHERENT TO THE FRAMEWORK WHICH
ALTHOUGH PRECAUTIONARY IN
NATURE'S STILL.
CALLS FOR ROBUST SCIENCE.
THERE ARE INHERENT TENSIONS
BETWEEN SCIENCE BASED IN WELL
SUPPORTED DECISIONS AND QUICK
IDENTIFIES SHOULD IDENTIFICATION
OF PRODUCTS.
BETWEEN FAST ACTION TO LIMIT A
CHEMICAL AND THOROUGH ANALYSES
TO LIMIT REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTES.
AND BETWEEN PROVIDING A FULL
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT.
AND MOVING FAST WE'VE BEEN VERY
COMMITTED TO OUR STAKEHOLDERS
AND HAD ITERATIVE ENGAGEMENT FOR
EVERY SIGNIFICANT DECISION THE
PROGRAM HAS MADE.
AND THIS LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT
TAKES TIME.
THE NEWNESS AND NOVELTY OF THE
APPROACH IS ANOTHER REASON THAT
THE RATE AT WHICH WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED THE REGULATIONS HAS
BEEN SLOWER.
THAN MANY STAKEHOLDERS WOULD
HAVE LIKED.
AND FIRST IN SOME CASES THEN WE
WOULD HAVE LIKED --
FOR THE FIRST SEVERAL YEARS OF
THE EVERY SINGLE THING WE DID
WAS BEING DONE FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
SOME MORE HIGHLY SKEPTICAL THAT
WE COULD DO DO SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE ASKED FOR SOME
AND WHATEVER GREEN RIBBON SIGNS
PANEL MEMBERS FOR INSTANCE SAID
WE HE HONESTLY DIDN'T THINK WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO DEVELOP
ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS GUIDANCE.
BUT HE'S SINCE BECOME THAT
CONVINCED THAT NOT ONLY COULD WE
DEVELOP THAT GARDENS.
BUT WE DID IT WELL.
WE STRUCTURE THE PROGRAM TO BE A
LEARNING ORGANIZATION WE APPLY
WHAT WE LEARNED FROM OUR
SUCCESSES AND OUR MISSTEPS. TO
BE MORE EFFICIENT I'M CONFIDENT
THAT THIS WILL BE APPARENT IN
THE PACE OF AND QUALITY OF THE
WORK THIS YEAR AND FURTHER INTO
THE FUTURE.
BUT AS THE REPORT POINTS OUT ONE
OF OUR BIGGEST CONSTRAINTS IS
RESOURCES.
ASI MENTIONED WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
SUCCESSFUL BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS.
AND THE PROGRAM HAS USED THE
RESOURCES IT'S BEEN GIVEN THROW
THOSE PROPOSALS AS EFFECTIVELY
AS POSSIBLE.
MORE RESEARCH IS WOULD ALLOW THE
PROGRAM TO DO EVEN MORE AS IT
MOVES FOR WITH IMPLEMENTATION.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT LEVEL
OF RESOURCES WILL NOT BE
SUFFICIENT FOR THE PROGRAM TO
HAVE THE IMPACT IT COULD AND
SHOULD ON PER TO FIND CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
OF COURSE WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT
THE NEED FIRST SEP RESOURCES
OUTSIDE OF A DISCUSSION OF THE
LARGER PRESSURE ON DTS SEES
BUDGET.
DGSE NEED SUPPORT ACROSS THE
BOARD TO ADDRESS ITS REVENUE
SHORTFALLS.
THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ACCOUNT OR TOSCA THAT FUNDS.
S. C. P. IS IN STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT.
IT'S BEEN TWENTY YEARS SINCE THE
DEPARTMENTS FEES WERE RESET.
BEYOND TOSCA THE LEGISLATURE
COULD HELP EVALUATE POTENTIAL
REVENUE STEAM STREAMS FOR SEP.
A POLICY ANALYSIS OF DIFFERENT.
MODELS COULD BE INFORMATIVE. FOR
INSTANCE FUNDING UNDER
MASSACHUSETTS TALKS EXCUSE
REDUCTION ACT.
HAS ENABLED THE STATE THAT STATE
TO FUND PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
UNIVERSITY RESEARCHERS AND
MANUFACTURERS TO DEVELOP PAINT
STRIPPERS SAFER PAINT STRIPPERS
PERFORMANCE TEXTILES ADHESIVES
AND NAIL PRODUCTS.
CALIFORNIA PRIDES ITSELF ON ITS
LEADERSHIP.
IF WE WANT TO STAY IN THE LEAD
WE MUST FULLY COMMIT TO THIS
WORK.
WE WELCOME THIS CHECK IN.
AT TEN YEARS IT'S APPROPRIATE.
SOMETIMES I DRAW A PARALLEL
BETWEEN A GROWING CHILD AND THE
GROWTH OF THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM.
WE WERE A TODDLER IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WHEN WE NAMED WHEN WE
PROPOSED OUR FIRST THREE
PRIORITY PRODUCTS.
AND QUITE FRANKLY WE FELL ON OUR
BOMB A FEW TIMES.
BUT WE GOT UP AND KEPT MOVING.
AND NOW WE'RE LIKE A TEN YEAR
OLD.
WE HAVE SOME SPROUT A SURPRISING
NUMBER OF SKILLS AND WE'RE
LEARNING IN AN ASTONISHING PACE.
MAYBE AS A TEENAGER WILL REALLY
START TO CALL CAUSE SOME TROUBLE.
WE'RE BEGINNING TO SEE THE
IMPACT.
THE VINYL FLOORING INDUSTRY
REMOVED OR IF OF FALAISE FROM
THEIR PRODUCTS IN RESPONSE TO
OUR WORK PLAN.
WE KNOW THAT MANUFACTURERS
DIDN'T EVEN WAIT FOR US TO
COMPLETE OUR REGULATIONS TO LIST
SLEEP PRODUCTS CONTAINING SOME
FLAME RETARDANTS AS A PRIORITY
PRODUCT.
BEFORE THEY STARTED REMOVING THE
FLAME RETARDANTS THAT WE THAT WE
NAMED.
EVERYONE HERE WANTS THE SAME
THING IT'S THE VISION THAT THE
DOCTOR MOBILE HOME LAID OUT.
GIVE YOUR KID A TOY DON'T THINK
TWICE ABOUT IT HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT IT'S SAFE.
SO WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE IN
TERMS OF THAT GOAL AND WHERE
WE'RE HEADED.
AND IT TOOK A LOT OF US ALL OF
US TO GET THIS FAR IN IS GOING
TO TAKE US ALL OF US TO KEEP
THINGS MOVING FORWARD.
DURING THIS MORNING STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS GOVERNOR NEWS AND
TALKED ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
CULTURE OF INNOVATION AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
ON A COUPLE DIFFERENT OCCASIONS
HE TALKED ABOUT THE STATE'S
ABUNDANCE OF SCIENTISTS AND
ENGINEERS.
WHO SOLVE PROBLEMS AND DRIVE
ECONOMIC GROWTH?
I ONCE LOOKED AT THE CLEAN TECH
PATENTS COMING OUT OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WHILE THE NUMBERS WERE
IMPRESSIVE NOT NEARLY ENOUGH OF
THEM WERE GREEN CHEMISTRY
PATENTS.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE A GREEN
GREEN CHEMISTRY BECOME A STRONG
STRONGER ECONOMIC SECTOR IN THE
STATE.
WITHOUT TO WRAP UP THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ATTENTION TO GREEN
CHEMISTRY AND FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW WORDS
ABOUT DTS HE'S WORK.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TOWARD THE GOALS WE WERE
DISCUSSING TODAY.
OF SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS A
CLEANER ENVIRONMENT AND A GREEN
CHEMISTRY INNOVATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
WILLIAMS FOR YOUR EXCELLENT
TESTIMONY I WANT TO INTRODUCE
SENATOR HENRY STERN MEMBER OF
THE SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE.
ARE DO YOU HAVE ANY --
INITIAL REMARKS.
NOW ALL RIGHT SO THEN DO WE HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS YES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THAT WAS --
A VERY CLEAR AND VERY HELPFUL
PRESENTATION.
AND I CERTAINLY --
APPRECIATE YOUR G. AND THE
PHILOSOPHY BEHIND --
THE WORK THAT YOU DO --
FIRST I WANT TO COMMENT ON
SOMETHING THAT MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY JUST A
PICKY BACK ON HIS STATEMENT
ABOUT.
A SOMETIMES HAVING.
TO MAKE DECISIONS WITHOUT YOU
KNOW HAVING A HUGE CONSENSUS OR
WITH THERE BEING DIFFERENT FACTS
ON BOTH SIDES --
I LOOK AT IT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY I LOOK AT WITH THE
FACT THAT WHEN PEOPLE GO WHEN
THEY PURCHASE PRODUCTS.
THEY ASSUME THAT THOSE PRODUCTS
ARE SAFE.
THEY ASSUME THEY'RE SAFE BECAUSE
WE ALLOW THEM TO BE SOLD.
AND WHILE THERE ARE SOME
CONSUMERS WHO HAVE THE WHERE
WITH ALL AND THE ABILITY.
AND A TIME TO DO SOME RESEARCH
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
DON'T -- IN
FACT IF I WALK TO MY OWN HOME I
COULDN'T TELL YOU WHAT PRODUCTS
WERE RISKY AND WHAT WARRANT --
BUT WHEN I GO IN AND BUY
SOMETHING YOU KNOW I HOPE IT
SAFE I THINK I KNOW ENOUGH TO BE
SKEPTICAL AND A LITTLE BIT
NERVOUS BUT I I DON'T.
I DON'T FEEL THE CONFIDENCE THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO FEEL.
AS A CITIZEN OF THIS SO I THINK
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THAT OUR CITIZENS AND OUR
CONSUMERS ARE SAFE.
AND THAT THAT IS THE PREDOMINANT
RESPONSIBILITY WE HAVE ABOVE ALL
ELSE.
AND WHILE SOME DECISIONS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT TO FLORIDA A
WATER HAS HAVE PUBLIC HEALTH --
BENEFITS AND RISKS ON BOTH SIDES
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE NOT LIFE AND DEATH ARE
PUBLIC -- A
HEALTH --
NECESSITIES A LOT OF THEM ARE
CONVENIENCES.
AND SO THEY HAVE AN EXTRA
RESPONSIBILITY I THINK --
TO BE SAFE.
SO WITH THAT AS AS MY PHILOSOPHY
I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOU --
THOUGH AND ONE OTHER COMMENT IS
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF OUR
MANUFACTURERS AND PRODUCERS WHO
ARE VERY RESPONSIBLE AND WHO
WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THINGS AND
THEY ARE TRUSTED BRANDS I KNOW A
LOT OF THEM ARE HERE.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE FULL RANGE OF
MANUFACTURERS AND WE CERTAINLY
HAVE MANUFACTURERS THAT ARE NOT
EVEN IN THE STATE OR IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WHO OPERATE UNDER VERY DIFFERENT --
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT AND SO
BUT THEY'RE ALSO ALLOWED TO BE
SOLD HERE AND SO WE HAVE AN
EXTRA RESPONSIBILITY WITH REGARD
TO THAT AND PUBLIC HEALTH AS
WELL -- WHEN
I WANT -- TO
ACKNOWLEDGE TO THAT I BELIEVE
THAT YOUR DEPARTMENT YOUR OF
DEPARTMENT OR AGENCY IS.
UNDER FUNDED AND WE SHOULD
CHANGE THAT AND GIVE YOU A LOT
MORE RESOURCES BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS IMPERATIVE --
I NOTICE FROM MY FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS I THINK IT IS FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE STATE IF
THEY UNDERSTOOD --
WHAT WAS ACTUALLY IN THE
PRODUCTS THAT THEY PURCHASE
QUITE INNOCENTLY THINKING THAT
IF THEY BUY WOULD TôI THAT IT'S
JUST MATTER WHAT?
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW WE KNOW
THAT'S NOT TRUE BUT THEY DON'T.
SO FIRST MY FIRST QUESTION IS
DOES T. T. S. S..
S. C. HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE THE CHEMICALS THAT ARE
USED IN FOOD AND DRINK PACKAGING
UNDER THE SAFE CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM AND IF SO ARE YOU
CONSIDERING ANY OF THOSE RIGHT
NOW AS PRIORITY --
PRODUCTS.
SO WE DO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
NAME -- FOOD
PACKAGING AS A CONSUMER PRODUCT
THE DEFINITION A CONSUMER
PRODUCT IS QUITE BROAD TO BE
REFERENCED OTHER DEFINITIONS IN
CALIFORNIA STATUTE.
IN OUR REGULATIONS.
AND ON THAT.
IT INCLUDES.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING EXCEPT
FOR MEDICAL DENTAL DEVICES AND A
PESTICIDES REALLY THOSE OF THE
THE MAJOR AREAS THAT ARE.
THAT WE CAN'T ADDRESS THROUGH
OUR REGULATIONS SO FOOD
PACKAGING IS ON THE TABLE.
AND WE HAVE A GROUP OF STAFF WHO
ARE ACTIVELY RESEARCHING THEM
THERE ARE QUITE A RANGE OF
CHEMICALS THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT THE P. FAST CHEMICALS
THAT ARE IN FOOD PACKAGING --
WE HA HAS LISTED AND CHEMICALS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THAT
HAVE TURNED UP --
IN FOOD PACKAGING THERE WAS A
LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT BPA THERE'S
SOME CONCERN AROUND AROUND
STYRENE THAT SAID WE'RE VERY
MUCH IN THE PROCESS OF
EVALUATING THOSE THINGS AND WILL
LIKELY HAVE IN A WORKSHOP.
STE WHEN.
LATER THIS YEAR JUST LIKE I KNOW
TO PROPOSED TO EXPLORE THE TOPIC
MORE FULLY AND RIGHT.
AND YOU COULD CHILDREN'S HEALTH
PRIORITY IN THIS PROCESS IN IN
OUR WORK PLAN WE STATED SOME
POLICY PRIORITIES AND CHILDREN'S
HEALTH AND AND THAT INCLUDES NOT
JUST CHILDREN BUT ALSO WOMEN OF
CHILDBEARING AGE BECAUSE THAT
CAN HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT ON
CHILDREN'S HEALTH --
SO WE'VE WE PRIORITIZE THOSE SO
SO INTENT IN A IF I AM INCORRECT
IN THIS PLEASE CORRECT ME BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM LISTENING TO
THAT IN TEN YEARS.
DTS SEASON DOBBY REGULATIONS
RELATING TO ONLY THREE CHEMICALS
AS LISTED ANOTHER THREE IS
PRIORITY PRODUCTS.
BUT THE LIST OF YOUR CANDIDATE
CHEMICALS IN THE LIST IS OVER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FOR
CONSIDERATION.
LET ME CAN I FOR YOU IF I MAY I
WILL RESTATE FAT AND ASSEMBLY
DIFFERENT WAYS SO YES WE'VE WE
RELEASED AN INFORMATIONAL
CANDIDATE CHEMICALS LIST.
AND ON THAT LIST I NO LONGER SAY
HOW MANY CHEMICALS ARE ON THE
LIST AND THE REASON I DON'T DO
THAT IS BECAUSE ONE OF THE LISTS
THAT WE REFERENCE IS THE
CALIFORNIA BIOMONITORING
PRIORITY CHEMICALS LIST.
AND THAT LIST ALLOW THEIR USING
A CLASS APPROACH TO CHEMICALS SO
WHEN THEY SAID THE CLASS OF P.
FAST WE ADOPTED THAT ENTIRE
GROUP OF CHEMICALS.
WHEN WE WHEN WE FIRST DID THAT
WE THOUGHT THAT WAS ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND CHEMICALS AND NOW WE
THINK IT'S ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
CHEMICALS SO?
YOUR GUESS IS AS GOOD AS MINE
AND SO IT IS IN THE THOUSANDS OF
CHEMICALS BUT I CAN'T PUT A
NUMBER ON IT.
EASILY BUT IN TERMS OF THE
REGULATIONS OF YOU'VE ADAPTED SO
MANY THREE PRODUCTS HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED OKAY IT SEEMS IT I MEAN
IT SEEMS TO ME.
UNLESS I ASSUME THAT THOSE FIVE
THOUSAND ARE NOT GOING TO END UP
BEING REGULATED WHICH YES AND
OKAY SO YOU WOULD AGREE THAT
THERE IS THIS TREMENDOUS BACKLOG
YES AND AND MEANWHILE WE'RE
ALLOWING ALL OF THOSE PRODUCTS
TO BE SOLD.
IN CALIFORNIA BEFORE WE REALLY
DONE THE REVIEW TO KNOW IF
THEY'RE SAFE.
CORRECT OKAY --
SO WHAT DO YOU NEED TO
ACCELERATE THAT PROCESS BECAUSE
IF I WAS THOUGH IF I WAS IN
CHARGE.
OF ALL OF THIS I WOULD ALLOW
ANYTHING TO BE SOLD UNTIL THEY
WERE PROVEN SAFE BUT THAT'S JUST
ME.
SO -- SO
WHAT DO YOU NEED. TO TO
ACCELERATE THIS PROCESS AND GET
THROUGH MORE OF THESE CHEMICALS
MORE QUICKLY.
SO.
AGAIN YOUR QUESTION IS HAS
MULTIPLE LAYERS TO IT --
IN TERMS OF THE TIME THAT IT
TAKES TO DO THINGS WERE YOU KNOW.
I WRENCH IN SOME OF THE TRADE
OFFS BETWEEN FOR INSTANCE
TRANSPARENCY AND PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT AND MOVING QUICKLY --
AND I WOULDN'T WANT TO SACRIFICE
THAT FOR INSTANCE --
WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE APA
PROCESS TO GET A PRIORITY
PRODUCT LISTED AND THAT MEANS
RESPONDING TO ALL THE COMMENTS
THAT CENTRIST SO THOSE ARE
CONSTRAINTS UNLESS --
UNLESS WE CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE A
FOR A PRIORITY PRODUCT LISTING
THAT'S GONNA TAKE WHAT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE --
I WOULD SAY THAT --
SOME OF THE RIVER THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE REPORT
BETTER CALL IN INFORMATION.
DID A CALL AND WE HAVE SPENT.
SURPRISING AMOUNT OF TIME TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT CHEMICALS ARE
AND WHAT PRODUCTS.
IT'S HARD.
IT IS REMARKABLY HARD THERE
INDUSTRY HAS COMMITTED TO DOING
SHARING MORE INFORMATION BUT
OFTEN THAT'S BEHIND PAY WALLS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS.
TO SO --
THAT'S THAT'S ONE BIG CHALLENGE
AND IS THAT SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE CONTROL OVER OR IS THERE
SOME FEDERAL PREEMPTION.
THAT WOULD PREVENT US FROM
REQUIRING.
THAT SHARING OF INFORMATION NOT
NECESSARILY WITH THE PUBLIC BUT
WITH YOU.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION --
I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANY
PROHIBITION AGAINST IT --
I THINK THAT IF IF IT WERE
CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION THAT HAD BEEN SHARED
WITH USEPA UNDER TOSCA AND THERE
MAY BE SOME RESTRICTIONS ABOUT
HOW THEY WOULD YOU KNOW ABOUT
SHARING INFORMATION THROUGH THAT
CHANNEL BUT IN OTHER WAYS I I
WOULD THINK THAT WE WOULD.
HAVE SOME ABILITY TO TO TAP INTO
THAT INFORMATION --
AGAIN THE RESOURCES --
HE BROUGHT A NUMBER OF NEW STAFF
ON JUST JUST WITHIN THE LAST
MONTH WE NINE WHEN ALL IS SAID
AND DONE. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT NEW
STAFF MEMBERS ALL AT ONCE AND
YOU CAN JUST ALREADY SEE HOW BIG
A DIFFERENCE THAT MAKES.
IN TERMS OF THEM COMING UP TO
SPEED DEVELOPING REC PACKAGES
MORE QUICKLY I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS DO YOU HAVE A WISH LIST THAT
WOULD HELP YOU GET THROUGH THESE
A LOT MORE QUICKLY --
MORE STAFF IS IS PROBABLY MY
NUMBER ONE WISH LIST --
AND THEN BETTER DATA CALLING
AUTHORITY IS VERY HIGH ON MY
WISH LIST AND THEN I WOULD SAY
THAT -- WE
THINK THAT THE TRAINS THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN.
GAINING MOMENTUM ARE GOING TO BE
VERY HELPFUL FOR US BUT I WOULD
SAY ON THAT FRONT --
SME OF THOSE HAVE COME WITHOUT
RESOURCES SO FOR INSTANCE THE
CLEANING PRODUCT RIGHT TO KNOW
IS HOMELESS IN TERMS OF IN TERMS
OF A STATUTE NOBODY REALLY OWNS
THAT.
AND SO YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT'S AN
AREA WHERE WE CAN'T GET THE
MAXIMUM VALUE OUT OF IT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW NOBODY'S WE DON'T EVEN
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO MECHANISM
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
ENFORCED AND IT'S IT'S KIND OF
IN LIMBO BETWEEN MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS AND DO YOU HAVE
DEDICATED.
FUNDING SOURCE AND WHAT IS IT
IT'S THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL ACCOUNT THAT IS IT IS IT
A IS IT A SEE A STATIC AMOUNT.
IT'S IT'S IT'S FUNDED BY
ENVIRONMENTAL FEES IT HAS A LOT
OF MY VARIATION FLUCTUATION AND
IT'S USED BY MUCH BIGGER PARTS
OF THE PROGRAM BY THAT OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
OKAY I JUST HAVE A FEW MORE --
SO THE LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSED
BILLS OVER THE YEARS DEALING
WITH ON INDIVIDUAL CHEMICALS
THAT COME TO OUR ATTENTION AND A
LOT OF TIMES WERE TOLD.
NO NO.
THAT'S NOT YOUR JOB WE HAVE THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM THEY'RE
GOING TO TAKE CARE OF IT RIGHT.
SO THAT CAN BE FRUSTRATING TO
OUR COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY HEARING
THAT YOU'VE GOT FIVE THOUSAND
CHEMICALS AND YOU'VE YOU KNOW
GOTTEN THROUGH A HANDFUL OF THEM.
SO.
DOES IT MAKE SENSE FOR US TO ACT
ON SOME OF THE SUBSTANCES GIVEN
HOW CHALLENGING IT'S BEEN FOR
YOU TO REGULATE THEM.
THERE ARE GOING TO BE CASES
WHERE WOULD MAKE SENSE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ACT --
PART OF THAT DEPENDS ON FOR
INSTANCE THE POTENTIAL FOR
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTES.
IF IF YOU'RE ACTING ON A
CHEMICAL WHERE THERE'S A HIGH
POTENTIAL FOR REGRETTABLE
SUBSTITUTES I THINK IT'S
RESPONSIBLE TO GO THROUGH THE
ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS PROCESS --
IF IT'S SOMETHING WHERE
EVERYBODY KNOWS THERE'S AN
ALTERNATIVE OUT THERE AND MAKE A
COUPLE MANUFACTURERS HAVE
ALREADY ADOPTED A SAFER
ALTERNATIVE.
YOU GET TO THE POINT WHERE IT IS
IT REALLY A IS THERE AN EXCUSE
TO STILL HAVE THAT PRODUCT ON
THE MARKET SO --
I THINK IT'S SITUATIONAL BUT I
DO THINK THERE ARE CASES IN
WHICH IT MAKES SENSE BUT SAYING
THAT WE SHOULDN'T BAN.
A DANGEROUS CHEMICAL BECAUSE
THEY MIGHT YOU SOMETHING WE
SHOULD KNOW THAT AND WE SHOULD
PROBABLY BàN ALL THOSE
CHEMICALS BUT I JUST I JUST HAVE
A EASE TO ISSUE MORE IT'S REALLY
YOU KNOW PESTICIDES ARE THE BEST
EXAMPLE OF THAT.
WHAT WE'VE DONE --
TO EVEN GETTING RID A LEADING
GAS AND GETTING IN TV AND NOW WE
HAVE GROUNDWATER COMMUNICATION --
CONTAMINATION ALL OVER THE STATE
WE END UP WITH THE BPA TO BE PS
TO WHATEVER.
AND AND SO WHEN.
YES THAT REALLY HAS TO INFORM
THE DECISION.
OKAY -- TWO
MORE QUICK QUESTIONS THE FIRST
IS --
DEREGULATION'S FRAMEWORK NOTES
THAT THAT THE STAKEHOLDERS
COMPETITION D. T. S. C. TO ADOPT
A PARTY PS PRODUCT AND I'M
WONDERING IF ANYONE HAS DONE
THAT WE'VE HAD TO PETITIONS HAVE
YOU ACCEPTED THEM A NO THE FIRST
PETITION WAS DENIED THE THE
PETITION PROCESS IS PRETTY.
EXTENSIVE.
AND REALLY WHAT THE PETITION
PETITIONER'S RECORD TO DO IS DO
THE SAME LEVEL OF DOCUMENTATION
OF ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
CALLED OUT IN THE REGULATIONS
THAT WE'RE REQUIRED TO CONSIDER.
WHEN THEY SUBMIT THEIR PETITIONS
SO IN THE --
FOR LININGS AND THE PETITIONER --
SUBMITTED A ON A FAIR AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION WE WORK WITH THE
PETITIONER TO STRENGTHEN THE
PETITION IN THE END WE DENIED IT
HOWEVER WE THOUGHT THERE WAS
ENOUGH CONCERN RAISED IN THE
PETITION THAT THAT WAS ONE OF
THE PRIME MOTIVATORS FOR US
PUTTING FOOD PACKAGING.
INTO OUR WORK PLAN AND THE
SUBSEQUENT WORK PLAN.
THAT WAS THE FIRST ONE THE
SECOND PETITION WE RECEIVED
ACTUALLY CAME FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION ARE THE
CALIFORNIA.
STORM WATER QUALITY ASSOCIATION
KASKA AND THAT WAS TO PETITION
FOR ZINC IN TIRES --
THERE ARE WATER BODIES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
GOING TO BE IMPAIRED OR ARE
ALREADY IMPAIRED FOR ZINC.
AND TIRES ARE ONCE OF ONE SOURCE
THAT -- IS
POTENTIALLY RIGHT FOR INNOVATION
AND SO WE'RE STILL WE'RE WORKING
WITH THAT PETITIONER DAVE
COMMITTED TO GIVING US
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION LATER
THIS SPRING.
AND AFTER SHORTLY AFTER THAT I
THINK WILL MAKE A DECISION ABOUT
THAT PETITION ANOTHER USE THOSE
TIRES TO MAKE ARTIFICIAL TURF
THE PEOPLE PUT IN THEIR YARDS
THEIR KIDS TO PLAN YEAH THAT'S A
FROM.
THE LASTLY DO YOU GIVE THOUGHT
TO THE SAFETY OF PRODUCTS WHEN
THEY'RE YOU WHEN THEY ARE.
PUT INTO EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES SO I'M THINKING OF
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER OF
PRODUCTS NOW THAT HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN FOREST FIRES.
SO HOMESTHAT HAD CHEMICALS THAT
MAYBE NOBODY ANTICIPATED BEING
INCINERATED BUT THE KNOWER AND
SISTER INSERTED IN TURN INTO
ACTION OR BREATHED.
AND SEX OR PRODUCTS THAT END UP
IN A OUR FLOOD PRONE AREAS IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU GIVE
CONSIDERATION TO BECAUSE THOSE
END UP --
YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY --
NOT THAT I'M COMMONLY I'M HAVING
THOSE KINDS OF CIRCUMSTANCES AND
YOU KNOW I WE'VE READ ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE HURRICANES IN THE SOUTH
AND THIS TOXIC BREW THAT YOU
KNOW WILL BE MAKES THE ENTIRE
STATE TOXIC.
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
GIVING ANY THOUGHT.
TO I WOULD SAY WE WE HAVEN'T
SINGLE THAT OUT MADE OUT OF
FOCUS OF OUR EFFORTS HOWEVER
THERE ARE A COUPLE CASES WHERE
THAT THAT KIND OF CONSIDERATION
IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT WITH
THE FLAME RETARDANTS.
THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT
FIREFIGHTERS ARE SUFFERING FROM.
SOME OF THE THE REPERCUSSIONS
FROM BEING EXPOSED TO THOSE
FLAME RETARDANTS AND OTHER
CHEMICALS ALSO IN AS THEY FIGHT
FIRES -- AND
SO THAT THAT GOES INTO THE
CONSIDERATION OF CERTAIN --
CERTAIN THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE
BUT THAT HAS NOT BEEN A FOCUS
BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT DGSE IS
THE FIRST DEPARTMENT THAT GOES
IN TO ALL OF THE FROM WILDFIRES
SITES.
AND EXPECTS WHETHER OR NOT THERE
ARE HAZARDOUS WASTE ON THOSE
SITES WE KNOW HOW MUCH HAZARDOUS
WASTE ISN'T IN.
ANY GIVEN HOUSEHOLD AND IT'S A
TREMENDOUS FOR CHEMICALS.
WOULD CERTAINLY BE IDEAL WELL
I'LL JUST CONCLUDE BY SAYING I
HOPE THAT WE CAN ACCELERATE YOUR
WORK AND THAT WE CAN SEE A
GREATER BODY OF WORK PRODUCT OUT
OF IT -- I
THINK THAT THE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
ASSUME THAT THIS IS ALREADY
HAPPENING AND A LOT OF THEM WILL
BE SURPRISED TO KNOW.
HOW MANY INCREDIBLY HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS THEY THEY AND THEIR
CHILDREN INTERACT WITH ON A
DAILY BASIS AND --
SO IF WE CAN BE AT ALL HELPFUL
YOU KNOW I'D LOVE. TO TO BE PART
OF OF CHANGING THAT EQUATION
THANK YOU THANK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS I THINK
YOU'VE GOT A HEART HEART OF A
LOT OF THE MATTERS THAT.
ARE THE REASON WE'RE HOLDING
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR ANSWERS
ARE SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU TO BOTH COMMITTEES FOR
QUICKNESS TOGETHER AND FOR YOUR
YOUR BIRTHDAY HERE --
ANNIVERSARY YEAR.
WHATEVER WE CALL THIS --
DOCTOR WILLIAMS I WANTED TO JUST
ASK YOU DRILL DOWN A LITTLE
FURTHER ON TWO ITEMS THAT YOU
MENTIONED THAT AND TREAT ME ONE
IS THIS --
THIS APPARENT LACK OF AUTHORITY
OR AMBIGUITY EVEN IF THEY'RE
ALREADY ABOUT DISCLOSURE OF THE
USE OF CHEMICALS IN CERTAIN
PRODUCTS THAT WAS GOING BACK
THROUGH THE ORIGINALLY BE
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE IN.
I MEAN IT'S IT'S I WOULD THINK
THE THE INTENT OF THE AUTHOR'S
ORIGINALLY WOULD BE ABLE TO I
MEAN EVEN IS HERE IT SAYS THAT.
YOU CAN YOU KNOW COLLECT THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO ADOPT
THE REGULATIONS AND WHAT HAVE
YOU JUST TELL US A LITTLE MORE
ABOUT THAT STORY OF TRYING TO
GET SOME OF THIS DATA FROM
INDUSTRY AND BARRIERS YOU FACE
IS THERE BEEN LITIGATION ON THIS
ISSUE WE HAVEN'T HAD LITIGATION
OKAY.
BUT I'M GONNA LET --
MISTER PALMER STICK TO THAT.
SURE I THINK --
YOU KNOW ARE STAFF WORK HARD TO
GET INFORMATION FROM A WIDE
VARIETY OF SOURCES YEAH YOU KNOW
PUBLIC DATABASES ARE COLLEAGUES
AND OTHER GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
AND THE INDUSTRY'S THEMSELVES
THE MANUFACTURE AND OFTEN WE GET
A LOT OF GOOD INFORMATION.
BUT OFTEN.
THEY'RE THE THERE'S AN
UNWILLINGNESS TO GIVE US
MULTIPLE SAID STEPHEN SOME OF
THE MANUFACTURERS OF PRODUCTS.
DON'T ENTIRELY KNOW ALL THE
CHEMICALS IN THEIR PRODUCTS
BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEX AND LONG
SUPPLY CHAINS SO --
WE DON'T HAVE DIRECT AUTHORITY
TO REQUEST.
THAT INFORMATION AND HAVE THEM
RESPOND TO US AND GIVE IT TO US
AS A REQUIREMENT WE HAVE A FORTY
REQUESTED.
AND THEY CAN SAY THANK YOU BUT
WE'RE NOT GONNA GIVE IT TO YOU
OR WHAT HAPPENS THEN THAT YOU
SAY.
PLEASE THEY SAY NO THANK YOU
THEN YOU SAY OKAY I MEAN IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE LEFT WITH IS THERE
NO WAY TO COMPEL.
WHAT DISCLOSURE WHAT WE CAN DO
AT THAT POINT IS WE CAN SAY?
WE CAN TELL THE PUBLIC THAT THIS
COMPANY CHOSE NOT TO SHARE
INFORMATION WITH US THAT'S WHAT
WE CAN DO.
AND IS THAT OCCURRED WE HAVE NOT
DONE IT YET WE HAVE HAD
OCCASIONS WHERE --
WE WERE ASSURED THAT INFORMATION
WAS FORTHCOMING --
REPEATEDLY AND WE HAVE NOT
RECEIVED SO SO HOW COMMON IS
LIKE HOW MANY TIMES DO YOU THINK
YOU'VE BEEN DENIED REQUESTS FOR
INFORMATION [inaudible]
SOME YEARS.
I DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW THE
NUMBER OF TIMES WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN DENIED I THINK THAT THE THE
BIGGER PROBLEM THIS IS FINDING --
AS SOMEONE WHO CAN TELL US WHAT
THEY KNOW AND IS WILLING TO GIVE
US THE INFORMATION SO --
ON ONE HAND WE DO HAVE THIS CALL
AN AUTHORITY THAT WHERE WE CAN
ASKING IF IT'S NOT CAN WE CAN
KIND OF PUBLICLY SAY THAT WE
WERE GIVEN IT BUT IT'S TYPICALLY
MORE.
OF A CHALLENGE OF GETTING THE
INFORMATION FROM --
IN THIS ACCURATE AND DETAILED
ENOUGH SO WE MIGHT GET GENERAL
INFORMATION BUT WE DON'T HAVE
FOR EXAMPLE ENOUGH INFORMATION.
TO TO DO ALL OF OUR WORK WE
MIGHT SAY THERE IS THIS CHEMICAL
NEVER WE DON'T OF THE
CONCENTRATION THAT CHEMICAL WAR
WE MIGHT KNOW CLASS OF CHEMICALS
OR IN THE CASE OF SAY FRAGRANCES --
THAT INFORMATION OFTEN THE
MANUFACTURE DOESN'T KNOW BECAUSE
THE FRAGRANCE HOUSES KEEP THAT
INFORMATION VERY CLOSE --
REGARDED AND THE MANUFACTURE MAY
NOT EVEN KNOW WHAT CHEMICALS ARE
IN THAT FRAGMENTS THEMSELVES SO.
THERE'S A LOT OF LAYERS AND NAME
IT MEAN DO THEY CLAIM THEY'RE
CONTRACTUALLY BOUND NOT TO EVEN
KNOW THAT THEY LIKE THEIR THEIR
AGREEMENT WITH SAY THE FRAGRANCE
HOUSE WOULDN'T ALLOW THEM TO SEE
THAT BECAUSE ITS PROPRIETARY AND
THAT KIND ARGUMENT.
YES BUT THERE I MEAN WE DO WITH
CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION AND MANY OTHER
CONTACTS AND GOVERNMENT RIGHT I
MEAN WE'VE DEALT WITH THAT KIND
OF DATA.
IN ALL.
OIL MARKETS IN YOU KNOW THE
FRACKING INDUSTRY IN ALL KINDS
OF SECTORS BUT SO WHY IS THIS
DIFFERENT.
WELL YOU'RE YOU'RE THE TO THE
COMPANY LET ME JUST INTERRUPT.
A DOCTOR SOLOMON WILL BE
SPEAKING AND ONE OF THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
ARE OF THE PANEL THAT LOOKED AT
THIS IS THAT WE GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT MORE AUTHORITY.
BY --
THEY'RE BRINGING UP EVEN IF YOU
GIVE THEM THAT ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY.
THEY MAY BE ABLE TO FIND THE
RIGHT PERSON TO TELL THEM BUT
THAT IS ONE OF THE REFORMS TO
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHICH OF COURSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN BROUGHT
UP AS WELL.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE REALLY
NEED TO WORK ON AND I'M PRETTY
SURE WE WELL.
I DON'T KNOW SOMEONE HAS A BILL
TO THAT EFFECT YET.
HI GENDER ALLEN HAS A BILL TO
THAT EFFECT ALREADY.
IS OUT I MIGHT GOOD ENDED THAT
LINE OF QUESTIONING BECAUSE IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU GUYS ARE FOUR
STEPS AHEAD OF ME THAT'S VERY
GOOD NEWS --
THE I JUST WANTED BRIEFLY ASK
ABOUT THAT --
THE THIS NOTION OF INNOVATION
AND THE LACK OF NEW I. P. AND
SORT OF VENTURE CAPITAL POURING
INTO ALTERNATIVE CHEMICALS SAFER
CHEMICALS --
I KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF OR
ADVANCED ENERGY RESEARCH IN THIS
STATE --
CERTAINLY EVEN FEDERALLY THERE'S
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY WE SPEND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR --
YOU KNOW RP AND IS THERE ARE
THERE ANY BEST PRACTICES OUT
THERE FOR FOLKS WHO ARE DOING
THE KINDS OF CHALLENGE GRANT
STORER INNOVATION PRIZES THAT
THAT WE COULD BE LOOKING TO
MAYBE IT FOR PRESIDENT THERE IS
IS.
KIND OF UNCHARTED TERRITORY --
I I DO THINK DOCTOR MALL THE
WHOLE PROBABLY KNOWS THAT
LANDSCAPE A LITTLE BETTER THAN
WE DO HOWEVER I WOULD SAY THAT
USEPA.
HAD A GREEN CHEMISTRY AWARDS
PROGRAM WHICH I BELIEVE IS
DISCONTINUED.
THIS IS A DISCONTINUED DOES
ANYBODY.
YEAH IS THERE WAS NO MY MONEY
ASSOCIATED WITH BUT UNDER THIS
IMAGE IT'S ACTUALLY NOT GOING TO
BE TOO EXCITED BUT IT REALLY
WHAT DID A GREAT JOB OF
HIGHLIGHTING AND SORRY AGAIN A
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA COMPANIES
THAT HAD BEEN.
INNOVATING AND MOVING AWAY FROM
TOXIC CHEMICALS.
GOT IT AND THAT SO THAT THAT WAS
AN AYE USEPA.
GRANT SURPRISE PROGRAM AS SOME
SORT.
AND IF YOU LOOKED AT ANY OTHER
EXISTING INNOVATION FUNDING THAT
MEAN LIKE I'M I'M THINKING IT'S
HARD OF THE STEPS TO GREENHOUSE
GAS NEXUS HERE BUT YOU KNOW WE
HAVE.
EVEN OPR IS DOING RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT GRANTS --
JUST TRYING TO THINK THE SMOKE
AND OF INNOVATION BUT IT'S AN A
CYCLOTRON ROAD WHICH IS A
PARTNERSHIP THAT ARE WITH RP
THEIR THERE --
THEIR THEIR MAINLY FOCUS AND
ENERGY BUT I KNOW THEY'RE DOING
SOME MATERIAL SCIENCE AND
CHEMISTRY.
THERE AS WELL WITH THE NATIONAL
LABS.
ANYWHERE ELSE.
TO ON YOUR MIND.
WELL YOU KNOW.
WE DON'T LOOK A LOT OF THAT
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A RESOURCE --
TO GIVE PEOPLE OR YOU TO I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT IN OUR
REGULATIONS ONCE WE GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS AFTER WE'VE REVIEWED
ON ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS IF WE
FEEL THAT --
THERE'S NO MOVEMENT TOWARDS A
CITY -- FOR
ALTERNATIVE AND THERE IS AN AREA
OF RESEARCH NEEDED WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE A WE CALL
REGULATORY RESPONSE WE WOULD.
ASK.
FOR THE MANY FACTORS TO FUND A
CHALLENGE GRANT THAT WOULD HELP
FILL SOME OF THIS DATA GAPS THAT
COULD MOVE.
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY SOLUTIONS
AND INNOVATION FOR CHOOSE THE
FASTER YOU HAVE ONLY AUTHORITY
HAVE YET SO WE HAVE A GOVERNOR
IN THE SENSE THAT IT'S GOT.
OKAY A THANK YOU MISTER THANK
YOU SENATOR HE BREAK UPS THE
EXCELLENT QUESTIONS AND WE WILL
BE LOOKING AT THE BUDGET.
LATER ON WILL BE LOOKING AT THAT
TOGETHER --
SO -- DOCTOR
WILLIAMS I HAVE A QUESTION
MYSELF.
MR SOMEONE ELSE HAS A QUESTION
FIRST OKAY GO AHEAD.
I ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARRIAGE
EIICHI THANK YOU I TRY TO FOLLOW
UP BUT A DOCTOR WILLIAMS ON YOUR
RESPONSE.
TO MISS FRIEDMAN'S QUESTION
ABOUT.
TO YOU KNOW HOW WE'RE OFTEN TOLD --
WITH WHAT YOU CHARACTERIZES THE
THE WHACK A MOLE APPROACH --
THAT -- THAT
THAT WE SHOULD DEFER TO THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROCESS AND YET
THERE IS THIS TREMENDOUS BACKLOG --
AND IT AND I I I THINK BECAUSE I
HEARD YOU SAY THAT.
THEIR THEIR BRAIN MAY BE.
SITUATIONS WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD PURSUE ALTERNATIVE
ANALYSES AND I WASN'T SURE IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE LAWS OF
NATURE.
THERE ARE PROVISIONS IN A
REGULATIONS SO THAT IF THE IF
THE LEGISLATURE'S CONCERNED.
ABOUT SOMETHING THEY CAN ASK US
TO LOOK INTO WOULD RUN THROUGH
OUR PROCESSES NORMAL.
SO FOR INSTANCE WE WERE ASKED TO
LOOK AT LEAD ACID BATTERIES AND
WE'RE DOING AN EVALUATION OF
LEAD ACID BATTERIES --
SO THAT'S ONE WAY TO FEED
PRODUCTS INTO OUR WORK IF THE
LEGISLATURE THINKS THAT ARE
ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL AND AND SO ARE YOU
ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT --
OF WHO WE WENT TO INDIVIDUAL
LESS LETTER --
BE OF THE REQUESTEDALTERMAN
ELSE'S ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW -- A
BILL HAVING TO BE PASSED IN
ORDER TO HAVE QUESTIONS WILL
WANT WE PROVIDE IN A PETITION
PROCESS --
BIAS IF AND IF WE ARE ASKED FOR
ANOTHER STATE AGENCY OR THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR.
TO LOOK AT A SPECIFIC PART
PRODUCT OR YOU COULD.
LEGISLATURE DID WITH LEAD ACID
BATTERIES AND GOVERNOR BROWN'S --
DESIRES AS WELL CITY SO IF A
INDIVIDUAL --
THE LEGISLATOR MADE TO REQUEST
THE YOU WOULD EXPEDITE THE
REQUEST AS AN ALTERNATE
ANNOUNCES.
WHAT WE'D BE DOING IS EXPEDITING
THE DECISION ABOUT LISTING IT AS
A PRIORITY PRODUCT WHICH THEN
WOULD TRIGGER THE ALTERNATIVES
ANALYSIS?
SO [inaudible]
IT'S BUT I WOULD I WOULD POINT
TO THE BILL THAT --
REMOVE THAT PROHIBITED CAN'T
CLAIM RETARDANTS IN CHILDREN'S
PRODUCTS LAST YEAR.
THAT'S NOT IN ANYWAY
CONTRADICTORY TO OUR REGULATIONS.
YOU KNOW THAT'S IN SO MANY OF
THOSE PRODUCTS THERE'S NO NEED
THERE'S NO NECESSITY TO HAVE
THOSE FLAME RETARDANTS SO IT
MAKES PERFECT SENSE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE ACTION. TO
BAN IT YEAH.
OKAY.
OKAY -- SO.
YOU MENTIONED --
BY THE WAY AT SO YOU'VE ADDED
EIGHT PEOPLE HOW MANY PEOPLE DID
YOU HAVE PRIOR TO THAT THIRTY TO
THIRTY TO SELL.
THAT FORTY PEOPLE SO EIGHT IS
NICE ADDITION BUT IT'S NOT A LOT
OF PEOPLE.
ARE ADDITIONAL TO WHAT YOU HAVE
IT'S A 15% OR SELL --
DON'T EXCUSE ME --
25% ANYWAY.
GOING -- TO
P. FAST MUCH AGREES THAT ONE HAS
TO LOOK AT GROUPS OF CHEMICALS --
RATHER THAN TRYING AS YOU SAID --
PLAYING WHACK A MOLE WITH ONE AT
A TIME.
AS WE WERE LOOKING AT P. FAST
LAST YEAR.
THERE WAS A GREAT CONSENSUS THAT
THE LONG CHAINS --
I THINK SIX CARBONS OR EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT CARBONS.
AND MORE WERE DEFINITELY A
CONCERN AND THEN THERE WAS A BIG
DISPUTE ABOUT THE SHORTER CHAINS --
AND I IT SUGGESTED THAT WE SEND
IT TO YOU AS A REQUEST TO GIVE
THAT PRIORITY IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT IT. FOR WHATEVER
REASON THEN THEY'LL STOPPED IN
THE SENATE I'M NOT QUITE SURE
WHY -- BUT
IN THAT CASE CAN'T.
AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT P. FAST NOW
IN.
CARPETS ARE YOU LOOKING AFTER
SHORT CHAINS SEPARATE FROM THE
LONG CHAINS KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THE MISS ONE CLASS RIGHT AND
THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT.
WE HAVE A SHORTHAND EXPRESSION
IT'S ALL ROADS LEAD TO PERFORM --
ALKYL ACIDS.
THOSE AS THE PFA ETS AND THAT'S
TO SAY THAT --
THAT'S THE THAT IS THE SUBSET OF
THE P. FAST FAMILY THAT'S THE
MOST WELL CHARACTERIZED AND MOST
WELL UNDERSTOOD TO HAVE TOXIC.
EFFECTS.
AT THE SAME TIME IF YOU LOOK AT
THE OTHER SUBCLASSES THEY EITHER
DEGRADED TO P. FAA'S OR PFA ETS
ARE USED TO MANUFACTURE THEM.
OR YOU KNOW THERE ARE THESE
INTERCONNECTIONS BETWEEN THE
CHEMICALS IN THE CLASS AND SO
THE THE THE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PFA ETS.
WAS ENOUGH TO MAKE A SAY.
WE'RE WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THIS AT THE AS A
WHOLE CLASS.
AND THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE
LONG CHAINS AND THE SHORTER
CHANGE IS IN SOME WAYS ARBITRARY
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S I THINK THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS THE LONG
CHAINS ARE WELL CHARACTERIZED.
RIGHT AND THAT'S WHY PEOPLE KNOW.
IT'S NOT THAT THE OTHERS ARE
[inaudible]
SAFER NECESSARILY I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE ANYBODY HAS CONCLUDED
THAT IT'S JUST THAT THEY'RE NOT
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN AS WIDELY
CHARACTERIZED SO WE WANT TO
PREVENT A CLAIM WAS THAT THEY
DON'T ACCUMULATE AND PEOPLE.
ARE AS THAT WAS THE CLIP THERE'D
THAT IS A CLAIM BUT IF YOU LOOK
AT THE CONSTANT EXPOSURE BECAUSE
THESE CHEMICALS STICK AROUND
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN SO MANY
PRODUCTS.
IT.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE GOING
TO STAY BE AN PEOPLE SYSTEMS AT
ANY GIVEN TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
DOCTOR SOLOMON [inaudible]
SO.
THERE WAS AT AN OUTSIDE REVIEW
OF THE PROGRAM.
WITH SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO
ACCELERATE --
THE THE PROGRAM SO COULD LOOK AT
MORE CHEMICALS MORE QUICKLY.
SO THAT.
THE PERSON WE'RE GONNA TALK TO
IS THE PRINCIPAL INVESTIGATOR AT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE DR
GINA SOLOMON.
TRIED A SUMMARY OF HER
EVALUATION OF CALIFORNIA'S GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM --
DR SOLOMON'S A REPORT AND
TESTIMONY IS ON THE WEBSITE
[inaudible]
AND IT'S CALLED CALIFORNIA'S
GREEN CHEMISTRY INITIATIVE AT
AGE.
TEN BY THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE AND DOCTOR SOLOMON.
ARE DOCTOR PEGGY RANNELLS AND
DOCTOR.
ON HONG OF THE UC SAN FRANCISCO --
ARE THE AUTHORS.
SO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
AFTERNOON --
DOCTOR QUIRK AND CHAIRMAN ALAN
AND MEMBERS OF BOTH COMMITTEES
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING
ME HERE I'M.
HONORED TO TO BE ABLE TO PREVENT
AT PRESENT TESTIMONY TODAY I AM
THE PRINCIPAL AUTHOR OF THE
STUDY -- OUT
ON CALIFORNIA'S GREEN CHEMISTRY
INITIATIVE AT AGE.
TEN AND THE STUDY WAS CONDUCTED
IS A RESEARCH COLLABORATION.
TWO AND YOU SEE SAN FRANCISCO
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO AREN'T
FAMILIAR WITH THAT PA TRY IT'S A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
PROMOTES HEALTH AND WELL BEING
AND QUALITY.
OF LIFE THROUGH RESEARCH POLICY
CHANGE AND DIRECT SERVICE.
THIS PROJECT WAS ALSO SUPPORTED
BY A GRANT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BREAST CANCER RESEARCH PROGRAM.
AT C. B. C. R. P. IS THE LARGEST
STATE FUNDED BREAST CANCER
RESEARCH EFFORT IN THE COUNTRY.
AND THAT PROGRAM IS FUNDED
THROUGH A PORTION OF THE TOBACCO
TAX -- AND
IS ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE UC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
IT FUNDS RESEARCH INTO THE
CAUSES AND THE PREVENTION OF
BREAST CANCER AND SO SOME OF THE
PROJECT --
LOOK AT POLICIES THAT HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO REDUCE BREAST
CANCER RISK --
AND SO THE NEXUS TO THIS PROJECT
IS THAT HUNDREDS OF CHEMICALS
HAVE BEEN LINKED TO BREAST
CANCER EITHER DIRECTLY IN HUMANS
OR ANIMALS WERE IN THROUGH
INDIRECT EVIDENCE SUCH AS
ESTROGENIC OF FACTS --
ESTROGENIC ACTIVITY --
AND MANY DOZENS OF THESE
CHEMICALS ARE STILL IN
WIDESPREAD USE IN CONSUMER
PRODUCTS.
IN FACT OF MY ANALYSIS FOUND A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN OF
BREAST CANCER RELEVANT CHEMICALS
ARE ON THE DTS SEE CAN IT
CHEMICALS LESS SAID THERE IS A
FAIR AMOUNT OF OVERLAP THERE --
THE RESEARCH PROJECT HOWEVER DO
THE LADY.
AT TO UP WITH EITHER POLICY
ENHANCEMENTS THAT COULD
STRENGTHEN THE CALIFORNIA GREEN
CHEMISTRY INITIATIVE FOCUSING ON
THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM THAT YOU JUST HEARD
ABOUT --
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED ENTRY BE --
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE ALSO
LOOKED AT THE TOXICS INFORMATION
CLEARING HOUSE --
UNDER SB --
FIVE OH NINE SO BE TALKING ABOUT
THE BOTH OF THOSE IN THE BROADER
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE REPORT IN THIS PRESENTATION
I'M HAPPY TO TALK.
IN MORE DETAIL ABOUT THE BREAST
CANCER SPECIFIC FINDINGS IN
RESPONSE TO ANY QUESTIONS --
AT THE END.
OF AND JUST TO SUMMARIZE WE GET
TO THE CHASE OF THE MAIN
FINDING OF THE STUDY ARE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA LAWS AND THE
PROGRAM ARE EXTREMELY INNOVATIVE
THEY HAVE A VERY BROAD.
IMPACT THE GOES VERY FAR OF
BECAUSE WORLDWIDE REALLY GOES
FAR BEYOND CALIFORNIA.
AND THE PROGRAM EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE KEY
ELEMENTS OF A STRONG REGULATORY
PROGRAM.
I DID FIND THAT TWO OF THE GAPS
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED IN THE
ORIGINAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT ACTUALLY.
SPURRED THE CREATION OF THESE
OUT.
OF THE PROGRAM THE DATA GAP AND
THE TECHNOLOGY GAP.
THIS TO THIS DAY THEY'VE BEEN
LARGELY UNADDRESSED
UNFORTUNATELY.
IN ADDITION THE SLOW PACE OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM
RELATIVE TO THE HUGE SCOPE OF
THE TASK --
AS WAS JUST DISCUSS.
IS.
IT HAS REALLY --
IMPAIRED ITS EFFECTIVENESS IN
ADDRESSING THE BIG BACKLOG OF
CHEMICALS AND PRODUCTS THAT
MIGHT REQUIRE EVALUATION --
SO JUST TO SUMMARIZE BRIEFLY THE
METHODOLOGY OF THE PROJECT
PROJECT IS A QUALITATIVE
RESEARCH PROJECT INCLUDED
SCOPING REVIEW OF THE LITERATURE
TO LOOK AT BEST PRACTICES.
IN CHEMICAL POLICY THAT HELPED
SERIES OF INTERVIEW QUESTIONS
THAN WE DID SEMI STRUCTURED
INTERVIEWS WITH EXPERTS IN GREEN
CHEMISTRY IN THE SCIENCE AND THE
POLICY ASPECTS OF GREEN
CHEMISTRY.
THOSE INTERVIEWS WERE TAPED
PROFESSIONALLY TRANSCRIBED EVERY
TRANSCRIPTION WAS CHECKED OUT BY
ME.
AND AND THEN THEY WERE COLLUDED
TO EXTRACT THEMES THAT.
EMERGED ACROSS THE DIFFERENT
INTERVIEWS.
SO -- I
INTERVIEWED TWO DOZEN EXPERTS
FROM GOVERNMENT ACADEMIA THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR --
THEY WERE SELECTED BASED ON BOTH
THEIR EXPERTISE AND ALSO AT THE
DIVERSITY OF OPINIONS THAT THEY
HAVE.
OTHER DIVERSITY OF VIEWPOINTS --
AND THAT WAS THE INITIAL ROUND
OF INTERVIEWS MORE THAN HALF OF
THOSE FOLKS WERE IN CALIFORNIA
BUT I LOOKED AT PEOPLE FROM
OTHER STATE INTERVIEWED PEOPLE
FROM OTHER STATES NATIONALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY --
AND THE INTERVIEWS --
ULTIMATELY IDENTIFIED GENERATED
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED TEXT
EXCERPTS FOR ANALYSIS.
THEN THE PRELIMINARY FINDINGS
FROM THAT FIRST ROUND WERE
PRESENTED ONE ON ONE IN THE
SECOND ROUND OF INTERVIEWS THAT
WERE LESS STRUCTURED.
WITH TEN ADDITIONAL EXPERTS FROM
ALL DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES AND
FINDINGS WERE FIND BASED ON THE
FEEDBACK AND THE ENTIRE PROJECT
WAS OVERSEEN BY AN EIGHT MEMBER
SCIENCE POLICY ADVISORY GROUP.
SO THE FINDINGS REALLY WERE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA GREEN CHEMISTRY
LAWS IN GENERAL --
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE IS.
AND THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM --
WERE CITED BY. THREE QUARTERS OF
EXPERTS FROM ALL PERSPECTIVES AS
UNIQUE INNOVATIVE.
HAVING A VERY BROAD SCOPE AND AN
INTERNATIONAL IMPACT SO I THINK
WE CAN BE --
IMPRESSED AND PROUD OF THAT
FINDING. ONE BUSINESS SCIENTISTS
FROM OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA IS BEING
A PUT IT WELL I THINK BY SAYING
I THINK THE CALIFORNIA IS TRYING
TO DO THINGS THAT NOBODY'S DONE
BEFORE --
WHICH IS WHAT I THOUGHT WAS UP A
PLUS IT'S CERTAINLY BY THE
CONTEXT --
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM
WAS ALSO RECOGNIZED BY MOST
EXPERTS AS HAVING FOUR MAIN
OTHER STRENGTHS HEADS VERY BROAD
SCOPE IN AUTHORITY ACROSS ENTIRE
CLASSES OF CHEMICALS AS YOU'VE
HEARD AND ACROSS.
A HUGE SWATH OF CONSUMER
PRODUCTS --
SECONDLY IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
PROMOTE INNOVATION AND REDUCE
THIS RISK OF REGRETTABLE
SUBSTITUTION THAT WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT TODAY.
THIRDLY AT THERE'S A FOCUS AT
KAT COMMENDABLE FOCUS ON
PROTECTING VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND SUB GROUPS SUCH
AS CHILDREN.
AND FINALLY --
THERE ARE MULTIPLE OPPORTUNITIES
SAYS SO THOSE FOUR THINGS WERE
ARE REALLY VERY --
CAME UP OVER AND OVER AGAIN IS
VERY SOLID --
SO DOCTOR OVER HELL MENTIONED
THE THREE GAPS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THE ORIGINAL TWO
THOUSAND SIX REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE UP FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA BY A
DOCTOR'S MIKE WILSON WHO I
BELIEVE IS IN THE AUDIENCE HERE
TODAY -- AND
DOCTOR MAKE SCHWARTZMAN QUITE
BELIEVE IS WATCHING THAT WEBCAST
UP FROM UC BERKELEY --
AND OUR FINDINGS IN THIS PROJECT
SUPPORTED THE ANALYSIS OF THESE
THREE GAPS BUT ALSO IDENTIFIED
THAT THERE SUB COMPONENTS OF
EACH OF THESE THREE GAPS.
AND SO I THINK IT TOO USEFUL
FRAMING FOR SOME OF THE FINDINGS
IN THE REPORT SO AS A REMINDER
THE THREE GAPS ARE THE DATA GAP --
THAT SAFETY GAP AND THE
TECHNOLOGY GAP.
AND THE DATA GAP.
COME TO GO BACK TO THAT --
WELL JUST TO SUMMARIZE THE MAIN
WEAKNESSES IN THE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM OR THAT THE DATA GAP IN
THE TECHNOLOGY GAP.
ARE SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS THEY
STILL HAVE NOT REALLY BEEN
ADDRESSED BY THE LEGISLATION
THAT'S IN PLACE MISS SAFETY GAP
IS PARTLY ADDRESSED --
SO LOOKING AT THE DATA GAP THERE
ACTUALLY THREE COMPONENTS OF THE
DATA GAP. ONE IS GAPS IN
CHEMICAL TOXICITY DATA AND OTHER
WORDS.
IT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT SOME OF
THE P. FASTS CHEMICALS BEING
WELL STUDIED SOME OF THEM NOT
BEING WELL STUDIED THEIR DATA
GAPS IN THE TOXICITY.
THAT HIM TESTING THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE --
THAT'S GONNA HAVE TWO PROBLEMS
ONE IS IT CAN MAKE THE
ALTERNATES ANALYSES A LOT HARDER
TO DO BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO BE --
EXPECTING TURN ITS ANALYSES
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT CHEMICALS
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
FULLY TESTED OR SCREEN --
FOR DIFFERENT EFFECTS ON HUMAN
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT --
THEN IN ADDITION IT COULD --
KEEP THE KENNETT CHEMICALS LIST
FROM BEING AS FULLY UP TO DATE
AS IT SHOULD BE.
A LOT OF CHEMICALS ON THAT LIST
BUT THEY'RE STILL NORMA'S NUMBER
OUT THERE THAT REALLY HAVEN'T
BEEN --
SCREENED AND WE DON'T KNOW IF
THEY SHOULD BE ON THE LIST OR
NOT SAID THAT IS --
UP PROBLEM.
THIS GAP THOUGH COULD BE
ADDRESSED BECAUSE THEY'RE NEW
PREDICTIVE TOXICOLOGY METHODS
THAT ARE.
ACTUALLY DEVELOPING INCREDIBLY
RAPIDLY THAT ALLOWS --
ALLOWS VERY I THINK AFFECTED
PREDICTION OF TOXICITY OF
CHEMICALS.
AND A WE HA THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT IS DEVELOPING THE
ABILITY TO TO USE THESE METHODS.
AND COULD USE THEM TO ANTICIPATE
THE HAZARDS OF EMERGING
CHEMICALS SO THIS IS A A
POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITY I THINK --
THEN THE SECOND DAY THE GAP IS
THE GAP OF IT IN EXPOSURE DATA.
ON IT TOO VERY HARD TO KNOW
WHAT'S GETTING IN ENVIRONMENT
FACT AGAIN TO USE THE P. FAST
EXAMPLE THOSE CHEMICALS BECAME
EXTREMELY WIDESPREAD IN WATER --
AND AND SOIL CONTAMINATION IN
EVEN -- YOU
KNOW THERE'S AIRBORNE THEIR P.
FAST ETHER IS THERE'S AIRBORNE.
HAZARDS AS WELL --
SO THE IDEA THAT THERE WASN'T A
REAL THERE ISN'T A REALIZATION
OFTEN THAT THESE CHEMICALS ARE
GETTING OUT THERE INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND TELL --
KIND OF LATE IN THE PROCESS.
THAT COULD BE ADDRESSED BY
EXPANDING THE BIO MONITORING
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM TO BETTER.
AT TRACK CHEMICALS IN PEOPLE.
AND ALSO BY ENHANCING AND BETTER
INTEGRATING ENVIRONMENTAL
MONITORING THAT'S GOING ON ON
CHEMICALS IN THE AIR WATER FOOD
AND PRODUCTS --
AND THEN FINALLY THERE'S THE
GAPS THAT THE PART OF THE DATA
GAP THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT SO
FAR TODAY WHICH IS THE GAP ON
INGREDIENTS INFORMATION AND
PRODUCTS.
AND THAT IS JUST A THRESHOLD
PROBLEM FOR DTS SEE.
THAT WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO
PRIORITIZE CHEMICALS AND
PRODUCTS FOR REGULATION AND TO
THE PROGRAM IT'S IT'S VERY HARD
AND IT'S EM ONE OF THE QUOTES
THAT GOT ACTION TING EXPEDITION.
YOU CAN SPEND A LOT OF TIME AND
MONEY LOOKING AT THINGS THAT
AREN'T HIGH IMPACT.
AND I THINK THAT IT'S REALLY UP
THAT CAPTURES THE PROBLEM.
AND AT ANOTHER SCIENTIST WHO I
INTERVIEWED --
SAID THAT CHEMICAL USE
INFORMATION IT'S REALLY
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE SIMPLY
GOING TO HAVE TO GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT THE AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE.
AND THAT THE THIRTY OUGHT TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR PRODUCTS.
OUT WHAT ARE THE INGREDIENTS IN
THIS CUP FOR EXAMPLE.
AND FOR CHEMICAL MANUFACTURERS
IN OTHER WORDS WE'RE ARE YOU
SELLING YOUR CHEMICAL LACKS.
SO THAT THEY CAN COME OUT OF
FROM BOTH PERSPECTIVES AND THEN
THAT SPEAKS TO THIS ISSUE IN THE%
BAY AREA --
IAN WE'RE WE'RE DETAILS HE SAID
SOMETIMES THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHO TO ASK --
AND IF THESE QUESTIONS ABOUT --
THE PEOPLE NOT EVEN KNOWING
WHAT'S COMING THROUGH THEIR
SUPPLY CHAINS --
SAID THEY DID A GAP THOUGH IT
AIN'T IN INGREDIENTS INFORMATION
RELATES DIRECTLY THE OTHER
BIGGEST CHALLENGE OF THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM WHICH
IS THE SLOW PACE OF THE PROGRAM.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT --
THE DIFFICULTY [inaudible]
FINDING INFORMATION HAS REALLY
SLOW THE PROGRAM DOWN --
ALMOST EVERYONE WHO I
INTERVIEWED.
SAID THAT THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
VERY SLOW.
AND SOME SOME SAID THAT'S TO BE
EXPECTED --
GIVEN THAT IT'S BEEN GETTING UP
AND RUNNING --
AND OTHERS SAID THAT IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE OF SOME OF FROM AN
NGO SAID IT'S MOVING AT A PACE
THAT SINCE THE PROGRAM.
AND AND I THINK THAT --
I'VE HEARD SOME OF THAT TODAY --
SOMEONE FROM FROM GOVERNMENT
SAID THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM IS LIKE A MACHINE AND
THEY BUILT THE MACHINE THAT
TESTING THE MACHINE THE WIDGETS
MACHINE.
ALL OF THAT TAKES TIME.
AND BEFORE YOU START ALTERING
THE MACHINE YOU HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL THE PIECES WORK.
AND THEN YOU CAN GO BACK AND
INCREASE THE SPEED.
AND SO UP I THINK ONE OF THE
FINDINGS OF THE REPORT IS AT
THIS POINT THE MACHINE IS BUILT
AND TESTED.
SO NOW IT'S TIME TO GO BACK AND
INCREASE THE SPEED.
HOW DO WE DO THAT WE'LL?
SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE
BEEN MADE AROUND THAT ONE KEY
RECOMMENDATION OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE
HEARD THIS IS TO INCREASE THE
FUNDING AND THE STAFF.
CURRENT PROGRAM IS SEVERELY
UNDER RESOURCE DID DOESN'T HAVE
ITS OWN DEDICATED FUNDING SOURCE --
STAFF IS TOO SMALL FOR THE
MANDATE --
AND THE PROBLEMS DO YOU NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED AND IN FACT --
I FOUND THAT CAN NEEDS --
TO TO REALLY RECOGNIZE ITS STATE
SCIENTISTS AND PAY THEM WHAT
THEY'RE WORTH --
IT'S BEEN IT'S DIFFICULT --
IF BOND UNDER --
IN THE STATE. TO REALLY RECRUIT
THE BEST AND THE BRIGHTEST
SCIENTISTS.
INTO THESE JOBS BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE HAVING TO TAKE SUCH A
MASSIVE SALARY CUT IN ORDER TO
DO IT AND SO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF COMMITTED
PEOPLE WHO DO YOU DO THAT THAT
NIGHT AND I COMMEND THEM --
IT'S IT'S GREAT THAT THEY DO --
BUT THERE IS ANOTHER WAY TO
INCREASE SPEED AND THAT IS THAT.
THERE IS REALLY ONLY ONE PATHWAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS AT RIGHT NOW --
AT AND IT REQUIRES THIS YEAR
REGULATION WHOLE REGULATORY
PROCESS TO JUST IDENTIFY A
PRODUCT CHEMICAL COMBINATION.
THERE COULD BE OTHER FAST TRACKS
THAT WOULD HELP MOVE CHEMICALS
CHEMICAL PRODUCT COMBINATIONS TO
ROOM MORE QUICKLY IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES --
SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW IF THE
PATH FORWARD IS REALLY OBVIOUS
OR IF THE CHEMICAL IS NOT
NECESSARY FOR THE FUNCTION OF
THE PRODUCT.
THEN YOU'D IS THERE REALLY A
NEED FOR A FULL.
PROCESS LEADING INTO A FULL
ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS THAT THEN
GOES ON TO TO AT A AT A
REGULATORY DECISION SOMEONE FROM
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY SUGGESTED
SOMETHING JUST LIKE THAT AB THAT
SAID.
IF YOU CAN FIND INGREDIENTS THE
DON'T CONTRIBUTE TO THE FUNCTION
OF THE PRODUCT.
AND THEY'RE CAUSING AT LEAST A
PERCEIVED PROBLEM OR AN
ESTABLISHED PROBLEM.
IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT THOSE
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T BE IN THERE.
SORT OF A COMMON SENSE APPROACH --
THIS AT THE FLAME RETURN TO NAP
MATS CAME UP --
JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO THAT'S A
REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING
WHERE IT DIDN'T NEED TO BE IN
THE PRODUCT FOR THE FUNCTION OF
THE PRODUCT TO IN FACT WHEN.
THE DEPARTMENT STARTED THE
REGULATORY PROCESS MANUFACTURES
VOLUNTARILY WENT AHEAD AND
REMOVE THE FLAME RETARDANTS FROM
THEM NOT MATCH THAT'S GREAT
[inaudible]
HOWEVER.
THAT MEANT THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE HAD NOT VAN ACTED TO
BAN FLAME RETARDANTS FROM NAP
MATS.
THE DEPARTMENT WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BAN THEM EITHER.
BECAUSE BY THE TIME THEY WERE
DEAD DTS SEE WAS READY.
TO RECEIVE ALTERNATES ANALYSES.
THERE WEREN'T ANY TO RECEIVE.
AND SO THE PROCESS AND IT --
DETAILS HE WENT OUT VERIFIED
THAT THERE AREN'T FLAME
RETARDANTS IN THAT MATCH AT THIS
POINT IN TIME THAT'S GREAT.
IF.
COUPLE YEARS FROM NOW.
IF THERE HADN'T BEEN LEGISLATION
COUPLE YEARS FROM NOW SEVERAL
COMPANIES COULD HAVE STARTED PUT
FLAME RETURNS BACK IN THAT
MATT'S --
BECAUSE DTS HE'S UNABLE TO
ACTUALLY FINISH THE PROCESS AND
BàN.
A FLAME RETARDANT IN AND NOT
MATT IF THEY DON'T GET --
A PROBLEM AS WELL THAT AN WHERE
THEY COULD SORT OF CUT TO THE
CHASE AND JUST TAKE A REGULATORY
ACTION -- SO
THOSE ARE A COUPLE OF
SUGGESTIONS --
AND AND THEN THE OTHER ISSUES
THAT CAME UP THAT I THINK --
YEAH I FOUNDER MORE
CONTROVERSIAL AMONG --
MEMBERS OF THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY BUT RELATE TO SOME OF
THE PREVIOUS DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHETHER THE LEGISLATURE --
SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT BE ACTING
ON PRODUCTS IS THAT --
LEGISLATURE COULD --
IF THEY WANTED IF YOU KNOW
LEGISLATURE ONE TO TAKE ACTION
ON A CHEMICAL IN PRODUCT.
BUT WAS WORRIED ABOUT THIS ISSUE
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTION SAID
WANTED SOME SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS.
COULD.
SKIP THE INITIAL --
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT
PROCESS FOR THAT PRODUCT
IDENTIFICATION.
AND JUST PUT THE PRODUCT
DIRECTLY INTO THE ALTERNATES
ANALYSIS --
AND THEN IN A MAKE IT WITH A
DECISION PENDING THE RESULTS
CSUS -- SO
THAT'S ONE ONE OP OPTION THAT
COULD OCCUR --
SO THE JUST FOR QUICK MENTION
RIGHT THE END ABOUT SB FIVE OH
NINE THE OTHER STATUTE THAT WAS --
PASSED AS PART OF THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY INITIATIVE PACKAGE.
THE TOXICS INFORMATION CLEARING
HOUSE THAT WAS CREATED UNDER
THAT LAW UNIVERSALLY SEEN OUT BY
THE EXPERTS AS NOT AT ALL USEFUL --
AND MANY EXPERTS SAID THAT THE
ORIGINAL VISION FOR THAT
CLEARING HOUSE REALLY HAS BEEN.
FULLY SUPERSEDED BY OTHER TOOLS
THAT ARE NOW OUT THERE --
SO SOME PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF
THAT RECOMMENDED JUST GETTING
RID OF THE TAX INFORMATION
CLEARINGHOUSE ABOLISHING IT ALL
TOGETHER --
OTHERS SUGGESTED KEEPING IT BUT
RESHAPING ARE SHIFTING THE
MANDATE AND THE PURPOSE --
AND SPECIFICALLY AN IDEA THAT
CAME UP.
I THOUGHT WAS VERY INTERESTING.
OF RELATED TO THE HAZARD TRAITS
ALSO MANDATED UNDER SB FIVE OH
NINE THE HAZARD TRAITS WERE
IDENTIFIED BY A WE HA.
UP BACK IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND WERE PRAISED
BY OUT MANY OF THE EXPERTS THAT
I INTERVIEWED AS BEING VISIONARY
AND VERY USEFUL AND FOUNDATIONAL.
FOR FIRST SURVEY CONCEPTUAL
FRAMEWORK ALL HAZARDS --
AND TO SOME EXPERTS SUGGESTED
TRANSFERRING THE TACTICS
INFORMATION CLEARING HOUSE TO A
WE HAVE.
AND USING THE CLEARING HOUSE TO
HOUSE INFORMATION ON CHEMICALS
THAT ARE SCREENED USING NEW
PREDICTIVE TOXICOLOGY METHODS.
AND THIS HAS SOME BENEFITS WOULD
ACTUALLY DRESS THREE PROBLEMS AT
ONCE IT WOULD ADDRESS THE
TOXICOLOGY DEEDED CAP THAT I
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY.
IT WOULD REPURPOSE THE TOXICS
INFORMATION CLEARING HOUSE AND
GIVE IT A NEW LIFE.
AND THIRDLY IT WOULD.
ALLOW --
SORT OF THE POTENTIAL TO UPDATE
THE CANDIDATE CHEMICALS LIST
OVER TIME.
WITH NEW SCIENCE AS IT EMERGES
SO FOR EXAMPLE --
AT AND BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE --
EXPERT SCIENTIST WHO I
INTERVIEWED FROM OUT OF STATE
SAID.
SAID WE COULD BE DOING MORE WITH
THE KENNEDY CHEMICAL CELESTE.
EN ADDING AND THEY COULD BE
ADDING CHEMICALS HAS THEY ASSESS
THE HAZARD USING NOT JUST
TRADITIONAL STUFF.
THE PERSON MEANT TOXICOLOGY DATA
BUT THE NEWER METHODS.
SO THAT --
THAT IDEA I THOUGHT WAS --
INTERESTED A AN INTERESTING WAY
TO MOVE THE SCIENCE FORWARD --
AND THEN I MENTION THE
TECHNOLOGY GAP A COUPLE TIMES --
AND THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT --
DOCTOR MULVIHILL TALKED ABOUT
QUITE A BIT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY IT IT WAS
NEVER REALLY ADDRESSED --
IN THE OR FROM THE ORIGINAL
GREEN CHEMISTRY INITIATIVE
VISION.
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IT'S THE CARAT TO THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM STICK --
AND IT'S AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP.
IT'S ALSO AN ISSUE THE GENERATED
ACROSS THE BOARD IN THE Z. AS IN
FOR EVERY STAKEHOLDER THAT I
SPOKE WITH --
SAID THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT
REALLY WAS.
IN A VERY.
VERY RECEIVE VERY WIDESPREAD
ENTHUSIASTIC --
ENDORSEMENT --
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT I
THOUGHT WERE INTERESTING.
OF ONE PERSON FROM AN NGO
PERSPECTIVE SAID IT'S A LOT
EASIER TO PUT PRESSURE ON
SOMEBODY TO TAKE SOMETHING BAD
OUT IF YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO
TURN -- TO
AND ANOTHER ANOTHER COMMENT FROM
ANOTHER NGO A PERSPECTIVE IT
SAID WE NEED CAP WE NEED TO
ASSIST CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES TO
LEAD THE WORLD IN GREEN --
DESIGN AND PRODUCTION.
AND THEN IF THE PROGRAM ACTUALLY
PRIORITIZE HAVE A SAFER
SUBSTITUTE CAN INCENTIVIZE THE
INDUSTRY TO COME UP WITH THAT.
IF YOU FINISH IN THE NEXT MAN
YEAH APPS ALMOST DONE OKAY --
SO AND I AND SO BE OF PEOPLE
ALSO POINTED TO THE BERKELEY
CENTER FOR GREEN CHEMISTRY IS A
MODEL THAT COULD BE EXPANDED
COULD BE REPLICATED AT OTHER.
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES AND ALSO PEOPLE POINTED
TO ONE CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP AND
CLEAN ENERGY AND THE BENEFITS
THAT THAT'S BROUGHT TO OUR STATE
WHICH IS A COMPARABLE
OPPORTUNITY.
SAID THOSE I THINK ARE THE
OVERALL RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
REPORT AND TâM.
AND I THINK THAT --
OVERALL THE THE MESSAGE --
AND FINDINGS OF THE REPORT ARE
THAT THIS IS EXTREMELY STRONG.
PROGRAM THAT WE ARE LUCKY TO
HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT THAT
THERE IT'S IT'S NOT QUITE ALL
THE WAY THERE AND THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT COULD BE DONE. TO
REALLY --
RING THAT VISION FULLY TO
FRUITION THAT WOULD --
BILL THAT A STRONGER SAFER STE
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM A MORE
RELEVANT CLEARING HOUSE IF
CHEMICAL HAZARD TRAITS.
AND A VIBRANT GREEN CHEMISTRY
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU DOCTOR SOLOMON FOR
WORKING ON THIS PROJECT AND FOR
THE OTHER ALL CO AUTHORS AS WELL.
OF THIS IS SAM.
MACHINE WASTE WHICH WE CAN HELP
MAKE THE PROGRAM BETTER THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO US.
I WANTED TO PARTICULARLY ASKING
FOR A LITTLE MORE DETAIL ON THE
IDEA SO WE HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE
TO GET RID OF THE TOXIC LAST.
FORTY CHANGE BRING IT TO ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT AND USE PREDICTIVE
OUR CHEMISTRY AGAIN.
REVOLUTION WE HAVE WITH
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WITH.
A GREAT AMOUNT OF COMPUTER POWER
HAVE GREAT BELIEF IN THAT SYSTEM.
COULD YOU --
MAYBE CONTRAST THOSE TWO
ALTERNATIVES AND WHAT YOU SEE IS
THE ADVANTAGE DO YOU SEE A A
REAL ADVANTAGE IN.
HAVING THIS LIST AND THEN OF
CHEMISTRY.
I THINK THE REAL ISSUE IS THAT --
THE PREDICTIVE CHEMISTRY THE
PREDICTIVE TOXICOLOGY.
IS IS MOVING FAST AND THERE IS A
GLOBAL VISION OF HOW TO MOVE
THAT FORWARD SOME OF ITS DRIVEN
BY -- INTO
IT A RELUCTANCE TO TO DO AS MUCH
ANIMAL TESTING HAS BEEN DONE THE
AND AND THAT AND ALSO
RECOGNIZING THE ENORMOUS.
DELAYS AND BACKLOGS IF OF
CHEMICAL TESTING --
AND AND ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT
THE ADVANTAGES OF SOME OF THE
NEW MODELS --
AND SO AS A STATE WE SHOULD BE
ON THAT TRAIN.
AND WE SHOULD BE ACTUALLY NO.
BUILDING THE INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
THE IN CALLEY PA. TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE SIN OF THIS NEW
FIREHOSE OF DATA THAT'S COMING
OUT.
IN USING IT FOR GOOD TO HEAR AT
THIS IS A BASIS FOR GOOD
DECISIONS.
AND IT'S GREAT BECAUSE WE CAN
ACTUALLY COVER.
LITERALLY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CHEMICALS WE WERE AS WERE
TALKING ABOUT MANY FEWER WITH
STANDARD TOXICOLOGY TESTING SO
WITH THEIR SO I THINK THE ISSUE
IS.
IF WE WANT TO DO THAT. ONE WAY
TO DO IT WOULD BE TO USE THIS
TOXICS INFORMATION CLEARING
HOUSE COMBINED WITH THE HAZARD
TRAITS TO HELP SORT OF GIVE THAT
A LITTLE.
SEND OFF A LITTLE NUDGE TO HELP --
MAKE IT HAPPEN THERE WOULD BE
OTHER WAYS TO DO IT SO I DON'T
THINK THAT THIS IS THE ONLY ONE
WAY TO THINK ONLY WHERE OUR
POLITICIANS WERE GONNA DEPEND
UPON -- YOU
AND OTHERS TO DO.
SO.
CENTER ALLEN IS LOOKING AT THIS
IN HIS BILL AND I WOULD JUST SAY --
PLEASE HELP US --
MAKE SOME GOOD DECISIONS IN THIS
AREA AND I KNOW AS A SCIENTIST
WE ALWAYS SAY ON THE ONE HAND ON
THE OTHER HAND BECAUSE THE OTHER
SCIENTISTS ARE GOING TO GET
AFTER REST.
IF WE SAY THERE'S CERTAINTY --
BUT I REALLY THINK WE NEED YOUR
BEST JUDGMENT AND WE CAN --
GO THROUGH THAT AT ANOTHER TIME
BUT IF YOU COULD HELP US --
CONSIDER THAT I I I AM A GREAT
BELIEVER.
THAT WE WILL NEVER HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY AND TIME TO DO ALL OF THE
EXPERIMENTS WE NEED TO DO PLUS
WE HAVE.
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LAB ANIMALS
IT CETERA AND SO I THINK WE NEED
TO ENCOURAGE THIS APPROACH AND I
WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE TO SEE IT --
TELL THANK YOU AND I THINK ONE
PROBLEM WITH THAT THAT OF COURSE
IS THE CLEARING HOUSE IS UNDER
RESOURCES --
TO OR REALLY NOT.
WE UNDER RESEARCH EVERYTHING
JUST SO YOU'RE NOW --
BUT YOU KNOW SO IS SO I THINK
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING TO WAY
THAT IF IT YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
FOR WERE ICY --
IF A WERE MOVED TO A WE HAD THAN
THAT THERE WOULD STILL BE A NEED
FOR THAT FOR RESOURCES --
TO TO TO TURN IT INTO SOMETHING
THAT WOULD --
THE THE YOU KNOW THANK SO --
WE DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT THAT THE BUDGET AS
WELL ARTS CENTER ALLEN DID YOU
HAVE A COMMENT YEAH WELL I I
JUST WANNA ASK YOU MEAN A PIGGY
BACKING ON THE QUESTIONS OF THE
CHAIR -- YOU
HAVE SOME FOLKS CALLING FOR THE
ALL THE ALL.
ALL THE ELIMINATION THE TCL
TOGETHER.
OUT WHAT WHAT DO YOU SEE
[inaudible]
AS DID YOU SEE ANY VALUE IN THE
CLEARING HOUSE AS IT STANDS
RIGHT NOW AND AND IF IT WERE TO
BE ELIMINATED.
I IS THERE ANYTHING THAT WE
WOULD NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WOULD REPLICATE ELSEWHERE WERE
FOUR HOUSE ELSE WHERE.
ARE YOU KNOW.
BECAUSE GETTING RID OF AN ENTIRE.
ENTITY WITHIN THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE MAY HAVE CAUSE
UNFORESEEN.
CONSEQUENCES.
OR OR MAYBE NOT --
YOU'VE LOOKED INTO A VERY
INTENTLY YEAH I MEAN THE
CLEARING HOUSE ITSELF AS IT
EXISTS NOW --
COULD BE ELIMINATED WITH REALLY
MEAN. TO BE HONEST NO ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT --
PROVIDING ADDED BENEFIT IN ITS
CURRENT FORM AND SO WHEN YOU
HAVE SOMETHING.
THAT'S NOT PROVIDING ADEQUATE
BEYOND ANY BENEFIT YOU CAN
ELIMINATE IT FOR YOU CAN SORT OF
TAKE IT AND THINK WELL WHAT DO
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT COULD THIS BE.
THAT IS NEEDED AND THEN
TRANSFORM IT AND I THINK BOTH
ARE REASONABLE --
PERSPECTIVES AND I CERTAINLY
FROM THE EXPERTS THAT I
INTERVIEWED THERE WAS NOT A
CONSENSUS ON THIS ISSUE.
MY MY FEELING --
AND THIS IS JUST ME I'M MUCH
MORE MY BIAS --
SCIENTIFICALLY IS THAT I FEEL
THAT THERE.
THE THAT THE SB --
FIVE OH NINE MANDATED THAT A
WEEK HA.
ARTICULATE HAZARD TRAITS OF
CHEMICALS AND WE HAD DID IT IN A
WAY THAT RECOGNIZED WHERE'S THE
SCIENCE WAS GOING.
AND INCORPORATES THESE THROUGH
PREDICTIVE METHODS --
AND IT -- IT
WOULD BE A NICE FIT. TO USED. TO
REPURPOSE THE CLEARING HOUSE TO
HOUSE INFORMATION ON CHEMICALS
THEY'RE NOT.
ON THE KENNEDY CHEMICALS LIST --
BECAUSE THEY DON'T RISE TO THAT
LEVEL BUT WHERE THERE'S
INFORMATION FROM PREDICTIVE
TOXICOLOGY THAT MIGHT RAISE
FLAGS AND THEN THAT WOULD BE A
RESOURCE FOR EXAMPLE FOR
COMPANIES.
THEY'RE DOING ALTERNATES
ANALYSES AND THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A CALF GOT THESE
SEVEN CHEMICALS THAT I'M
CONSIDERING AS SUBSTITUTES.
LET'S SEE IF ANY OF THEM XIN
CLEARING HOUSE AS FLAG WITH
HAZARD TRAITS BECAUSE THEN THAT
THAT TO CONSIDERATION SO IT'S
UNFOLDS IN AND AND BOOSTS.
MAKES THE ACT ALTERNATES
ANNOUNCES A LITTLE EASIER.
ON CRIME.
RIGHT WILL WHAT I THINK WILL BE
WILL WANT TO CONNECT WITH THE
UNSERVED TALK MORE ABOUT THE
SPECIFICS BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOUR
RENT CHAIRS RIGHT YOU'VE YOU'VE.
FIVE ACTIVELY PRESENT ALWAYS OF
A PERSPECTIVES THAT ARE OUT
THERE BUT BUT HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT IF WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE AHEAD WITH THE WOMEN IN THE
CLEARING HOUSE WE THAT WE AND
I'LL.
BE.
TRANSFER MAYBE THE HAZARD TRAITS
MAYBE THAT'S THE KIND OF THE
BETSY THAT IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT YEAH OKAY.
THAT'S THAT'S ON THE THE OTHER
THING I WAS ASKED I WAS THINKING
ABOUT IN THE CONTEXT OF THE DATA
GAP AND YOU KNOW --
PUTTING A LITTLE MORE TEETH INTO
THE THE IN A THE THE THE THE
ABILITY OF THE REGULATORS TO GET
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED.
TO MAKE THEIR FINDINGS AND
DETERMINATIONS.
HAVE YOU SEEN OUT THERE KIND OF
A BEST PRACTICES WITH AGGRESSIVE
ENFORCEMENT OUT MAYBE ELSEWHERE
IN MAYBE IN EUROPE OR OR
ELSEWHERE --
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION I I
DIDN'T LOOK A LOT AT THE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS --
A IN OKAY SOUNDS LIKE.
HE CAN ASK BUT THEY'RE OUT THERE
YOU KNOW.
THE PEOPLE THE STONE WALL OF ALL
TIME IN --
THE EUROPE BUT I THINK IT DOES
HAVE PRETTY STRONG --
ENFORCEMENT ABILITIES CENTER
REACH AND THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE FAT.
CALLING IN DATA --
MASTER AND SO I ANSWER BLUR
SUBPOENA POWER CRIMINAL
PENALTIES OR WHAT.
WHAT'S IT'S RIGHT NOW BUT THAT
SOMETHING COULD EASILY FIND OUT
GET BACK TO YOU ON OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT --
LESS THEIR ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
WE SHOULD GET ON TO THE NEXT.
PANEL WHICH A CENTER ALLEN WILL
INTRODUCE [inaudible]
SERVICE NEXT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
DOCTOR SOLOMON WE REALLY
APPRECIATE REPORT A GREAT DEAL.
AND IT WILL BE THE BASIS OF SOME
FUTURE WORK.
ASSN NOW THIS NEXT FINAL PANEL
LOOKS AT WHERE WE GO FROM HERE.
AND WE HAVE --
FIVE FANTASTIC PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING UP TO THE TO THE TO THE
DESK FIRST RYAN WILLIAMS WHO'S A
HAD A PHD AND HE'S FROM GLOBAL
GREENS KEEPER OF PRODUCT
EXPERIENCE WEST OF THAT'S A
WONDERFUL JOB TITLE --
WE ALSO HAVE NANCY BOY A BOY --
MEYER WHO IS SENIOR POLICY
STRIDES WITH BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS TIME JACOB
EXECUTOR AFTER THE CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
HELEN HOLDER THE DISTINGUISHED
TECHNOLOGIST WITH H. P. AND ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE GREEN RIVER IN
SCIENCE PANEL THAT.
WAS MENTIONED AND I MEAN A CAR
SENIOR ATTORNEY IN DIRECTORS.
FOR STATE HEALTH POLICY FROM
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL SAYS YOU CAN SEE WE GOT
SOME PRIVATE SECTOR VOICES WE'VE
GOT SOME ENVIRONMENTAL VOICES.
AWESOME PUBLIC HEALTH VOICES AND
IT'S A GOOD MIX OF PERSPECTIVE
SO WE'LL START WITH YOU DOCTOR
WILLIAMS.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
BUT IT'D BE HEARING PRESENT TO
THE TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY AND
SIR.
AND I GOT A LOT TO GET THROUGH
SOME VERY PERSPECTIVES AND PRIDE
MUST VALUE COMES FROM THE
QUESTION SO.
I'M REAL BACKGROUND ON METHOD
WERE UP TO WEAR MAKE UP
HOUSEHOLD CLEANING LAUNDRY
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS.
NUMBER FOUND IN SAN FRANCISCO IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE OF THE PROMISE
THAT'S POSSIBLE TO MAKE PRODUCTS.
THAT ARE BETTER FOR HUMAN HEALTH
AND THE ENVIRONMENT --
SCIENCE TRANSPARENCY WE CONDUCT
HUMAN HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL
ASSESSMENTS INCLUDING ALTERNATE
ASSESSMENTS ON EVER IN GREETING
WE USE.
AND WE KNOW THAT CONSUMERS
EXPECT THE PROXY USE IN AND
AROUND THEIR HOMES ARE SAFE --
AND EXPECTATIONS SAFE
INGREDIENTS IS EVEN HIGHER FOR
THE PRODUCTS THEY USE ON
THEMSELVES --
OVER THE PAST EIGHTEEN YEARS OF
THE GROWTH OF THE GOING GREEN
CLEANING CATEGORY HAS
DRAMATICALLY OUTPACED OUT OF
CONVENTIONAL CLEANERS.
AND FACTOR PULLED SOME DATA JUST
IN ADVANCE THIS HEARING.
IN THE PAST THREE YEARS ALONE --
THE TOP THREE GREEN CLEANING
BRANDS OF GROWN 30%. FOR THE TOP --
THREE CLING CONVENTIONAL BRANDS
HAVE GROWN 3% --
AND THAT.
GROWTH CAP IS EVEN MORE DRAMATIC --
OVER THE PAST DECADE WE LOOK FOR
TO ACCELERATE AND THE FUTURE.
OUR GROWTH YOU KNOW IS IT
ENABLED US TO EXPAND FROM --
THE ORIGINAL TWO FOUNDERS INTO
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE TO A COMPANY
NOW THAT HAS OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY PEOPLE HAD CORN SAM --
IN ADDITION OF THAT OUR GROWTH
CREATED.
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE FIRST
LEED PLATINUM MANUFACTURING
FACILITY OTHER WE CHOSE TO
LOCATE IN CHICAGO ON THAT
CURRENT FACILITY.
EMPLOYS CLOSE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THE BECAUSE OF
THE CHEMICAL SCREENING PROCESS
YOU KNOW THAT WE VOLUNTARILY
CONDUCT --
WE'VE NOT BEEN DIRECTLY IMPACTED
BY THE G. DGSE GREEN CHEMISTRY
PROGRAM INGREDIENT LIST OR THE
INITIAL --
PRAIRIE PRODUCT CATEGORIES.
OUR COMPETITORS COULD HOWEVER --
BE AT IMPACTED BY THE PROPOSED
LAUNDRY DETERGENT --
WITH THE THAT CONTAIN THE A AND
P. AS A CATEGORY --
WE'VE NEVER USED MP IS AND OUR
PRODUCTS --
THEIR ADVERSE ENVIRONMENTAL
HUMAN HEALTH EFFECTS ARE ARE
VERY WELL DOCUMENTED.
BUT THINK THE I THINK THE
CONCEPT HERE THAT'S INTERESTING
IS THAT --
YOU THE PROPOSED CATEGORY WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT --
THE PEOPLE AND THE ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA BUT KIND OF RAISING
THE MINIMUM BAR.
AND THE PRINCIPLE OF RAISING THE
MINIMUM BAR --
WOULD HELP REDUCE THE GAP.
KIND OF BETWEEN --
AND COMPANIES THAT ARE JUST --
YOU KNOW OPERATING.
AT THE LOWER WATER LEVEL.
SO TO MAKE THE MARKET PLACE MUCH
MORE COMPETITIVE --
FOR SAFER MORE SUSTAINABLE
PRODUCTS.
NOW WITH RESPECT TO FUTURE
REGULATION --
IN PRINCIPLE WE WOULD ADVOCATE
AFRICAN AND CONTINUED EVOLUTION
THE REGULATION A NUMBER OF THE
PRINCIPLES THAT WERE BROUGHT
FORWARD HERE.
BUT A REGULATION THAT
FACILITATES BE TO BE
TRANSPARENCY AYE A POSITIVE
INGREDIENT LIST THAT SCIENCE
BASED AND CONTINUES TO RAISE THE
MINIMUM BAR.
I THINK A CLEAR LEGISLATIVE
SIGNAL --
WITH THIS IS IT WITH DECISION
MAKING RESOURCES FOR INDUSTRY I
WOULD FACILITATE BETTER PRODUCTS
FOR CALIFORNIANS.
OKAY THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT
ONYX RING HERE FROM NANCY GOT
YOUR MAYOR FROM BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS THANK YOU --
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M A BUSINESS OF
YOUR MARIN THE SENIOR POLICY
STRATEGIST FOR BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS OR THANK
CHAIRMAN QUIRK IN CHAIRMAN ALAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
OF THE BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS FORMALLY KNOWN AS
BREAST CANCER FUND IS A NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
PREVENTING BREAST CANCER BY
REDUCING EXPOSURES TO TOXIC
CHEMICALS AND RADIATION LINKED
TO THE TO THE DISEASE.
WE TRANSLATE THE GROWING BODY OF
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE LINKING
BREAST CANCER AND CHEMICALS INTO
PUBLIC EDUCATION MARKET
CAMPAIGNS POLICY ADVOCACY TO
PROTECT HEALTH AND TO REDUCE
BREAST CANCER RISK. ONE IN EIGHT
WOMEN IN THE U. S. WILL BE
DIAGNOSED WITH BREAST CANCER
THAT TRANSLATE TO A PROSTITUTE
TRANSLATES TO APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND CASES.
AND FORTY THOUSAND DEATHS EACH
YEAR.
CANCER IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
YET MOST WOMEN DIAGNOSED WITH
BREAST CANCER DO NOT HAVE A
FAMILY HISTORY OR A GENETIC
PREDISPOSITION FOR THE DISEASE.
SIGN SHOWS THE CHEMICALS THE
CHEMICALS WE ARE EXPOSED TO IN
THE AIR WE BREATHE.
THE WATER WE DRINK THE FOOD WE
ATE AND YES THE CONSUMER
PRODUCTS IN OUR HOMES.
SCHOOLS AND BUSINESSES PLAY A
ROLE IN INCREASING A RISK FOR
BREAST CANCER.
AND THESE CHEMICALS ARE NOT JUST
LIST LINKED TO BREAST CANCER.
THE CAMELS CHEMICALS OF CONCERN
ON THE DTS SEE LIST ARE LINKED
TO NUMEROUS HEALTH ISSUES
INCLUDING OTHER CANCERS
INFERTILITY BIRTH DEFECTS
LEARNING DISABILITIES AND
OBESITY AMONG OTHERS.
OVER THE YEARS BC PP HAS FOCUSED
ON REDUCING CHEMICAL EXPOSURE
SPECIFICALLY FROM CONSUMER
PRODUCTS INCLUDING COSMETICS AND
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS.
FOOD PACKAGING AND CLEANING
PRODUCTS.
AS A RESULT WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN ALL ASPECTS OF CREATING AND
IMPLEMENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM.
WE SUPPORTED THE ENABLING
LEGISLATION H. EXTENSIVELY ON
DEVELOPMENT OF THE REGULATIONS
AND HAVE CONTINUED TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THROUGHOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS.
AND IN FACT WE WERE ONE OF THE
SIGNATORIES ON THAT PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED PETITION AROUND THE PA
AND CANNED FOOD LINES.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PROGRAM
HOWEVER IT HAS YET TO REACH ITS
FULL POTENTIAL.
THE PROGRAM IS UNIQUE AND
GROUNDBREAKING.
FAR TOO OFTEN WHEN UNSAFE
CHEMICALS ARE IDENTIFIED AND
REMOVED FROM PRODUCT PRODUCTS
THEY ARE REPLACED WITH CHEMICALS
THAT ARE SHOWN TO BE EQUALLY OR
MORE TOXIC.
TOXICS ONCE THE SCIENCE CATCHES
UP.
AN EXAMPLE OF THIS TOXIC
TREADMILL IS BPA.
OR BEST FILLET AN ESTROGENIC
COMPOUNDS LINK TO BREAST CANCER
AND NUMEROUS OTHER HEALTH
IMPACTS.
IT IS OFTEN REPLACED WITH
COMPOUNDS LIKE B. P. S. OR B. P.
F..
WHICH SCIENCE IS NOW SHOWING TO
HAVE EQUALLY PROBLEMATIC
PROPERTIES.
SIMILAR SITUATIONS EXIST WITH
OTHER CHEMICAL FAMILIES SUCH AS
PERFORMING A COMPOUND WHICH
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT PHTHALATES
AND FLAME RETARDANT.
THIS PROGRAM FOCUSES NOT ONLY ON
WHAT CHEMICALS TO REMOVE BUT
ALSO REQUIRES INDUSTRY TO
CONDUCT ALTERNATIVE ASSESSMENT
TO ENSURE THAT THE REPLACEMENTS
ARE TRULY SAY.
FOR HELPING US STEP OFF THE
STRIP MALL.
THE PROGRAM DRIVES INNOVATION IN
GREEN CHEMISTRY THAT RESULTS IN
SAFER PRODUCTS NOT JUST FOR
CALIFORNIANS ABOUT FOR THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
AND THE PROGRAM IS NEEDED NOW
MORE THAN EVER WHILE THERE WAS
GREAT HOPE THAT THE RECENT
UPDATES TO THE FEDERAL TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACT WOULD
RESULT IN BETTER CHEMICAL
REGULATION.
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
IMPLEMENTATION HAS CAPITULATED
TO THE CHEMICAL INDUSTRY AT
EVERY TURN.
WE MUST AGAIN DEPEND ON THE
STATE'S TO PROTECT OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH.
AS IS OFTEN THE CASE WITH
INNOVATIVE AND UNIQUE PROGRAMS
TEN YEARS INTO IMPLEMENTATION IT
IS NOW CLEAR THAT THE PRO THE
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM.
NEED SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO FULLY
REALIZE ITS POTENTIAL.
FIRST AND TO QUOTE DOCTOR
WILLIAMS INFORMATION IS THE COIN
OF THE REALM. TO BE EFFECTIVE
THE PROGRAM.
NEEDS.
TO THE IS THE AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE MANUFACTURERS TO TELL
THEM WHAT CHEMICALS ARE IN THE
PRODUCTS THEY ARE SELLING IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS INFORMATION CAN BE HELD
CONFIDENTIAL PROVIDING THE
NECESSARY DATA TO THE PROGRAM
WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING.
TRADE SECRETS.
AS AN ASIDE OUR ORGANIZATION IS
ALSO GONNA BE LOOKING AT
LEGISLATION TO TRY TO TO REQUIRE
DISCLOSURE OF FRAGRANCE AND
CHEMICALS WHICH IN PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS WHICH WAS ALSO
MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY --
SECOND MORE FOCUSED ON SPECIFIC
WORK PLANS AND CLEAR DEADLINES
FOR ACTION WOULD HELP THE
PROGRAM BECOME MORE EFFICIENT
AND PRODUCTIVE.
AND OF COURSE THE PROGRAM NEEDS
TO SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS GOAL.
FINALLY WHILE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM NO MATTER HOW
EFFICIENT THE PROGRAM BECOMES IT
WILL NEVER ADDRESS THE VAST
ARRAY OF PRODUCTS CONTAINING
CHEMICALS OF CONCERN.
THIS LEGISLATURE MUST ALSO PLAY
ITS ROLE IN PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS BY RESTRICTING.
UNSAFE CHEMICAL EXPOSURES
PARTICULARLY LOCALS THAT CAUSING
GREAT HARM AND FOR WHICH SAFER
ALTERNATIVES ARE CLEARLY
AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AND
THIS AND THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY AUTHORITY
AND RESOURCES. TO FULLY REALIZE
THE ENORMOUS POTENTIAL OF THE
CALIFORNIA SAY FOR CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT.
SO NOW WE HEAR OF AN INDUSTRY
SIDE PERSPECTIVE AND AND WE HAVE
TIME TAKEN HERE --
EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF THE CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
MY GOD.
I THINK SO YEAH OKAY YEAH --
MY NAME IS TOM JACOB I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO ON THE STEERING
COMMITTEE OF THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
ALLIANCE.
THE COUNCIL ALONG WITH A NUMBER
OF OTHER COMPANIES AND TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS.
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED WITH GREEN
CHEMISTRY STE --
SINCE MIKE WILL SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX REPORT.
WHEN THE DISCUSSIONS LED TO THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY BILLS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND?
EIGHT MANY OF US IN INDUSTRY
ACTIVELY JOINED WITH OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL COLLEAGUES.
AND SUPPORTED THEIR PASSAGE.
THE BILL'S DEMANDED A MORE
HOLISTIC PERSPECTIVE ON
CHEMICALS WE RECOGNIZE THAT WITH
TAKE A DEDICATED STAFF OF
SCIENTISTS.
OPENED INPUT FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
INVESTING --
INVESTING SIGNIFICANT TIME --
IN ORDER TO DO JUSTICE TO THAT
TASK.
THIS WAS PREFERABLE IN OUR VIEW
TWO A LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
BURDENED.
BY HAVING TO ADDRESS THOUSANDS
OF BILLS IN VERY LIMITED TIME
WITH LIMITED SCIENTIFIC
EXPERTISE.
THAT SIMPLY CANNOT DO JUSTICE TO
THE MORE HOLISTIC APPROACH THAT
IS NOW BEING DEMANDED.
WE WERE CONSCIOUS THOUGH THAT
COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION OF
POSSIBLE IMPACTS OF CHEMICALS
AND THEIR ALTERNATIVES.
WAS NEW TO REGULAR PROGRAM
REGULATORY PROGRAMS IN THE US.
AND VERY AMBITIOUS.
WE RALLIED TO THAT CHALLENGE
WITH ONE OF THE BROADEST AND
DEEPEST EFFORTS EVER MOUNTED BY
INDUSTRY TO ENABLE STATE LEVEL
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY.
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY ALLIANCE
BROUGHT TO CALIFORNIA EXPERTISE
FROM LEADING NATIONAL COMPANIES.
AND TRADE ASSOCIATIONS THE AIM
WAS AND STILL IS TO HELP DE TSC
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
REGULATIONS.
THAT DO JUSTICE TO THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY Là WAYS THAT ARE
MANAGEABLE BOTH FOR THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND FOR INDUSTRY.
THE PIONEERING CHARACTER OF THIS
EFFORT PROVED TO BE DEMANDING AS
HAS BEEN ALLUDED TO IT TOOK.
FIVE YEARS FOR DTS SEE TO
FINALIZE ITS INITIAL REGULATORY
PACKAGE.
THE LAWS MAYBE TEN YEARS OLD BUT
THE TEN YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE
SUSTAINABLE CONSUMER PRODUCT
REGULATORY PROGRAM --
WILL HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL.
TEN TWENTY TWENTY THREE THIS
PROCESS IS REALLY FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE STILL IN ITS INFANCY.
THAT SAID.
WE ARE NOW FINALLY TESTING THE
PROCESS AND FEEL MANY OF THE
ISSUES POINTED TO AN DR
SOLOMON'S REPORT.
JUSTIFY ENGAGEMENT AND DIALOGUE.
A HIGHLIGHT A FEW.
WE SHARE THE VIEW THAT THIS
PROCESS CAN AND SHOULD BE MORE
EFFICIENT.
AND ARE PREPARED TO ENGAGE WITH
PTSD AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS THAT.
GREATER CLARITY REGARDING THE
EVALUATION PROCESS FOR SELECTING
CANDIDATES CHEMICALS SHOULD BE
AS COULD BE A START.
AS WOULD EARLIER DIRECT
ENGAGEMENT WITH KEY COMPANIES
AND INDUSTRIES WHEN
CONTEMPLATING SPECIFIC PRODUCT
AREAS.
WE BELIEVE THE PROCESS MAY ALSO
BENEFIT FROM --
ALLOWING STRATEGIC OFF RAMPS FOR
COMPANIES OR INDUSTRIES THAT
COMMIT TO PROPOSALS CLEARLY
MEETING THE AIMS OF THE LAW.
IMPORTANTLY THOUGH WE SEE SUCH
REFINEMENTS AS BEING WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF THE REGULATORY DOMAIN.
WE DO NOT SEE LEGISLATIVE CHANGE
AS A APPROPRIATE AT THIS
JUNCTURE.
WE NOTE THAT THE ISSUE OF DATA
COLIN HAS BEEN RAISED --
WE DO KNOW THAT DDT ESSIE
ALREADY POSSESSES AUTHORITY FOR
PRODUCT SPECIFIC DATA COLLINS --
IT'S NOT TOTALLY CLEAR TO US WHY
THE EXISTING AUTHORITY IS NOT
ADEQUATE ALTHOUGH THAT'S BEEN
SPOKEN TO TO A DEGREE TODAY --
WE SUSPECT HOWEVER THAT THE IN
THE END MAY NOT BE SOUGHT FOR
THE TRADITIONAL NEED A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING SPECIFIC PRODUCTS.
BUT RATHER A MORE WHOLESALE CALL
IN AT THE VERY BROAD RANGE OF
PRODUCTS.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE BEING
FOCUSED UPON BY THE PROGRAM.
AND IN OUR VIEW THAT WOULD BE A
QUITE DIFFERENT CHALLENGE.
AND YES WE TO SEE FUNDING AS AN
ISSUE WARRANTING ATTENTION AND
DIALOGUE DESPITE THE RESOURCE
INFUSION THAT YOU APPROPRIATED
LAST YEAR.
IN THIS CONTEXT IT IS INDEED
UNFORTUNATE THAT LARGER FUNDING
QUESTIONS MAY BE LURKING IN THE
BACKGROUND FOR DTS SEE.
AS YOU ALLUDED TO AND AS YOU'LL
BE DISCUSSING ON THE TWENTY
SEVENTH.
FINALLY WE CONTINUE TO OPPOSE
LEGISLATIVE INTERVENTIONS THAT
BYPASS CRITICAL AREAS OF THE SDP
PROCESS.
AS RECOMMENDED.
THEY WOULD DIRECTLY OBSTRUCT THE
FLOW OF THAT PROCESS.
AND IMPEDE GAINING THE
EXPERIENCE NEEDED FOR ITS
IMPROVEMENT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY.
WE FEEL THAT THEY WOULD RUN THE
RISK OF UNDERMINING THE AIM OF
THESE LAWS.
AND THROWING US BACK INTO AN ERA
OF COMPETITION OF ONE OFF
CHEMICAL BILLS.
RATHER WE BELIEVE THAT WE CAN
WORK THROUGH THE WORK WITHIN THE
PRESENT LAWS TO IMPROVE THIS
PROCESS SIGNIFICANTLY.
NOW THAT THE REGULATIONS ARE
PLAYING OUT AND ENABLING THE
NECESSARY LEARNINGS. FOR THAT
REASON WE APPRECIATE THE
INITIATIVE OF OUR COLLEAGUES.
IN PUTTING THESE CHALLENGES BACK
ON THE TABLE.
WE THINK WE THANK THE COMMITTEES
FOR INDULGING THIS.
WE DO THINK IT'S TIMELY NOW THAT
WE ARE FINALLY GAINING SOME
EXPERIENCE ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING
THE REGULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
I AND MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
CHEMISTRY ALLIANCE WHO ARE HERE
WILL BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS --
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE IT.
OKAY AND I'M NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM HELEN HOLDER WHOSE --
WITH HEWLETT PACKARD ALSO MEMBER
THE CREAM OF INSIGHTS PARA.
HI THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY -- I
AM A DISTINGUISHED TECHNOLOGISTS
HP LABS AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE GREEN RIBBON SIGNS PANEL --
I WANTED ALSO MENTION THAT I WAS
ALSO POINTED TO THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES PANEL ON STE
CHEMICAL SUBSTITUTION AS WELL AS
THE OECD WORKING GROUP.
ON CHEMICAL SUBSTITUTION AND SO
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
I'M PROBABLY YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
KEY ARCHITECTS OF THE MODERN
APPROACH TO CHEMICAL
ALTERNATIVES ASSESSMENT THAT WE
USE TODAY.
BOTH AROUND THE WORLD AND IN
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK THAT'S
RELEVANT BECAUSE SOME OF THE
THINGS I'M GONNA SAY PROBABLY --
RELY ON SOME KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
THAT.
SO SEVERAL PEOPLE HAVE MENTIONED
TODAY ABOUT THE PACE OF THE
PROGRAM ESPECIALLY THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM.
AND I'M CAREFUL TO SAY PACE AS
OPPOSED TO SLOW.
BECAUSE I THINK --
SEE HOW THE HOW THE PROGRAM
WORKS.
IT IS FUNCTIONING AS IT WAS
DESIGNED.
AND THIS IS A A REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT --
THERE'S NOT BEEN A BIG --
EXECUTION FAILURE THE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY IS DONE AN OUTSTANDING
JOB OF PUTTING THE PROGRAM
TOGETHER AND STANDING IT UP --
THROUGH THE STAKEHOLDERS OF BEEN --
PRETTY RESPONSIVE ACTUALLY ALL
THINGS CONSIDERED AND WE'RE NOT
SEEING A AND VERY SIGNIFICANT
DEADLINES MISS WAS NOT
CHARACTERIZED BY MISSING
DEADLINES WHERE WE MIGHT THINK
THAT PEOPLE WERE --
MAYBE PROGRESSING SLOWLY SO SO
WHY IS THE PROGRAM PROGRESSING
AT THE SPEED THAT IT IS WHY ARE
WE ONLY SEEN THE NUMBER OF
CHEMICALS THAT WE'VE SEEN.
AND SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
THE ADAGE YOU CAN HAVE IT FAST
CHEAP OR RIGHT PICK ANY.
TWO RIGHT SO IS CALLED THE
TRIPLE CONSTRAINT IS A VERY
COMMON WAY OF LOOKING A
CONSTRAINED SYSTEMS WHICH THIS
VERY DEFINITELY IS [inaudible]
SO --
THERE'S THIS TENSION BETWEEN THE
RIGHTNESS OF THE ANSWER THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET.
WE WANT TO HAVE.
ALMOST NO CHANCE THAT SOME BAD
OUTCOME WILL HAPPEN IF SOMETHING
HAS GONE THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
WE NATURALLY HAVE CONSTRAINED
RESOURCES.
AND THE ONLY THING REALLY
LAUGHED. TO ACCOMMODATE IS SPEED
AND SO THE SPEED THAT WE SEE THE
PROGRAM PROGRESSING IS REALLY.
THE NATURAL OUTCOME OF THE WAY
THAT WE'VE STRUCTURED.
SO WE HAVE OF VERY MUCH
PRIORITIZE THE RIGHTNESS OF THE
ANSWER THAT WERE SEEKING --
AND THIS COMES BY ACTUALLY LIKE
FROM THE BAND BILLS WE SAW WHAT
HAPPENS IF YOU TAKE A SUBSTANCE
USE RESTRICTED.
AND YOU DON'T NECESSARILY LOOK
AT THE ALTERNATIVES.
OF YOU CAN END UP WITH SOMETHING
THAT'S EVEN WORSE THAN THE
ORIGINAL CHEMICAL OR THAT MOVES
THE PROBLEM SO YOU MIGHT GET RID
OF A CARCINOGEN.
BUT THEN AND UP WITH --
ACOSTA TOXICANT INSTEAD AND SO
AS WE CREATED THE APPROACH TO
CHEMICAL REGULATION WE WANTED IT
TO BE VERY BROAD.
WE WANT TO LOOK ACROSS MANY
DIFFERENT IMPACTS.
A BIG BECAUSE OF THAT WE SET THE
BAR VERY HIGH FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVENESS OF WHAT WE
WANT THE PROCESS TO DO WHEN TO
BE.
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT WAYS OF
ACCELERATING THE PROCESS WE HAVE
TO REALLY LOOK AT THAT AS THE
MAIN DRIVER.
BECAUSE WE CAN ONLY PUT SO MUCH
RESOURCES INTO IT THIS IS JUST
THAT'S THE REALITY OF IT.
AND SO IF WE WANT --
TO GET MORE SPEED WE HAVE TO GO
INTO SOME OF THESE OTHER OPTIONS
THAT INCLUDE THINGS LIKE --
WHERE CAN YOU INJECT INTO THE --
PROCESS THAT MIGHT SACRIFICE A
SMALL AMOUNT OF THAT
COMPREHENSIVENESS BUT GET YOU A
MUCH BIGGER OF ACCELERATION OF
THE PROGRAM.
NO WE DON'T WANT TO DO THIS
MINDLESSLY AND SO AS A MEMBER OF
THE GREEN RIBBON SIGNS PANEL I
WOULD.
SUGGEST THAT YOU RELY ON US TO
HELP FIGURE OUT WHAT THOSE
OPTIONS MIGHT BE.
AND WHAT THE IMPACT MIGHT BE AND
AS WE ASSESS ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE COMING.
OUT TO THE TABLE THAT WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT WHAT ARE THE
IMPACTS IN THE COMPLETENESS.
OF THE ANSWER.
ON IN THE RESOURCES REQUIRED TO
DO THE EXPECTED SPEED THAT WE
WOULD GET FOR MAKING THOSE
CHANGES AND THAT WE USE THAT.
AS A MAJOR --
INDICATOR OF WHETHER WE SHOULD
ADOPT A PARTICULAR CHANGE OR NOT.
AND SO --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU COULD YOU AT THE IF
YOU WERE TO DESCRIBE SOMEONE IN
THE ELEVATOR AND THEN OF NEW
SAID WHAT'S THE RETIREMENT
SCIENCE PANEL HOW HOW WOULD YOU.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE IT OF
WHERE THE PANEL THAT ADVISES THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON --
CHEMICAL REGULATION.
AND IT'S MADE UP OF A MIX OF
FOLKS WITH THAT WITH THE
BREAKDOWN --
ACTUALLY THAT'S A I WOULD HAVE
TO DEFER TO THE TSC OF THE
ACTUAL MEMBERSHIP BUT WE DO HAVE
PEOPLE FROM INDUSTRY ACADEMIA
AND SHE GOES --
IT'S A BROAD GROUP OF YOU KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE ON THE PANEL.
TWO POINT. TWO TWELVE OKAY.
HOW OFTEN DO YOU MEET --
TWICE A YEAR.
OKAY ANY ANY IN.
ANY OF THE STAFF THAT WORK FOR
THE COUNCIL.
TO YOU KNOW TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AND PROVIDE OF REPORTING IN --
CAMPUS THAT'S ALL THAN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
THE MEETINGS ARE HERE AT
MEETINGS ARE CONTANDO YES.
OKAY THANK YOU PRESENT THAT --
CORRECTION HERE FROM IV CAR
WHO'S A SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH AN
RTC.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY --
AS YOU SAID I'M A SENIOR
ATTORNEY AND DIRECTOR FOR STATE
HEALTH POLICY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL.
NRDC HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
WORKING ON TOXIC AND ENSURING
ROBUST LAWS AND PROGRAMS TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE
RISKS FROM HARMFUL CHEMICALS --
AND THEN OF COURSE CALIFORNIANS
CONTINUE TO BE EXPOSED DALY DICK
TOXIC CHEMICALS IN OUR HOMES
WHETHER IT'S IN OUR DRINKING
WATER OR FOOD HOUSEHOLD AND
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS AREN'T
FURNITURE.
THAT ADDITIONALLY --
WORKERS EXPOSED TO TOXIC
CHEMICALS IN JOB SETTINGS
RANGING FROM.
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES OIL
REFINERIES.
AND CALIFORNIA'S GREEN GREEN
CHEMISTRY INITIATIVE THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM AND
ITS MISSION OF MAKING PRODUCTS
SAFER AND DRIVING INNOVATIVE
CHEMISTRY IS THUS A PROGRAM OF
GREAT INTEREST TO US.
PART ME.
AS DR SOLOMON'S REPORT SHOWS
THAT THE PROGRAM HAS TREMENDOUS
PROMISE --
IT IS AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM OF TOXIC
CHEMICALS UP FRONT RATHER THAN
AFTER THE FACT THAT IS
PREVENTING TOXIC EXPOSURES IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
RATHER THAN CLEANING UP OR
FIXING THE FACTS OF THAT
EXPOSURE.
IT REFLECTS AN APPROACH OF
ASKING THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
THE USE OF TOXIC CHEMICALS.
OR CHEMICALS OF CONCERN IS
NECESSARY.
EVALUATING THE ALTERNATIVES AND
MOVING US TOWARD SAFER CHEMICALS
AND PRODUCTS ESPECIALLY WITH A
VIEW TO THE PROTECTION OF
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
WE ARE HUGELY SUPPORT OF ALL
THOSE GOALS.
AND WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE PROGRAM AND
HEARTENED BY THE DIRECTION OF
THE PROGRAM IS HEADED. FOR
INSTANCE WITH AS EVALUATION OF
STAND RESISTANT AND TOXIC TEFLON
PERFLUORINATED COMPOUNDS AND
CARPETS AND RUGS.
THE PROGRAM IS TAKING ON A HUGE
CATEGORY OF POTENTIAL EXPOSURE
TO HAZARDOUS CHEMICAL --
AND LOOKING AT THE WHOLE CLASS
OF CHEMICALS ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T END UP WITH A REGRETTABLE
SUBSTITUTION.
AND ON THE TOXIC TREADMILL WHERE
ONE HAZARDOUS CHEMICAL AS
REPLACEMENTS CYNICAL SIMILAR
CHEMICAL WITH ALL THE ATTENDANT
RISKS UP THAT'S AN ALL TOO
FAMILIAR STORY.
HOWEVER.
BECAUSE OF A NUMBER HAS BEEN
UNABLE TO DELIVER FULLY AND ITS
POTENTIAL --
FULLY ON ITS POTENTIAL AND SO
THIS IS TO BE EXPECTED AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM DOCTOR WILLIAMS AND
FROM DR HOLDER --
BUT THERE ARE SOME ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATIONS AT PLAY HERE AS
WE'VE ALSO HEARD TODAY.
IN A PERIOD OF TEN YEARS WE HAVE
SEEN ONLY A HANDFUL OF PRODUCT
CHEMICAL COMBINATIONS ADDRESSED
IN ONLY ONE THAT HAS MADE IT ALL
THE WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS.
AND EVEN THAT AS WE HEARD
EARLIER TODAY DID NOT RESULT IN
REGULATORY ACTION.
A NUMBER OF FACTORS ARE AT PLAY
I'LL BRIEFLY ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ONE KEY ISSUE FOR PERSPECTIVE AS
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY IS DTS IS
LACK OF ACCESS. TO PRODUCT
INGREDIENTS DATA.
PROGRAM STAFF HAVE HAD TO RESORT
TO GOOGLE SEARCHES AND
UNSUCCESSFUL VOLUNTARY INDUSTRY
REQUEST TO GET INFORMATION
PRODUCT INGREDIENTS.
THE RESULT HAS BEEN LONG DELAYS
AND HESITATION TO CONSIDER ALL
THE PRINCIPAL INGREDIENTS MAKING
A PRODUCT AND UNSAFE.
THIS CLEARLY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
WITH CLEAR ARE STRONGER DTC DATA
COLLECTION AUTHORITY INCLUDING
BACK TO THE CHEMICAL
MANUFACTURER.
THAT'S STILL PRESERVES THE TRADE
SECRET PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
ALREADY IN THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
Là.
A SECOND ISSUE IS A LACK OF
DEADLINES AND OF CLEAR
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE PROGRAMS
OUTLINED TIME LINES FOR ACTION.
WHICH WOULD DRIVE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE CURRENT THREE YEAR WORK
PLANS AND NOT SPECIFIC ENOUGH TO
BE MEANINGFUL.
AND THUS FACILITATE THE LEND THE
DELAYS --
THAT HAVE BEEN UNFORTUNATE
FEATURE OF THE PROGRAM TO DATE.
IMPROVEMENTS ON THIS FRONT WOULD
HELP WITH THE PRIVATIZATION
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS BUT DOCTOR
SOLOMON HAS HIGHLIGHTED.
A THIRD FACTOR LIKELY TO BECOME
MORE PROBLEMATIC IF NOT
CORRECTED IS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH OF REQUIRING A NEW
COMPANY DRIVEN ALTERNATIVES
ANALYSIS FOR EVERY MANUFACTURER
AND PRODUCT EVEN WHEN
INFORMATION ALL HEART IS.
IS ALREADY AVAILABLE FROM
RELIABLE SOURCES.
WE AGREED THAT WE DON'T WANT TO
INTERRUPT THE FLOW OF THE
PROCESS HOWEVER A FAST TRACK
OPTION THAT ALLOWS THE AGENCY TO
MOVE FASTER.
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY FOR NOTICE
AND COMMENT WHEN SUCH
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE.
COULD SPEED UP THE PROCESS.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR LINE THE
PROGRAM TO ADDRESS MORE OF THE
HUGE UNIVERSE OF PRODUCTS AND
CHEMICALS OUT THERE.
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THE FAST TRACK PROCESS COULD
ALSO REDUCE THE BURDEN AND
COMPANIES ESPECIALLY ON MORE
RESOURCE STRAPPED SMALLER
COMPANIES.
THAT WHICH WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE
TO CONDUCT THEIR OWN ALL TURNS
ANALYSIS.
FINALLY AS WE'VE HEARD TODAY
THERE'S A GREAT NEED FOR
SUBSTANTIALLY BETTER AND MORE
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT MISSION OF
PROTECTING THE HEALTH OF
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING OF COURSE
THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM.
WHAT IMPROVEMENTS LIKE THESE AND
MORE EFFICIENT PROCESS WE
ON ITS VAST POTENTIAL AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON THAT?
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT HAD.
ME IF YOU WANT ONE QUESTION WE
TALK WITH THE LACK OF DEADLINES.
ME DOES THIS RUN INTO THE
PROBLEM THAT THE AND THAT --
MISS HOLDER WAS TALKING ABOUT
WITH REGARDS TO YOU KNOW YOU CAN
EITHER BE FAT WILL FAST CHEAPER
RIGHT PICK ANY.
TWO IS IS THE ISSUE.
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU THINK THAT
THIS DEADLINES --
THAT THIS PROCESS TAKES TIME.
AND THAT IS IT IN IN LESS YOU
WANT TO BLOW UP THE BUDGET --
SPEEDING THINGS UP. TO QUICKLY
BECAUSE KIT CAN CAN LEAD TO
ACCURACY PROBLEMS OR OR MAJOR
COST PROBLEMS THAT WOULD REALLY
CREATING A REASONABLE --
I THINK WE WANT TO GET IT RIGHT
AND IDEA ISN'T TO PUSH THE
PROGRAM TO WORK FASTER THAN I
CAN BUT TO HAVE CLEAR TIME LIES
IN PLACE SO IF THE WORK PLAN FOR
INSTANCE.
LAYS OUT --
HERE THE NUMBER OF CHEMICALS WE
CAN ADDRESS IN THIS PERIOD OF
TIME HERE ARE THE MARKERS FOR
PROGRESS AND WHEN IT'S GOING TO
GET DONE.
THAT PROVIDES CLEAR TIME LINES
THAT.
THE REGULATED COMMUNITY AND
STAKEHOLDERS CAN ACT UPON IT
ALSO GIVES CLEAR GOALS --
THAT THE AGENCY IS SETTING ITS
OWN TIMELINE THAT SCENARIO BUT
WITHIN A TIME FRAME SO IF SAY A
FIVE YEAR TIME FRAME.
BUT WITHIN THAT PERIOD THIS
AGENCY CqC SET ITS OWN GOT
GOLDEN TIME LIGHTS --
AND DEVELOP THAT BASED ON THE
NEEDS OF THE PARTICULAR PRODUCT
CHEMICAL COMBINATION IT'S
LOOKING AT SO I THINK THERE'S A
WAY TO BALANCE THOSE TWO NEEDS
WHAT WHAT'S STOPPING THEM FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
FROM IMPOSING.
ADEQUATE DEADLINES --
I THINK THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT
AT THE MOMENT AND I THINK.
YOU.
GIVEN -- THE
CHOICE ANYBODY WOULD TAKE TIME
EXACTLY RIGHT AND I THINK OF
HAVING SOME REASONABLE
CONSTRAINTS ON THE DEADLINES AND
TIME LINES --
SO THAT YOUR DRESS A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF PRODUCTS AND CHEMICALS
WOULD THEN AT A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME.
I THINK IS A FAIR APPROACH IT'S
BEEN DEMONSTRATED IN MULTIPLE
REGULATORY REGIMES THAT ARE
WHERE WHERE WHERE WHERE YOU SEEN
THAT IT WORKS WELL --
THERE ARE DEADLINES AND IN PLACE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CLEAN AIR
ACT THEIR DEADLINES IN PLACE
UNDER THE CLEAN WATER ACT THEIR
DEADLINES IN PLACE UNDER ALMOST
ANY ENVIRONMENTAL LAW FOR THE
AGENCIES.
YES.
AND THAT'S GOOD JUST AT THE
CERTAIN JUST ON THAT POINT THE
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACT
WHICH WAS AMENDED AND AS I SAID
HASN'T BEEN IMPLEMENTED WELL.
DID PUT IN PLACE TIME LINES AND
MINIMUM NUMBERS OF CHEMICALS
THAT THE IT THAT THE EIGHT EPA
SHOULD LOOK AT AND COMPLETE
WITHIN A FIVE YEAR PERIOD SO.
IT YOU KNOW.
THERE ARE A LOT OF COULDN'T
THERE ARE A LOT OF DEMANDS ON
AND AGENCIES BOTH AT THE STATE
LEVEL IN THE FAT FEDERAL LEVEL
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
POKING ADAM TO DO THINGS IN A
PARTICULAR WAY.
AND I THINK HAVING THAT
STATUTORY DEADLINE HELPS KEEP
THINGS FOCUSED TO KEEP THINGS
MOVING AND RISE.
TO SORT OF TAMP DOWN SOME OF THE
STATIC AROUND THE EDGES MISTER
JACOBS AND SEE YEAH I JUST LIKE
TO ENTER THIS DISCUSSION BRIEFLY
BECAUSE I THINK --
DOCTOR WILLIAMS OF ALLUDED TO IT.
AN ISSUE THAT I THINK IS VERY
RELEVANT OR HAS BEEN VERY
RELEVANT --
AND THAT IS SIMPLY THAT.
THAT OUT THERE.
AND I THINK.
THEY'VE DONE.
QUITE AN ADMIRABLE JOB OF
PROCEEDING ON THAT BASIS. TO
CONSTRUCT THIS --
FROM THE GROUND UP --
IN I THINK --
AS ONE OF THE FOLKS THAT WAS
ALWAYS PICKING AT THEM I THINK
THEY'VE BEEN.
RECEPTIVE --
TO THE IDEAS AND CONCERNS --
THAT ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
BEEN REGISTERING WITH THEM AS
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH THIS AND
WE'VE SEEN THE PROCESS IMPROVING --
BEING MODIFIED --
AND I BELIEVE [inaudible]
PICKING UP DIFFICULT DEGREE OF
MOMENTUM AND I DON'T THINKWE
SHOULD LOSE SIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT -- THAT
THIS REALLY IS A VERY VERY NOVEL
UNDERTAKING AND I THINK --
THE CHALLENGE OF DOING THAT IN A
WAY THAT PRESERVES THE INTEGRITY
OF THE END PRODUCT IS IS QUITE
SIGNIFICANT IN A AND THAT'S BEEN
A CONTRIBUTOR TO THIS.
I MEAN PART PROBLEMS IT'S TO
NOVEL WRITING AND IF IF IF MORE
PEOPLE WERE DOING THIS AROUND
THE WORLD WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THE EXTRA WILL EMPOWER ITS THAN
I WOULD.
HEART OF IT TOO IS.
THE STATUTE WAS EXTRAORDINARILY
COMPREHENSIVE --
AND THE IT THE THE DEGREE TO
WHICH IT ITERATED SUCH A VERY
VERY BROAD RANGE OF
CONSIDERATIONS THAT HAD TO BE.
DO HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED --
I THINK --
CARRIES A A GREAT DEAL OF WEIGHT
IN TERMS OF FIGURING OUT JUST
HOW YOU CAN DO THAT ON AN
EXPEDITIOUS FOR THE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE THAN WHAT THE
EUROPEANS ARE DOING.
YES I BELIEVE SO ADVOCATE ADDS
TO THAT IS --
I THINK THAT THERE'S ALSO A
DIFFERENCE OF INTENT IN THE WAY
THAT ALTERNATIVES ASSESSMENT ARE
INCORPORATED INTO THIS.
EFFORT WHERE --
HISTORICALLY OR PREVIOUSLY ALTER
IS THIS ASSESSMENT WAS OFTEN
USED AS AN EXCUSE TO CAN THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS TRIED TO
REHABILITATE THAT --
TO MAKE IT.
MUCH MORE FORWARD LOOKING SEVEN
THAT IT'S NOT JUST A MATTER OF I
CAN'T FIND ANYMORE ALTERNATIVE
SO I HAVE TO KEEP USING THIS BAD
THING -- TO
A MORE EXPLORATORY CAN WE FIND
SOMETHING THAT'S ACTUALLY BETTER
THAN WHAT'S A CHEMICAL OF
CONCERN.
AND YEAH.
SEVERAL IF I MAY CLARIFY WHAT I
WAS GETTING AT ITSELF NOT THE
IDEA ISN'T TO REGULATE EVERY
SINGLE STEP OF THE PROCESS FOR
THE AGENTS SAY WE DON'T WANT TO
DICTATE EVERY STEP IN THE RIGHT
TAKE A TIME LINE DESIGN THINGS
UP TO MAKE A SOME GENERAL
PARAMETERS HERE.
WITH THEM TO DEVELOP THEIR OWN
TIME LINES WITHIN THOSE BROAD
PARAMETERS SHE'S IT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING YOUR THE THE
ATTORNEY HERE IS IF YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THE THAT THIS
REALTORS SCHEME IS MORE
COMPREHENSIVE THAN THE EUROPEANS.
I THINK THEY'RE DIFFERENT IN
NATURE AND THEY ARE
COMPREHENSIVE IN DIFFERENT WAYS
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A
DIRECT COMPARISON THAT'S
POSSIBLE BETWEEN THE TWO IN
QUITE THOSE TERMS --
BECAUSE THE THE THEY BEHAVE AND
DISTINCTLY DIFFERENT WAYS.
THINK YEAH THAT'S FAIR.
OKAY LET ME ASK YOU A MISTER
JACOB YOU KNOW THE ONE OF THE
ISSUES IS FROM BROUGHT UP
SEVERAL TIMES IS QUESTION ABOUT
OF OF DATA AND AND AND GETTING
DATA AND AND THE THE FRUSTRATION
OF THE REGULATORS IS THAT THEY
YEAH THEY KEEP.
ASKING FOR THIS INFORMATION AND
JUST PEOPLE ARE NOT FORTHCOMING
WHY IS THAT WHAT'S YOUR
UNDERSTANDING AS TO AS TO YEAH
WELL LOCKED OR SLOW ROLLED AND I
HAVEN'T HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SIT DOWN --
WITH THE STAFF AND DISCUSS THIS
IN IN DETAIL.
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT -- THE
ITS AT WORK HERE --
IS THE WHOLE ISSUE OF SUPPLY
CHAINS --
AND THE COMPLEXITY OF
CONTEMPORARY YEAH OPERATIONS --
OFTEN INVOLVING GLOBAL --
MOVEMENTS OF PRODUCTS OR
CHEMICAL.
AND WE DO TRY TO ADDRESS THAT WE
HAVE A SYSTEM FOR TRYING TO
ADDRESS IT THROUGH --
THE ITS MISSION OF MATERIAL
SAFETY DATA SHEETS THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO REPRESENT --
SOME GUIDANCE ON HOW A GIVEN
CHEMICAL IS SUPPOSED TO BE
HANDLED --
I'M NOT SURE THAT THEY ARE
TOTALLY ADEQUATE TO THE KIND OF
TASK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE --
AND TO EXT TO A CERTAIN EXTENT
THERE MAY BE DEFICIENCIES IN
THAT PROCESS.
THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING --
TO SOME OF WHAT THEY'VE.
FOUND MY EXPERIENCES WITH THE
MAJOR CHEMICAL MANUFACTURERS.
AND MY PERSPECTIVE FROM THAT.
IS THAT THEY RESPECT.
DATA COLLINS THEY RESPECT --
THAT THE AND NEEDS OF REGULATORS
FOR DATA --
AND COMPLY --
AND NOW WHAT WE'RE NOT HEARING
THAT FROM.
THE DEPARTMENT BUT AS WELL AYE
AYE UNDER AND THAT THEY'RE
HAVING DIFFICULTIES GETTING DATA --
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY FROM HOME --
BUT WITH THE KINDS OF
PROTECTIONS THAT CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE --
PROVIDES --
WE ROUTINELY PROVIDE DATA THAT.
THE COMPANIES ROUTINELY PROVIDE
DATA -- TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION. TO CARBON TO DTS SEE --
AND IF IT'S A CASE OF OF
COMPANIES THAT ARE NO BETTER
THAN -- THEN
WE ARE INTERESTED IN.
CRAP -- I
MISTER JACOB FINAL YEAR.
YOU PUT FOR THE WEST THAT YOU
DON'T THINK RIGHT NOW IT'S TIME
FOR MORE LEGISLATION I THINK.
HAVING READ THE THE REPORT THAT
DOCTOR SOLOMON WROTE WE DO THINK
IT IS TIME.
BUT THERE WILL BE A LONG
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND WE WILL
CERTAINLY LISTEN TO THE INDUSTRY --
WHAT DO I DO AND I THINK I WAS
SAYING HE DOESN'T WANT%
LEGISLATIVE ONE OFFS?
THE HE HE HE WHAT HE WANTED THAT
HE SUPPORTED THE SORT OF THE
PROCESS OF THE DEPARTMENT MAKING
DECISIONS.
RATHER I'D RATHER THAN HAVING
THE LEGISLATURE COME IN AND ASK
FOR INDIVIDUAL CHEMICAL BANDS IS
THAT RIGHT I THINK WHAT I THINK
WHAT WE'RE CONCERNED WITH IS.
THIS.
YOU KNOW THIS [inaudible]
AT DR WILSON'S REPORT ORIGINATED
WITH THESE TWO COMMITTEES --
AND A REQUEST --
WHICH AS WE UNDERSTAND IT AND I
WASN'T AROUND --
AT THE TIME THAT REQUEST WHEN IN --
WAS -- BORN
AT LEAST IN PART SENSE OF A
BARRAGE OF OF CHEMICAL BILL'S
INDIVIDUAL BILLS YES.
AND OF THE FACT THAT HAPHAZARD
THAT GIVEN THE IMPERATIVES THAT
YOU GUYS WORK UNDER --
IT WAS A DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO JUSTICE TO THEM
IN THE SENSE.
THAT WE WERE FINDING --
OURSELVES.
EXPECTED TO DELIVER A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE PERSPECTIVE.
ONLINE --
CHEMICALS AND WHAT WE'RE TRADING
OFF -- WE AS
THE CHEMICAL MANUFACTURERS --
HAVE A STAKE OBVIOUSLY IN.
IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE TRADE OFFS THAT
ARE OUT THERE --
BUT I THINK THAT'S BEEN --
TO WE DON'T WANT TO SEE
[inaudible]
ROUTE RECREATED.
THAT WOULD END UP ATTRACTING
FOLKS AS WAYS OF BYPASSING.
THE INITIAL REVIEW PROCESSES OF
THIS REGULATION --
BUT IF.
YOU KNOW WE WE ARE OPEN TO
DISCUSSING.
THE RANGE OF ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN TALKED ABOUT HERE.
AND IF THE CONCLUSION OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS IS THAT THE ONLY
REMEDY FOR THIS IS IN FACT --
STRATEGICALLY --
PLACED LEGISLATION THEN.
THAT THAT'S WHAT WILL BE.
OUR SHOWS SENATOR ALLEN HAS A
VERY IMPORTANT MEETING KEPT TO I
WILL -- BE A
HOT MONITORING THE REST OF THE
DISCUSSION AND THEN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT --
SHOW S. AS I WAS GOING TO SAY TO
YOU MISTER JACOB --
WHEN WE DO BRING LEGISLATION
FORWARD I WOULD JUST ASK YOU TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE DETAILS OF IT?
AND YOU KNOW IF YOU THINK IT'S
DUPLICATIVE.
FINE BUT YOU KNOW TELL US WHERE
GOING TOO FAR WE'RE NOT FAR
ENOUGH AND JUST TALK TO US ABOUT
THE DETAILS OF WHAT WE'RE DOING.
OKAY THAT'S ALL WE ASK AND THAT
THERE WILL BE LEGISLATION COMING
FORWARD --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR I I
WANTED TO ASK A ESPECIALLY SOME
OF THE THE ADVOCATES OF A OF
ELIMINATING TOXIC CHEMICALS FIRM --
FROM THE CONSUMER MARKET
[inaudible]
THE WHAT IF ANY SITUATIONS TO
SEE WHERE YOU KNOW WE WE'VE
HEARD TESTIMONY ABOUT HOW THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM IS
SUPPOSED TO AVOID THESE.
THESE ONE OFF TYPE APPROACHES
THE THE WORKABLE APPROACHES AS
THE DUTY --
DTS SEE A DIRECTOR INDICATED BUT
ARE THERE --
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE SITUATIONS
WHERE YOU THINK --
YOU KNOW THEY WOULD BE JUSTIFIED
THAT THE THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
JUST TOO SLOW AND THAT.
TO AND THAT --
GONNA WE NEED --
TO YOU KNOW MAKE EXCEPTIONS
GRAHAM. TO TO GOOD A ADDRESS
SPECIFIC CHEMICALS --
BUT LET ME MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION LATE BUT
IF YOU'RE ASKING WHETHER THERE'S
ROOM FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO ACT
WE DEFINITELY THINK SO --
AN EXAMPLE IS THE FLAME
RETARDANT BILL FROM LAST YEAR
WHICH PROHIBITED THE USE OF
FLAME RETARDANT CHEMICALS BROAD
CLASSES OF THEM IN FURNITURE
CHILDREN'S PRODUCTS AND MATTRESS
PHONE.
AND WITH THEIR THEIR EVIDENCE
WAS PRETTY CLEAR THAT WERE NOT
NEEDED IN THESE PRODUCTS AND WE
THOUGHT IT WAS APPROPRIATE FOR
THE LEGISLATORS ACTED DID NOT
NEED UP EXTENSIVE ALTERNATES
ANALYSIS PROCESS IN THAT
SCENARIO --
BUT IT'S STILL CLASS APPROACH WE
FULLY SUPPORT THAT CLASS
APPROACH OKAY I HOPE THAT HELPS
ANSWER THE QUIESCENT.
BUT THEN I WOULD JUST ADD THAT
WE ABSOLUTELY THINK THERE'S A
ROLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND I
AND I YOU KNOW IS AS IMPORTANT
AS PROJECT THIS PROGRAM IS AND
AS LONG AS IT'S SORT OF TAKEN TO
GET UP TO SPEED.
YEAH IN THE MEANTIME WE'RE BEING
EXPOSED TO CHEMICALS THAT ARE
JUST REALLY PROBLEMATIC AND
REALLY --
ARE HARMING PEOPLE AND SO.
WE NEED THE LEGISLATURE TO ACT
IN SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE
THE FLAME RETARDANT LEGISLATION
YOU KNOW WE'VE BROUGHT A LOT OF
FUN.
DISCLOSURE BILLS TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO WHICH HELPS NOT
JUST THE PROGRAM BUT CONSUMERS
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S IN THEIR
PRODUCTS WE WORKED ON THE CLEAN
PRODUCT.
BILL TOGETHER WE WORKED ON A
SALON PRODUCT BILL AS I
MENTIONED WE HAVE SOME FRAGRANCE
LEGISLATION COMING --
BUT WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO SEE IT
IS THE LEGISLATURE SIMPLY TO SAY
WE CAN'T TOUCH CHEMICAL
REGULATION BECAUSE THIS PROGRAM
EXISTS BECAUSE AS WE'VE HEARD.
THERE'S NO WAY THIS PROGRAM CAN
DEAL WITH THE FULL ARRAY OF
ISSUES OUT THERE RIGHT THANK YOU
CAN JUST ADD ONE QUICK POINT ON
THAT VERY POINT WHICH IS THAT
THERE ARE OVER.
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND CHEMICALS AN
ACTIVE USING COVERS AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND THAT HAVE BEEN USING
COVERS AT SOME POINT IN TIME.
YOU KNOW EVEN IF THE PROGRAM
WERE -- TO
YOU KNOW WORK AT FALL BREAK
ADDRESS ALL THOSE HANDS A
CHEMICAL SO THERE'S CLEARLY ROOM
FOR ACTION FROM BOTH PARTIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CURRENT
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT --
I THINK IT THEN IT IS TIME TO
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE --
I LEARNED QUITE A BIT TODAY
THANK YOU AND THIS WILL
DEFINITELY HAVE IMPACT ON THE
LEGISLATION THAT'S BROUGHT
FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT HOW MANY PEOPLE WOULD
LIKE TO DO PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO I SEE [inaudible]
TWO FOUR SIX EIGHT TEN DOZEN
[inaudible] FIFTEEN TWENTY ALL
RIGHT -- I'D
LIKE YOU TO TRY AND LIMIT
YOURSELF TO ABOUT A MINUTE OR
SAID BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO FINISH
THIS AT FIVE O'CLOCK.
AND THERE'S ONLY TWO OF US --
MEMBERS HERE SO.
IF YOU CAN --
I'M WILLING TO GIVE ME A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME IF YOU REALLY NEED
IT BUT IF YOU CAN DO AND AMEND
THAT THAT BE GREAT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBER.
JULIE MALON OWSKI BALA BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
FIRST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU I'M
SURE EVERYONE BEHIND ME IS GOING
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING.
WE THINK LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
PERIODIC REVIEW IS HEALTHY FOR
THE PROGRAM IMPROVEMENTS CAN BE
MADE --
WANTED JUST MAKE CLEAR TO THAT
THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
ITS MEMBERS HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN
THIS PROGRAM FROM PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO LIMITATION AND IN
FACT YOU KNOW OUR BEFORE DTS SEE
RIGHT NOW.
WITH -- OF
CHEMICALS OF CONCERN --
WE ARE PUTTING ALL OUR COMMENTS
ACTUALLY IN WRITING WILL DELIVER
TO THE COMMITTEE SO YOU CAN SEE
THAT MORE DETAIL BUT WE JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT --
JUST ONE THING IN PARTICULAR AND
THAT'S BEEN RENTAL IN RELATION
TO THE ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS --
YOU HEARD A LOT ABOUT THAT TODAY
ACTUALLY REFERENCE THAT YOU KNOW
MAYBE THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR IMPROVEMENT WE THINK THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVEMENT
THE ALTERNATES ANALYSIS.
SOME COMPLIANCE FLEXIBILITY HE
TALKED ABOUT STRATEGIC OFFRAMP
WE LIKE TO BE A PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION AND AS WELL AS ANY
OTHER BILL THAT'S INTRODUCED
REFORM THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU.
CAN I CAN GUARANTEE MISMATCH.
BALANESCU BALL THAT YOU WILL BE
PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
GO RIGHT AHEAD.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
AS WELL FOR HOSTING THIS JOINED
ME DOWN HEARING MY NAME IS PAUL
AND I AM THE AIR IN TALKS IS
POLICY ANALYST WITH PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES.
AND THE COALITION COORDINATOR
FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR HEALTHY AND
GREEN ECONOMY --
FOR OVER A TWENTY YEAR PERIOD
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN ABLE WITH
TEXAS POLICY AND WE HAVE
DELIVERED A CONSISTENT MESSAGE
THAT WITH MOST MOVE --
UPSTREAM AND WE MUST FOCUS ON
AND DEEPEN OUR COMMITMENT TO
PUTTING HEALTH AND PREVENTION OF
THE CENTER OF TAXIS POLICY --
FROM THE OUTSIDE OF THE GREEK
YOU MISTER PROGRAM --
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATES
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROGRAM
NOT MOVING FAST AND FOURTEEN OF
AB STRING.
BECAUSE A GREEK MISTER PROGRAM
WAS BE SEEN FROM A CONTEXT OF AN
AGENCY THAT IS FAILING TO MEET
ITS MISSION ON ALL THREE COUNTS.
AS A FORMER DTC DIRECTOR ONCE
SAID THE JOB OF THE T. C. IS.
TO LOOK AT THE PAT THE SINS OF
THE PAST ADDRESS CURRENCIES AND
PREVENT DISEASE OF THE FUTURE.
THE DISEASE OF DEALING WITH THE
LEGACY OF WATER IN AIR AND AND
WE AGREE THAT THE PACE OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SECOND WAS
FACE OF A CONSUMER PRODUCTS IS
BEING TO SLOW.
THE CALIFORNIA'S OVERALLS
EFFORTS TO FOSTER RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TO FIELD INNOVATION
GAP HAS NOT BEEN ENOUGH --
THE GREEK CAM SUBURBAN COULD
PROVIDE A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHIFT TOWARDS A CRADLE TO CRADLE
ECONOMY AND SHOULD BE PART OF
OUR LARGEST EFFORTS.
TO DETECT THE CART DETOXIFY TO
CARBONIZED IN THE MARKET AS OUR
ECONOMY BUT THAT WILL ONLY
HAPPEN WITH A STRONG COMMITMENT
WITH THE STRONG LEADERSHIP AND
WITH COMPLETE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT ANYMORE SOME POORLY
AGENCY ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE GREEK MISTER PROGRAM LACKS A
COHERENT --
LONG TERM STRATEGY FUNDING AND
THE LINKAGE TO OTHER DTC
PROGRAMS LIKE POLLUTION
PREVENTION AND PERMITTING.
ADDITIONALLY FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM SHOULD NOT COME AT THE
EXPENSE OF OTHER PROGRAMS WHICH
IS SPEAKS TO THE NEED TO FIX THE
TIAS HE'S OVERALL FUNDING FEE
STRUCTURE.
ON THE SERVER GOES WHAT PRODUCTS
REGULATION DTZ HAS FOCUSED ON
THE CHEMICALS BASED LIST.
OF FOCUS ON HIS POTENTIAL TO
CAUSE HARM YET LITTLE HAS BEEN
DONE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE AND
THE URGENCY TOM YOU YOU'VE GONE
OVER TO MEN OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR EACH
SHARE.
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
MY NAME IS MIKE WILSON AND THE
NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF HEALTH
PROGRAMS FOR THE BLUE GREEN
ALLIANCE.
WERE A PARTNERSHIP OF THE
NATION'S TEN LARGEST LABOR
UNIONS AND SIX ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS WITH ABOUT FIFTEEN
MILLION MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS.
LAST YEAR I MET ONE ON ONE WITH
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN WHO WERE
HIGHLY EXPOSED TO TOXIC
CHEMICALS AT ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST CELEBRATED ADVANCED CLEAN
ENERGY MANUFACTURING SITES.
THAT EXPERIENCE TO HELP ME
UNDERSTAND THAT GREEN CHEMISTRY
AND CLEAN ENERGY ARE TWO SIDES
OF THE SAME COIN REITERATING --
DOCTOR MULTI HOLES CLOSING
COMMENT YOUNG PEOPLE WERE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY BUILDING
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE.
ALL WORKING WITH CHEMICALS THAT
ARE CLASSIFIED BY OSHA IS
PRESUMED HUMAN REPRODUCTIVE
TOXICANTS.
MEANING THAT THEY CAN AFFECT
FERTILITY SEXUAL FUNCTION AND
PREGNANCY AND CAUSE IRREPARABLE
DAMAGE DURING FETAL DEVELOPMENT.
THE PEOPLE I SPOKE WITH WERE
COMPLAINING OF NOSE BLEEDS AND
MIGRAINE HEADACHES BUT THESE
WERE JUST SYMPTOMS OF EXPOSURE
THEY WERE NOT AWARE OF THE
LIFELONG CONSEQUENCES OF THESE
CHEMICAL EXPOSURES POST FOR THE
TO THEIR HEALTH AND HEALTH THEIR
FAMILIES.
THERE ARE NINETEEN MILLION
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA TO HANDLE
THE MAJORITY OF THE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION POUNDS OF
CHEMICAL PRODUCTS THAT ARE SOLD
EACH DAY IN THE STATE. 98% ARE
FORMULATED WITH OIL GLOBAL
CHEMICAL PRODUCTION IS DOUBLING
EVERY TWENTY FOUR YEARS.
WE CAN BE PROUD THE CALIFORNIA
HAS CREATED A GENUINE CLIMATE
ACTION PORTFOLIO WITH CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS AT SIX POINT ONE
BILLION FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
ON THE OTHER HAND ARE GREEN
CHEMISTRY INVESTMENTS ARE BARELY
A SHADOW IN COMPARISON AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM DOCTORS WEIGH INS AND
SOLOMON --
DID YOU THINK OF GREEN CHEMISTRY
AND CLEAN ENERGY AS TWO SIDES OF
THE SAME COIN IS INTERDEPENDENT.
YOU COULD DO A GREAT SERVICE TO
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION BY
SHINING A LIGHT ON THIS LINKAGE
AND TAKING ACTION TO IMPLEMENT
DR SOLOMON'S RECOMMENDATIONS AND
DRIVE REAL RESOURCES TO DO TSC.
COMMENSURATE WITH THE SCALE AND
PACE OF THE PROBLEM THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A DOCTOR
WILSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISETTE FAMILY
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS I FORMALLY WORKED FOR
TWELVE YEARS FOR AN NGO IN
EUROPE ON REACH SO I JUST HAVE
TO COMMENTS ABOUT DEADLINES AND
ENFORCEMENT.
FIRST FULL YES THERE ARE
DEADLINES IN THE EUROPEAN SYSTEM
IT'S A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT.
SET UP BUT THERE ARE DEFINITELY
DEADLINES AND THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES FOR MISSING THOSE
DEADLINES.
SECOND OF ALL WITH RESPECT TO
ENFORCE OF ENFORCEMENT THE
RANGES ACROSS THE DIFFERENT
PROCEDURES WITHIN THE EUROPEAN
SYSTEM.
ANYTHING FROM FINES PUT BY
MEMBER STATES TO THE COMPANIES
WITHIN THEIR GEOGRAPHIC AREA FOR
NOT COMPLYING WITH THE LITTLE.
TOO THE EUROPEAN CHEMICALS
AGENCY WITHDRAWING THE
REGISTRATION THAT ALLOWS THE
CHEMICAL TO BE LEGALLY ON THE
MARKET AND THAT'S FOR NOT
FULFILLING THE CONDITIONS OF THE
REACH SYSTEM.
IF YOU HAVE FURTHER DETAIL
QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
ANSWERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HEALTH
HELPFUL TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND AGAIN THANK
YOU IT'S IT'S WONDERFUL TO BE IN
A ROOM FULL OF SO MANY SMART
PEOPLE TRYING TO MOVE SOMETHING
FORWARD HERE.
ARE MY NAME IS ANDREA EVAN
TURNER I'M WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION I AM ALSO AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE MIND THE STORE
CAMPAIGN THAT DOCTOR MULVIHILL.
MENTIONED EARLIER IN HIS
TESTIMONY.
ARM I'M JUST GOING TO FOCUS ON
ONE THING THAT WE HAVE BEEN AS
AN ORGANIZATION INVOLVED AS WELL
AS OTHERS SINCE THE VERY
INCEPTION OF THIS PROGRAM FROM
THE PASSAGE OF THE ORIGINAL LAW
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS
AND BEYOND.
AND WE DO BELIEVE --
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE
REALIZED A LONG TIME AGO THAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO TREAT
OUR WAY OUT OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
PROBLEMS OR ARE HEALTH PROBLEMS.
AND WE NEED TO START GETTING TO
THE SOURCES AND WE THINK THAT
THIS PROGRAM IS THE INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM THE FRANKLY THE WHOLE
WORLD IS WATCHING TO SEE MOVE
FORWARD.
SO WE WANT TO SUPPORT THAT WE
THINK THE STAFF HAS STRUGGLED
THROUGH A LOT OF DIFFICULTY.
GROUND BREAKING EFFORTS AND HAVE
DONE VERY WELL BUT IT NEEDS TO
DO BETTER.
AND I JUST WANT TO FOCUS MY
COMMENTS A FAST TRACK OR THE
LEGISLATORS LEGISLATURE'S ROLE.
OUR FRUSTRATION HAS BEEN THAT
WHILE THIS SHOULD BE A
DELIBERATE PROCESS AS WE LOOK AT
SCIENCE AND AVOID REGRETTABLE
SUBSTITUTION IS AS YOU'VE HEARD
THERE ARE CASES WHERE IT'S VERY
CLEAR.
THAT PROGRAM --
THE PRODUCTS DON'T NEED CERTAIN
KINDS OF CHEMICALS IN THEM OR
THAT THERE ARE.
WELL VETTED SAFER ALTERNATIVES
OUT THERE THAT HAVE BEEN
ANALYZED AND WE DO THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE A STRUCTURE FOR
EITHER THE LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATURE TO ACT OR FOR
DETAILS SEAT TO LOOK AT THE DATA
THAT'S BEEN OUT THERE AND TO
MAKE A REGULATORY DECISION.
AS LONG AS THAT HAS BEEN VETTED
SO WE'RE NOT TRYING TO MOVE AWAY
FROM SCIENCE WE'RE TRYING TO
MOVE TOWARD EFFICIENCY SO WE CAN
PUT THE RESOURCES WHERE THINGS
AREN'T QUITE AS CLEAR.
I STARTED MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE.
IN YOU REALLY HAVE.
TO YOUR AT TWO MINUTES OKAY THEN
I WILL AND THERE THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR USEFUL COMMENTS
[inaudible]
NEXT.
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING CHAIRMAN
QUIRK.
I'M DAVIS BALL TO SAN FRANCISCO
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY WE COLLABORATED
WITH DR SOLOMON --
IN THE PHASE OF HER REPORT IN
THE DISSEMINATION AND PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT WITH STAKEHOLDERS --
PRIMARILY THE LEGISLATURE.
CALIFORNIA'S POSITION TO EXTEND
ITS BROAD LEADERSHIP ON HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENT POLICY OF BY
PROMOTING HEALTHY GREEN
CHEMISTRY INITIATIVES AT SUNSET
HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS THROUGHOUT
OUR ECONOMY.
OUR LEADERSHIP IN THE STATE IS
EVER MORE IMPORTANT NOW IS
FEDERAL LEADERSHIP HAS COLAPSED.
THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM WHICH YOU HEARD ABOUT
TODAY.
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO DRIVE
PROBLEMATIC CHEMICALS OUT OF
CONSUMER PRODUCTS IN LARGE
MEASURE BY SENDING SIGNALS TO
THE MARKET PLACE THAT FORWARD
THINKING ENVIRONMENTALLY
CONSCIOUS ENTERPRISES WILL
RESPOND.
TO THESE KINDS OF VOLUNTARY
MARKET SHIFTS CAN PREVENT HARM
BUILD OUR ECONOMY AND
IMPORTANTLY REDUCE THE
EXPENDITURE OF STATE RESOURCES
TO RUN THE PROGRAM.
BUT TO REACH ITS POTENTIAL THE
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM
SIMPLY MUST GET MORE CHEMICAL
CONSUMER PRODUCTS IN THE
PIPELINE. TO THE MESSAGE GOES
OUT TO MANY MORE SUPPLIES FIND
SAY FOR REPLACEMENT CHEMICALS OR
REMOVE THEM IF THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARY.
AND FOR THOSE ENTITIES THAT
DON'T CHANGE THEY MUST FACE
MEANINGFUL REGULATORY
CONSEQUENCES. TO OF DR SOLOMON'S
RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD GO A LONG
WAY TO SPEEDING THE PROGRAM THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT. ONE THE
PROGRAM MUST HAVE CLEAR
AUTHORITY TO COMPEL
MANUFACTURERS TO DISCLOSE
INGREDIENTS IN THE PRODUCTS AND
TWO THERE SHOULD BE AN EXPEDITED
PATHWAY TO REDUCING EXPOSURE TO
TOXIC CHEMICALS. FOR WHICH THERE
ARE ALREADY WELL STUDIED SAFER
ALTERNATIVES THANKS AGAIN TO
BOTH COMMITTEES AND TO STAFF FOR
THIS IMPORTANT CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU AS WELL.
HELLO MY NAME IS KATHERINE
HOUSTON I'M WITH THE UNITED
STEELWORKERS DISTRICT TWELVE IN
THE CHAIR OF THE WOMEN OF STEEL.
I'M I'M HERE TO TALK ON BEHALF
OF THE WORKERS AND SO ON THE
UNITED STEELWORKERS IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED IN THAT WE HAVE
WORKERS THAT ARE IN JUST ABOUT
EVERY INDUSTRY THAT'S CONSIDERED
HIGH HAZARD.
AND SO WE HAVE EVERYTHING FROM
CAR WASH WORKERS TO UPHOLSTERY
WORKERS --
TO HIGH RISE WINDOW CLEANERS WE
WORK IN MANUFACTURING
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE WE MAKE
EVERYTHING FROM HOSE CLAMPS AND
CANS TO WHITE BOARDS AND
PARTITIONS AND SO WE ALSO
MANUFACTURE CEMENT.
STEEL.
AND GLASS AND MORE WE REPRESENT
95% OF THE WORKERS IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY.
AND WE ALSO 25% OF OUR DISTRICT
IS IN HEALTH CARE WITH THE ANTIS
PARAMEDICS HOSPITALS AND NURSES.
AND SO WE HAVE ALL OF THESE
WORKERS THAT ARE BEING EXPOSED
ON A CONTINUAL BASIS.
THROUGH THE VARIOUS ELEMENTS AND
SAID -- NOT
ONLY IS IT THAT THEY'RE USING
SOMETHING ON IN ORDER TO CREATE
THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY NEED TO
MANUFACTURE.
AND SELL WITH THE SAFETY AND THE
HEALTH OF OUR WORKERS AND ALL
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES IS OF
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE TO US WE DO
ALL WE CAN TO EDUCATE THEM TO
SAFEGUARD THEM AND MAKE THOSE
WORK ENVIRONMENTS.
AS TOXIC FREE AS POSSIBLE.
SO THAT BEING SAID WE ARE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THEY COME
INTO CONTACT WITH ON A DAILY
BASIS IN THEIR JOBS --
WHAT WE REPRESENTED THE WORKERS --
THAT OF THE TO POP FACILITY THAT
MANUFACTURED TEFLON WE WORKED
VERY HARD AS WE KNOW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO ELIMINATE PEOPLE.
AND SO ON WE'VE BEEN ENGAGED IN
THIS IN A LONG TIME BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND HOW CRITICAL AND
CRUCIAL IT IS.
AND SO FOR US WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM IN THE GOALS
THAT IT SEEKS TO TO ACHIEVE BUT
WE WORRY ABOUT THE INGREDIENTS
SAFETY AND DISCLOSURE.
WE WORRY ABOUT THE THOROUGH DATA
COLLECTION THE MONITORING AND
ANALYSIS AND WE NEED THE
STREAMLINE PROCESSES WITH VERY
SET GUIDELINES TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO
WORKERS THE WORKERS CAN'T WAIT
THEY GETTING SICK AND THEY JUST
CAN'T WAIT.
THANK YOU.
GREAT TO HEAR FROM WOMEN OF
STEEL AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CONCERN.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CATHERINE
PORTER WITH SAN FRANCISCO
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND ALSO THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY
NAIL SALON COLLABORATIVE --
EVERY DAY NAIL AND HAIR SALON
WORKERS ARE EXPOSED TO A VARIETY
OF PRODUCTS A WITH CHEMICALS
LINKED TO CANCER REPRODUCTIVE
AND RESPIRATORY HARMON OTHER
CHRONIC HARM.
THEIR AT THESE JOBS SIX SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK SOMETIMES AS MANY AS
TEN HOURS TODAY --
WE DO KNOW THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS OR ON THE RADAR AND DTS
C. IN THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM --
BUT IT'S BEEN ON THERE REYES AND
FIFTEEN CLEARLY --
ADDED TO RESOURCES SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE --
BOLSTER STAFF --
IMPROVE THEIR ABILITY TO CALL IN
DATA UP WITH GREATER ENFORCEMENT
AND PENALTIES --
WE ARE CONFIDENT WOULD HELP WITH
ANY ISSUES THAT THERE MAY BE
WITH -- THE
PACE OF THE PROGRAM --
WE URGE LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO
BRING THESE IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM.
BUT WE ALSO AGREE WITH OTHER
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE SAID THERE
ARE THERE IS THERE ARE TIMES AND
PLACES FOR THE LEGISLATURE. TO
TAKE DIRECT ACTION ON SOME OF
THE WORST CHEMICALS IN PRODUCTS
INCLUDING COSMETIC PRODUCTS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
HI THANK YOU MY NAME IS JAN
JACKSON I'M WITH THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND THE
TOXICS REDUCTION PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR THE CITY'S DEPARTMENT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND JUST THE FACT THAT I HAVE
THE TOXICS REDUCTION PROGRAM
MANAGER ROLE INDICATES THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL -- TO
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S SUPER
IMPORTANT FOR THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WE HAVE A HUGE STAKE
AND THE VIABILITY AND SUCCESS OF
THE PROGRAM.
AND SO WE SUPPORT MANY OF THE
PUBLIC PROCESSES WE ATTENDED
HEARINGS WE PROVIDE INFORMATION
ABOUT.
PRODUCTS THAT WE'VE RESEARCHED
I'M THINGS THAT I THINK THAT ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT FIRST.
YOU ALL HAVE A ROLE AS MANY OF
HAVE SAID IN ENSURING THAT THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE PROGRAM ARE
CLEAR.
THAT THEY HAVE DATA COLIN AND
FORTY SO THAT THEY CAN BRING IN
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED.
AND IN ADDITION I WOULD SAY YOU
ALL HAVE A ROLE IN LEGISLATING
SO WHEN THERE IS CLEAR EVIDENCE
THAT ANY CHEMICALS PROBLEMATIC
AND THERE'S CLEAR ALTERNATIVES.
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN LAST YEAR YOU
WERE THEY AT THE LEGISLATION IS
INTRODUCED REGARDING FOREIGN ANY
CHEMICALS IN FOOD PACKAGING.
WE KNOW THAT ABOUT 4260% FOOD
PACKAGING.
IS NOT FLUORINATED SO CLEARLY
THE MARKET COMPARE PRODUCTS
WITHOUT THIS CHEMICALS AND SO
IT'S YOUR ROLE TO TAKE ACTION
WHEN WE KNOW THE EARTH THERE ARE
SAFER ALTERNATIVES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE TAKING
LEADERSHIP IN THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADAM RIGHTLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE --
WE WANTED TO STATE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDERS TODAY --
I THINK THE ONE BIG TAKE AWAY
THAT -- I
HEARD TODAY WAS EVERYONE
SUPPORTS THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM WE ALL WANT TO
SEE IT IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY --
THE EXPEDIENCY FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE DO --
VALUE THE OUTCOME BEING CORRECT.
AND I'LL JUST SAY --
ONE DISAGREEMENT WE HAVE IS THE
RIGHT BACK TO THE PRE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT MODEL OF ONE OFF
LEGISLATIVE BAND WE DON'T THINK
THE POLITICIZATION OF CHEMICAL --
OR PRODUCT BANDS IS THE RIGHT
WAY TO ACHIEVE THE OUTCOME OF
BEING CORRECT WE THINK THE SAFE
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM WHICH
ALLOWS THE SCIENTISTS SO TO
SPEAK TO DICTATE WHICH IS SAFE
AND WHICH IS NOT SAY PRODUCT. TO
IS THE RIGHT FORM A WE AGREE WE
COULD IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
EXPEDIENCY AND SO I THINK JUST
GETTING THAT RIGHT IS IS REALLY
CRUCIAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT WAS
VERY HELPFUL.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
DON KEPT KEY WITH MCCUE CAP CAN
ASSOCIATES HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION.
ALSO AS ARE THE CO CHAIR OF THE
AD HOC SWEAT EQUITY COALITION
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY ALLIANCE A
SEEMS HERE WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER
OF THE U. G. CA --
SHORTLY AROUND THE TIME THAT THE
LEGISLATION WAS PASSED IN --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT NOT ONLY A C.
M. T. A AND IT'S AN INDIVIDUAL
MANUFACTURING MEMBERS AND BEEN
DEEPLY ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS --
DURING THE LEGISLATIVE
DISCUSSIONS AS WELL AS AS PART
OF THE PREPARATIONS IN
DEVELOPMENT OF THE REGULATIONS
ABA CONTINUE TO BE DEEPLY
ENGAGED ON WITH THE DEPARTMENT --
TO AS WELL AS THROUGH THEIR OWN
SUSTAINABILITY EFFORTS --
I WOULD JUST OFFER TO YOU THAT
AND DID YOU SEE A SAYS I TO BE
SOLUTIONS ORIENTED IN PROACTIVE
IN THEIR FEEDBACK ON THESE
ISSUES AND REALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO BEING A RESOURCE ON BEHALF OF
OUR MEMBERS ARE TO YOU --
INTO YOUR COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND CERTAINLY ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH DTS CD
ON ONGOING IMPLEMENTATION THE
PROGRAMS WITHOUT THANK YOU LOOK
FOR TO BE IN RESEARCH THANK YOU
MISS KEPT THE FOR OFFERING YOUR
HELP.
GOOD LATE AFTERNOON I'M BILL
ALLEY --
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP -- WE
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM WE THINK THE
STAFF IS DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN DO -- TO
GET THIS STUFF DONE AND AND
PROTECT HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT --
BUT IF THE PROGRAM'S WORKING THE
WAY IT WAS DESIGNED TO DO I
THINK WE NEED PROGRAM CHANGES I
KNOW THINGS AFTER YOU DELIVER IT
DELIBERATE COULD SCIENCE AT
CETERA BUT IF WE DON'T GO FASTER
THINGS WILL TAKE TEN TWENTY
YEARS BEFORE WE GET.
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS SO --
THAT'S OUR BIG CONCERN ON THE
ROLE OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
TWENTY ELEVEN WHEN THE BPA IN
BABY BOTTLE BILL CAME THROUGH --
THE DIRECTOR DTS AT THAT TIME
WROTE A LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE
WAS TO THE LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY
SAYING WE SUPPORT THE BILL NOT.
NEUTRAL BUT WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THEY SAID BECAUSE IF YOU THE
LEGISLATURE FEELS LIKE SOME
PORTENT TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
MORE EXPEDITIOUSLY THEN WE CAN
GET TO GO FOR IT. NINE NO THEY
WEREN'T REGULATIONS THEN YEAH
AND THINGS WERE LAID OUT AS WELL
THEY ARE NOW BUT I THINK THE
MESSAGE THEY'RE STILL HOLDS.
AND I THINK WHEN THE QUESTIONS
WHEN YOU HAVE CLEAR EVIDENCE TO
ACT IN THE LESSER TO SAY IS
DROOLING SCIENCE WHAT WE DID
WITH BPA WE HAD.
AT THAT TIME TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE ABSTRACTS TO THAT SHOWED
HARM AND THE INDUSTRY AT TWENTY
FIVE SHOWING NO HARM THEY WERE
ALL INDUSTRY FUNDED SO WE FELT
WE HAD AN OVERWHELMINGLY CLEAR
CASE YOU MAY NOT GET A IN EVERY.
A CIRCUMSTANCE LIKE THAT BUT WE
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD WAIT TILL
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY CLEAR
EVIDENCE OR WE COULD WAIT
FOREVER.
AS WE KNOW SMOKING TOBACCO WENT
ON FOR SOME THIRTY YEARS AND
EVEN TODAY SOMEONE ARGUED
DOESN'T CAUSE CANCER SUS A
STRONG CORE CORRELATION SO YOU
WON'T GET THAT ARGUMENT HERE
YEAH I KNOW THAT.
BUT IN TERMS OF GETTING CLEAR
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE CAN ACT I
KNOW PEOPLE DON'T LIKE THE
SINGLE CHEMICAL BAND BILLS
YOU'LL VOTE ON A BILL.
TO AFFECT THE TAKE OF DUNGEON IS
CRAB ONE DAY YOU'RE NOT MARINE
BIOLOGIST YET YOU'RE GETTING
INFORMATION FROM FISH AND
WILDLIFE BIOLOGISTS USING THEY
MUST BE RIGHT.
BUT WE CAN PRESENT YOU TO
INFORMATION THAT SOME CHEMICALS
ARE REALLY BAD FOR YOU AND MOST
SCIENTISTS WHO AREN'T BEING PAID
BY THE INDUSTRY TO SAY SO WILL
AGREE.
SO WE THINK THERE WILL BE A ROLE
WE'RE NOT SAYING WE'RE GONNA
OPEN THE FLOODGATES ON SINGLE
CHEMICAL BAND BILLS THIS ONE
ONLY THAT OPENING THEIR THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
THE END OFASK IS SOME POLICY
MANAGER FOR THE CALIFORNIA FROM
TO SCIENCE AND I'M HERE. TO
REALLY ACOSTA MY COMMENTS EVER
MADE BY WHENEVER MEMBER ANY
PATIENTS --
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY THE LA CHAPTER IN
THE SPECIFICALLY JUST
EMPHASIZING THAT LOOKING AT THIS
PROGRAM IS REALLY CRITICAL.
ON BUT ALSO HAVING OF
UNDERSTANDING BOTH FOR THE SAME
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM IN THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM LOOKING
AT THROUGH MORE HOW WE CAN
ACTUALLY INVENTS A MOMENT SUCH
AS THE POLICIES IN THOSE
PROGRAMS WERE LOOKING AT THE PRE
SHUFFLING.
BUT ALSO BE MINDFUL THERE'S A
LARGER CONVERSATION HAPPENING
ABOUT HE'S HE'S TTC OVERALL IN
THE REFORM THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
TO REALLY LOOKING AT HOW THIS
PROGRAM CAN ACTUALLY FIT IN THAT
CONVERSATION UP WHEN WE ACTUALLY
LOOK AT HOW DO WE LOOK AT THE
ENTIRE DEPARTMENT AND THE
DIFFERENT.
THIS COMMITTEE I KNOW WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ON
REALLY CLOSE IN THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS THANK YOU.
SO I I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO TESTIFIED AND ALSO ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO GAVE ME THEIR PUBLIC
COMMENTS --
THE I'M SURE THERE WILL BE BILLS
LIES THERE WAS LAST YEAR ON THE
BANNING OF THE FLAME RETARDANT
MATERIALS ON THE GROUNDS THAT
THEY WEREN'T NEEDED WHEN YOU GET
THAT KIND OF ADVICE FROM THE
FIREFIGHTERS IT'S HARD TO IGNORE.
ON THE OTHER HAND I ALSO HEARD
FROM PEOPLE IN THE TESTIMONY
HERE INCLUDING PEOPLE WHO ARE
ADVOCATES ARE.
CONCERNED ABOUT BREAST CANCER.
THAT YOU HAVE A PROBLEM IF YOU
BAND B. P. A AND THEN THERE'S A
SUBSTITUTION OF B. PS I'M NOT
EVEN SURE WHAT THAT IS BUT THEY
SAID IT'S JUST AS DANGEROUS SO I
THINK.
YOU KNOW IT'S ONE THING TO SAY
WE DON'T WANT ANY CHEMICAL.
THAT'S PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
BUT YOU KNOW WHEN IT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING WHERE
WERE BANNING ONE CHEMICAL AND WE
MIGHT GET SOMETHING JUST AS BAD
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL.
AND THAT'S A MAJOR REASON WHY WE
NEED GREEN CHEMISTRY AND WHY WE
REALLY HAVE TO BE CAREFUL WHEN
WE LOOK AT INDIVIDUAL BILLS.
THAT WE ARE VERY CAREFUL --
SHE CHIU --
I WOULD SAY REFERRED THEM WHICH
ACCORDING TO THE TESTIMONY WE
HAD DE HERE TODAY.
THAT WE REFERRED THEM TO THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM TO
REALLY LOOK AT THE ALTERNATIVES --
PARTICULARLY FOR REALLY SURE
THAT'S A CHEMICAL THAT SHOULDN'T
BE SOMEWHERE.
THAT WOULD PUT IT TO THE HEAD OF
THE LINE FOR THE DEVS AND I
THINK THAT IS SOMETHING THAT.
IN MANY CASES IT WILL BE
IMPORTANT TO DO --
DIFFICULT CASES WHERE THERE'S
SCIENTIFIC UNCERTAINTY --
HOW DO WE INTEGRATE THAT INTO
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM
RATHER THAN MAKING IT A?
PRIORITY CHEMICAL HOW DO WE ASK
THEM.
SHOULD THIS BE A PRIORITY
CHEMICAL I'M NOT QUITE SURE YET
AND WE DON'T HAVE THE WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE PERHAPS.
COULD YOU COME UP.
OF SIR I KNOW YOU'RE IN CHARGE
OF THIS PROGRAM.
IF THE LEGISLATURE IS CONCERNED
THAT A CHEMICAL COULD BE HARMFUL.
BUT THEY'RE NOT READY YET TO SAY
FOR SURE IT IS IS THERE AWAY
YOUR PROGRAM CAN ADDRESS IT.
AND HOW WOULD WE CRAFT THAT
LEGISLATION. FOR THE FIRST AM I
JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT OUR
PROCESS OF SELECTING PRODUCTS
AND EVALUATING.
WHAT WE PUT IN OUR WORK PLAN AND
VALUING SPECIFIC CHEMICALS IS A
VERY OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
PROCESS IS SO EVERYONE'S WELCOME
TO PARTICIPATE THAT WHETHER
YOU'RE?
CARRYING A BILL YOUR WORK
REPRESENT ADVOCACY GROUP FOR AN
INDUSTRY REPRESENTED BECAUSE
SOMEONE ALLUDED TO WE SAY
INFORMATIONS ACQUIRE THE REAL
REALLY FOCUS ON GETTING GOOD
INFORMATION --
AND SO IF YOU HAVE A INFORMALLY
FORMALLY IF YOU PASS A BILL YOU
COULDN'T.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN FORCE US TO
LOOK AT SOMETHING AND AND OUR
PROCESS E CAN GIVE JUST GIVE US
A PETITION SO THERE'S A VARIETY
OF WAYS THAT YOU CAN.
WRITE YOUR CONCERNS KNOWN --
IN THE OKAY SO IF WE WERE TO
PASS A BILL BY.
AND WE WEREN'T SURE IT WAS A
PROBLEM IF IT'S A PROBLEM WE
SHOULD IF WE'RE SURE IT'S A
PROBLEM WE CAN MAKE IT A
PRIORITY PRODUCT.
INSTANTLY AND THEN YOU'RE GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT ALTERNATIVES IF
WE'RE NOT SURE WHAT DO WE SAY IN
THE BILL.
WHAT DO WE ASK YOU TO DO?
WELL I THINK IT MANY TIMES A
LEGISLATURE ASKED US TO
INVESTIGATE.
OR DO A STUDY ON SOMETHING AND
WE COULD DO THAT AND THERE'S
DIFFERENT ENTRY POINTS IN OUR
PROCESS ONE IS IN OUR WORK PLAN
YOU COULD ASK THAT WE PUT
SOMETHING IN A WORK PLAN.
CATEGORY OR CLASS OF PROP OF
CHEMICALS FOR EXAMPLE --
SO THAT'S ONE POINT IN THE
PROCESS AND AND ANOTHER POINT IS
WHEN WE ACTUALLY DETERMINE
SOMETHING IS A PRIORITY PRODUCT.
THAT FRANK DIRECTED US TO
LEGISLATION --
TO DO THAT WE COULD ADOPT THE
PARTY PRODUCT AND AS SOMEONE
POINTED OUT OKAY SO --
FOR THE CASE WHERE I'M TALKING
ABOUT WE'RE NOT SURE IT'S RIGHT.
THEN WE ASK YOU TO PUT IN YOUR
WORK PLAN.
I THINK THERE WOULD BE AN
APPROPRIATE PLACE TO LOOK
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE WE WE
IDENTIFY THOSE CATEGORIES
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
EVIDENCE OUT THERE IN ONE SHAPE.
OR ANOTHER TO ONE DEGREE OR
ANOTHER TO SUGGEST THIS IS AN
AREA THAT WARRANTS US LOOKING AT
IT.
THEN WE ADOPT OUR POLICY
PRIORITIES TO HELP US.
YOU KNOW FIFTY THOSE TO HUNDREDS
SOMETIMES THOUSANDS OF CATEGORY
OF PRODUCTS IN THAT CATEGORY --
BUT WE'RE GOING TO TELL YOU IT'S
PRIORITY PERIOD.
WELL WE MIGHT YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING IN MIND
BUT I'M JUST SAYING IF WE DID
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY I'D BE REMISS
IF I DIDN'T POINT OUT THAT.
YOU KNOW WE DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE RETAIN A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF DISCRETION IN
LOOKING AT OUR LIMITED RESOURCES
AND THE THINGS THAT OUR WORK
PLAN.
AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW ANY BILL
WE WOULD LOOK AT THAT ON ITS
MERIT AND EVALUATE ITS FISCAL
IMPACT AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I THINK WE'RE DONE.
AND I WANNA OUR WAITRESS --
I HAVE CLOSING REMARKS --
AS A REMINDER WILL KEEP THE
COMMITTEE RECORD OPEN FOR TWO
WEEKS TO FEBRUARY TWENTY SIX FOR
ADDITIONAL WRITTEN COMMENTS SOME
OF THE MORE PROMISED ALREADY --
SHOULD YOU STILL LIKE TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN PUBLIC COMMENT.
PLEASE CONTACT MY STAFF P.
ESTRADA SHE I UNDERSTOOD YOU
STAND UP.
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF MY STAFF.
AND SHE WILL DEFINITELY PUT THAT
IN A PLACE WERE WE CAN ALL TAKE
A LOOK AT IT --
ONCE AGAIN I HAVE I I I LEARNED
A LOT TODAY I THINK THIS IS
DEFINITELY GOING TO INFLUENCE
THE DIRECTION THAT WE GO AS WE
LOOK FOR REVISIONS TO THE
PROGRAM.
AND WE ARE GOING TO TRY AND
SPEED THINGS UP --
I DON'T THINK THERE'S MUCH
QUESTION ABOUT THAT PART OF IT
CAN BE RESOURCES OTHERS COULD BE.
TAKING A LOOK AT WELL VALIDATED
STUDIES WERE AND BRING A PRODUCT
MORE CLOSELY INTO.
A PRIORITY PRODUCT IF THERE'S
GOOD RESEARCH OUTSIDE HIS
APARTMENT.
THESE A VARIETY OF THINGS WHICH
WE WANT TO GET INPUT FROM FROM
BOTH INDUSTRY ACT ACADEMIA AND
OF COURSE THE DEPARTMENT ITSELF
AS WE LOCK.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN AND
I'M GOING TO CLOSE THE HEARING